AFTERNOON EVERYBODY WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
TODAY'S A VERY EXCITING DAY WE
WILL BE PRESENTING THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PLAN FIFTY
EIGHT THAT IS BEING PROPOSED-
ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE SENATE
AND THE- ASSEMBLY. THIS BUDGET
IS- ONE OF THE LARGEST OR THE
LARGEST IN THE STATE'S HISTORY-
A FULL FUND OF TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS A
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. IT'S GOT
RECORD RESERVE THAT FIVE
BILLION WITH A PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING AT NINETY SIX
BILLION. IN PARTICULAR THIS
BUDGET HAS REALLY. FOCUSED ON
THE CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN
REALLY HARDEST HIT BY THIS LAST
YEAR IN THIS PANDEMIC. FOCUSES
ON A SMALL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN HURTING I SPOKE WITH THE
SUCCESSFUL ON INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN NEED. OF TAX RELIEF IT
DEFINITELY FOCUSES ON OUR
SCHOOLS WHO HAVE HAD A VERY
VERY DIFFICULT YEAR. AND DIED%
REALLY DONE THEIR BEST THIS AS
BEST AS THEY COULD THROUGH
DISTANCE LEARNING AND TRYING TO
EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN. IT ALSO.
MAKES GREAT STRIDES IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT WE CAN INVEST IN
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. AT THE END
OF THE DAY THIS IS A HISTORIC
BUDGET IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY NOT
TO JUST BUILD FOR NEXT YEAR.
REALLY BILLS FOR THE NEXT HALF
DECADE IN ENSURE THAT OUR OUR
ECONOMY CAN REMAIN VIBRANT
THROUGH FUNDING OUR EDUCATION.
EDUCATION IS NOT JUST A KEY
THROUGH TWELVE EARLY EDUCATION
AS WELL AS OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION. IN ENSURING THAT WE
CONTINUE TO EDUCATE ALL THE
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA BUT WE
HAVE GIVE THEM EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO REMAIN IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE KEEP. IN
CALIFORNIA- WITH THAT I AM
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO. OUR
SUCH- ARE SHARE OF. ONE WHICH
IS DOCTOR REGULAR. I'M SORRY.
LET ME LET ME GIVE A OUR VICE
OPPORTUNE COMING TO WILL
CONDUCT INDEX YOU. I THINK IT
WAS CHAIR- TURNING TO THE FIRST
SECTION OF THE SECOND WE'RE
BEFORE A- THE TITLE READ. TOP
PLDGES PRIORITY OR- BUDGETING
THANK AGREE MORE. THIS FAST AND
I HAS OUR TO REBUILDING. AND TO
DO THE WE NEED TO PRIOR TO.
MAKING I GOT WORK FOR THE
PEOPLE. WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
BASICS AS I'VE SAID BEFORE
FULLY RE OPENING OUR SCHOOLS
FIXING A BROKEN EDIE
BUREAUCRACY HE BUILDING A ROADS
MORE WATER STORAGE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO DEAL WITH
THE DROUGHT- THAT IS NOW BEFORE
US URREA AND REOPEN OR KANEMI
AND THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING REQUIRES
HONEST DELIBERATION OF ALL
SIDES AND WE HAVE MUCH TO
DISCUSS TODAY. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION. THE YOU MR
VICE TURN OUT GOOD AND A- YOU
MISTER. GOOD EVENING MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED AND HONORED TO
PRESENT TO YOU THIS YEAR'S SUB
ONE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
BUDGET PLAN. IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING BUT I WILL SAY IT
ANYWAY. THIS IS BEEN A YEAR
LIKE NO OTHER AND OUR BUDGET
PLAN IS LIKE NO OTHER AS WELL.
I AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
RESOURCES IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
AS THE PEN PANDEMIC HAS NOT HIT
US ALL EQUALLY. WE WILL MAKE
MAJOR INVESTMENTS IN OUR SOCIAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS AND MOST OF
WHAT YOU SEE ON OUR PLANS ARE
PRIORITIES THAT CHAMPIONS AND
ADVOCATES HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
FOR YEARS. THESE INVESTMENTS
ENSURE THAT ALL COMMUNITIES CAN
MEET BASIC NEEDS FEED
THEMSELVES AND THEIR CHILDREN
AND BE CARED FOR AND RECEIVE
SUPPORTS WHEN THEY FACE TRAUMA
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY
UNEMPLOYMENT DISEASE AND
DISABILITY. THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
COMPLETED A BURNS RATE STUDY IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TO ADDRESS THE
SUSTAINABILITY QUALITY AND
TRANSPARENCY OF COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. IT IDENTIFIED A
SHOCKING ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
IN MAJOR GAPS OF WHAT DDS
PROVIDERS NEEDED VERSUS WHAT WE
WERE FUNDED. I AM PROUD TO
ANNOUNCE THAT THE BUDGET BEFORE
US. PROVIDE A PHASED IN
APPROACH TO CLOSE THIS GAP BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THIS WILL PROVIDE
STABILITY FOR A SYSTEM THAT HAS
BEEN ROCKED IN COVE IT AND THAT
HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY
UNDERFUNDED. THIS ACTION MEANS
THAT WE WILL FULFILL THE
PROMISE OF THE LANTERN MEN ACT.
ON WHICH S MANY RELY TO LIVE
FULL SAFE AND DIGNIFIED LIVES
IN OUR COMMUNITY. WE MAKE
CRITICAL CHANGES TO MINIMIZE
THE CAL WORKS TO MODERNIZE THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM SO THAT I CAN
PROVIDE REAL TRAUMA INFORMED
SUPPORT TO PARENTS AND THEIR
CHILDREN IN THE SAFETY NET
PROGRAM. WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
NEUROSCIENCE ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND IMPLICIT BIAS
HAVE INFORMED US WITH WHAT WE
CALL CAL WORKS TWO POINT OH AND
THESE INVESTMENTS WILL HELP TO
REALIZE THE TWO POINT NO
TRANSFORMATION. THIS POWERFUL
PROGRAM CAN BREAK THE CYCLE OF
POVERTY SO THAT THE PARENTS AND
CHILDREN HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LIVE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM. WE
INVEST FURTHER INTO CAL WORKS
FUNDING. CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES AND RESTORES THE CUTS
TO THE CAL WORKS HOME VISITING
PROGRAM. THE IRONY OF LIVING ON
THE BREAD BASKET OF THE WORLD
IS THOSE WHO WORKED SO
DILIGENTLY TO PUT FOOD ON OUR
TABLES. TOO OFTEN FACE FOOD
INSECURITY THEMSELVES. THE
SOLUTION TO FIGHTING HUNGER AT
RECORD LEVELS IN CALIFORNIA IS
TO PROVIDE STRONG INVESTMENTS
IN OUR EMERGENCY FOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS BUDGET
SUPPORTS FOOD FOR ALL WHICH
EXPANDS ACCESS AND C. PAP TO
END THE IMMIGRANT EXCLUSION IN
THE STATE'S NUTRITION SAFETY
NET. RAMPING UP TO GET THERE BY
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. IT ALSO PROVIDES
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS TO FUND
THE NEEDS OF OUR INDISPENSABLE
FOOD BANKS AND PROVIDES
DISASTER RESILIENCY FOR THE
FUTURE. WE GIVE OVER ONE
BILLION TO HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS THAT ARE
PART OF THE FRONT LINE ANTI
POVERTY SAFETY NET WE PROVIDE A
SUBSTANTIAL GRANT INCREASE FOR
SS I SS P. RECIPIENTS AND WE
FIND A MULTITUDE OF SUPPORT IN
OUR CHILD WELFARE AND FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. OTHER NOTABLE
INVESTMENT IN OUR HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS INCLUDE
EXPANDING ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES RESTORING THE SOCIAL
RECREATION AND CAMPING SERVICES
FOR PERSONS WITH. INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
BROADENING EARLY START SERVICES
TWO THREE AND FIVE YEAR OLDS.
AND INCREASING THE CAPACITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAMS. SIMILARLY
THERE ARE MANY INVESTMENTS IN
OUR HEALTH PROGRAMS TO BE
EXCITED ABOUT IN THIS BUDGET.
LED BY ADVOCATES AND MY
COLLEAGUES THEY INCLUDE
ESTABLISHING A STATEWIDE
ELECTRONIC POLST REGISTRY.
CREATING HEALTH PROFESSIONS
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
PROVIDING WRAPAROUND SERVICES
FOR PATIENTS WITH ALS
CONTINUING THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PILOT PROGRAM FUNDING
THE END THE EPIDEMICS PROPOSAL.
ELIMINATING THE MEDIC CAL ACID
TEST EXPANDING THE PARKINSON'S
DISEASE REGISTRY PROGRAM. AND
COVERING DOULA AND PROMOTE
TAUGHT SERVICES MEDICAL. IT
ALSO SUPPORTED THE ALL CHILDREN
THRIVE THE STATEWIDE INITIATIVE
THAT SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO
MITIGATE THE DISPARATE EFFECTS
OF ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN FACE. SIMILARLY IT
PROVIDES SIXTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUSTAIN AND EXTEND
THE INNOVATIVE AND IMPACTFUL
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT. I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE EXTRA EXTRA ORDINARY WORK
DONE BY THE ADMINISTRATION
UNDER USED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROPOSAL. EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC
MANY OF US RECOGNIZED THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CRISIS WOULD BE A
TSUNAMI. THAT RESULTS FROM
CORVIDS EARTHQUAKE. RADICALLY
DATA BEARS THIS OUT SHOWING
SIGNIFICANT RISING RATES OF
MENTAL ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE ESPECIALLY AMONG KIDS.
RISING TO THE MOMENT THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDED A FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR RESPONSE TO THIS
CRISIS IN AS MANY REVISED AND
I'M HONORED THAT IT'S PART OF
OUR PLAN TO. OUR LAN MAKE
STRIVES TO INCREASE RESILIENCY
AND TO ADDRESS TRAUMA THAT
CHILDREN HAVE FACED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. I'M ALSO APPRECIATIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S IN DOING THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCING AND
INNOVATING MEDIKAL CAL TEAM
PROPOSAL AND THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR WORKING
CLOSELY WITH MY COLLEAGUES. CAL
AIM IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
SWEEPING PACKAGE OF REFORMS TO
STREAMLINE TRANSFORM AND FOUND
DACIAN WE CHANGE MEDICAL
SERVICE DELIVERY AND FINANCING.
TALION WILL HELP TO IMPROVE
SERVICE DELIVERY AND IN DOING
SO REDUCE HEALTH DISPARITIES. I
AM THRILLED THAT BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN ACTION TO SUPPORT
HEALTH FOR ALL EXPANDING FULL
SCOPE MEDICAL COVERAGE TO OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AGED
FIFTY AND OLDER. THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS HIT FRONT
LINE AND THE CENTRAL WORKERS
ESPECIALLY HARD INCLUDING
MILLIONS OF UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS TAKING ON A
DISPROPORTIONATE RISK OF
EXPOSURE. THE PANDEMIC HAS
FURTHER EXACERBATED RACIAL AND
ETHNIC HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
MADE IT CLEAR THAT ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE IS
NECESSARY FOR EVERY RESIDENT IN
OUR STATE. IT IS CRITICAL THAT
OUR STATE ACT NOW TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH OF ALL LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY WERE BORN. THE
DEFICIENCIES IN OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM NATURALLY HIGHLIGHT THE
DEFICIENCIES IN OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM. IT HAS LONG BEEN
UNDERSTOOD THAT SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH HEALTH
INEQUITIES AND AN UNDER FUNDED
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
ARE KEY FACTORS AFFECTING THE
HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS. AND IN
THE INTEREST OF NOT LETTING A
GOOD CRISIS GO TO WASTE OUR
PLAN INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. WE ARE PROVIDING A TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS TO MEET. CORE
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS AN INVESTMENT THAT ISN'T
ACCOMPANIED BY RESOURCES TO
FUND AN ANALYSIS OF LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH STAFFING AND
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. IN
ORDER TO INFORM FUTURE FUNDING
DECISIONS. THESE INVESTMENTS
AND OUR EXPERIENCE RESPONDING
TO THE PANDEMIC UNDENIABLY BEGS
THE QUESTION. HAS CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC HEALTH REALIGNMENT BEEN
A FAILURE. WE CAN NO LONGER
TURN A BLIND EYE AND BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A QUESTION THAT
MUST BE ANSWERED AND A
CONVERSATION THAT MUST BE HAD
IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE. OUR
PLAN ALSO MAKES AN
UNPRECEDENTED A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL
INVESTMENT. DIRECTLY INTO
COMMUNITIES IN CBO'S VIA A
HEALTH EQUITY FUND AS WELL AS A
TRANSGENDER HEALTH EQUITY FUND.
IN ORDER TO BEGIN TURNING THE
TIDE ON SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
ENTRENCHED HEALTH INEQUITIES IN
OUR STATE. I SAW FIRST HAND THE
IMPORTANCE THAT THESE
NONPROFITS PLAYED IN BEING
BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND TRUSTED
MESSENGERS. AND HELPING TO
EDUCATE AND ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS
OF THE COVERT NINETEEN VACCINE.
IT'S REQUIRED A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN STATE COUNTY AND CBO'S
TO EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS THE
COMPLEX ISSUES FACING OUR STATE.
THE HEALTH INSURANCE
INVESTMENTS IN OUR PLAN REFLECT
NOT ONLY CARE SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES THAT PEOPLE NEED TODAY
BUT THE CALIFORNIA THAT WE ALL
WANT FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN A POST PANDEMIC
FUTURE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THESE IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS ON THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
ADDRESSING THE UNDERLYING ROOT
CAUSES BETWEEN THE INEQUITIES
THAT PERVADE OUR SYSTEMS AS
PART OF MY ROLE AS CHAIR OF SUB
ONE. AND AS THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON ENSURING SYSTEMIC
EQUITY POSTPONED AT NINETEEN.
BEFORE I END I WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION. THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE COUNTIES IN ADVOCATES
AND THE PUBLIC. THIS IS YOUR
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
BUDGET WE HOPE WE DID YOU PROUD.
THANK YOU DR PEPPER WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO MISS MCCARTY. THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA SIT DOWN THANKS FOR A
STANDING IN THERE SAYING US
DOCTOR EMMA BUT- I'M GONNA SIT
RIGHT HERE I FIRST I WANT TO
THANK OUR COMMIT MEMBERS WHO
PARTICIPATED THROUGHOUT THE
SPRING- ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS-
GALLAGHER. WE HAVE- VIA DAR ES
GO DONALD RAY S. LEE ANN MEDINA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PART THANK
YOU TO OURS TO STAFF MEMBERS.
GABLE AND MORE MARTIN THE THEIR
AMAZING WORK AND I'M TRYING TO
PULL UP THE NOTES HERE SO ME SO-
I WOULD TO JUST YOU KNOW HIGHLY
WITH TEAM SAID- THIS A ONCE IN
A LIFE FRANKLY BUT WE ALL SAY
THAT. IS R. V. STAY THE MOST
IMPORTANT WE DO ON ANNUAL BASIS-
THE IN THIS IS FRANKLY THE
REASON WHY MANY OF US RAN FOR
OFFICE TO INVEST IN OUR FUTURE
OUR KIDS OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION I
DON'T THINK IT'LL GET ANY ANY
BETTER THAN THIS AND THIS IS
NOT JUST MONEY THEY WERE
PUTTING IN HERE A LOT OF THESE
ARE DOLLARS AND CENTS. BUT
THESE- EFFORTS HERE WILL REALLY
TRANSFORM LIVES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SO ALL START WITH
OUR OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS AND
THAT'S- EARLY EDUCATION WE KNOW
THAT IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL EDUCATION SYSTEM YOU
TO MAKE SURE WE INVEST IN OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS SO R. E. C.
E. PACKAGE I REALLY IS A
TRANSFORMATIONAL BUDGET
PACKAGE. INCREASING ACCESS TO-
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS BY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
SLOTS WAS THAT MEAN FOR PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA WE CURRENTLY HAVE
A WAITING LIST OF FOUR THOUSAND
FAMILIES WILL TO BE CUT IN HALF
BECAUSE OF THE INCREASED CHILD
CARE SLOTS LED UNIVERSAL ACCESS
TO TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS. MANY YEARS
IN THE MAKING FOR THIS TO
MAKING SURE THAT THAT MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES AND ALL FAMILIES
OF FOUR YEAR OLDS WERE ABLE TO
ATTEND A PUBLICLY FUNDED
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WE
ALSO INCREASE OUR REIMBURSEMENT
RATES FOR OUR CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS AND PRE K. PROGRAMS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR WORK
PROFESSIONAL WORKERS I DON'T
GET PAID POVERTY WAGES BUT CAN-
TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES MANIAS
WORKERS ACTUALLY QUALIFY FOR
THE SAME PROGRAMS THAT THEY
WORK IN BECAUSE OF THEIR LOW
WAGES SO THIS WILL
PROFESSIONALISE THE PROGRAMS
WELL AS MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A NOT SO MUCH TURNOVER WE
ALSO EXPAND ACCESS TO OUR- OUR
OUR PRESCHOOL. PROGRAMS TO
SERVE MORE THREE YEAR OLD LET'S.
AND WITH THE WHOLE PACKAGE.
THAT'S NOT ONE THING- INTO TOWN
THE THIS WILL IN ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE. AT UNIVERSAL AND- FOR NOT
ONLY FOR YOUR OWN BUT FOR MOST
LOW INCOME. THREE FIVE YEAR
OLDS IN CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE A
CHANCE TO MAKE SURE WE CAN.
TAKE CARE OF FAMILY SO THEIR
PARENTS CAN CAN GO TO SCHOOL-
GO TO WORK AND TO MAKE SURE
THOSE KIDS HAVE A HEAD START.
FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS FIRST AND
FOREMOST AS OUR BUDGET CHAIR
STATED. PRIORITY NUMBER ONE
WE'RE RE OPENING OUR SCHOOLS
THIS FALL. MAKE NO MISTAKES. NO
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT GOING BACK
NO FOOD NO EXCUSES. WE ARE
WROTE RE OPENING OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THIS FALL WERE ADAMANT
ABOUT THAT. WE'RE PROVIDING
ENORMOUS RESOURCES. TO FUND OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS- THIS IS THIS.
HAS A WRECK NUMBER OF FUN PER
STUDENT ABOUT TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. A PER
STUDENT. AND ABOUT TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN MORE PROP
NINETY EIGHT THEN JUST LAST
YEAR. SO THIS IS THE HIGH WATER
MARK EVER FOR FUNDING OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN WE'RE PROVIDING SUPER CALL
OF OVER FOUR PERCENT. FOR ALL
OF OUR ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS THAT
ARE K. TWELVE. SCHOOL SYSTEM
FOR SPECIAL LED THE SAME WERE
ALSO MAKE MAKING SURE WE
EXPANSIVENESS LED EARLY
EDUCATION INCLUSION PROGRAMS.
FOR CTP TOP PRIORITY FOR MANY
PEOPLE THE LEGISLATURE- WE'RE
DOUBLING FUNDING FOR OUR CTE
PROGRAMS. WE SAY THAT NOT ALL
OF OUR KIDS- CERTAINLY- HAVE
PLANS TO GO TO. HIGHER
EDUCATION BUT THEY HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET MORE EDUCATION
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL AND C. T. IS
A WAY. TO GET A PIPELINE FOR-
YOU KNOW THE JOBS OF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. BUT IT'S CALLED
READING THIS IS A BIG PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE TOO SO WE HAVE.
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
FOR A THREE G. COMPLETION GRANT
PROGRAMS CREDIT RECOVERY AS
WELL AS HELPING PAY FOR. AP
EXAMS AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
LONG A PRIORITY THE
LEGISLATURE. WE BUILD UPON WITH
THE GOVERNOR- RECOMMENDS AND
HAVE A BILLION DOLLARS TO
EXPAND OUR OUR EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS OTHERWISE
ANOTHER ASUS PROGRAMS. A
PRIORITY FOR THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY IS TO HAVE UNIVERSAL
SCHOOL MEALS- THAT'LL BE PART
OF OUR BUDGET. AND THEN- LASTLY
FOR IT FOR K. TWELVE ONE
DIMENSION. THIS IS A PRIORITY
FOR OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SHARE
SOME HE'S WORKED ON FOR A LONG
TIME TO FIND- ETHNIC STUDIES.
THROUGH A BLOCK GRANT AS WELL
AS MAKE ETHNIC STUDIES
AVAILABLE FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. A PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE A TEACHER SHORTAGE. HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT. WE
KNOW THAT WOULD RETIRED TEACHER.
WHO HAD SO HARD TO THIS PAN.
HIS WELL JUST INTERESTED. AND
WE NEED TO MEET HIRING- TEACH
TO R. T. CAKES. SO WE HAVE A
BILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME. TO
FOCUS ON EXISTING. TEACHER
PIPELINE PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- GET TEACHERS THROUGH
OUR TEACHER RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
OTHER TESTED. EFFORTS THAT WE
KNOW OF I WORK HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO OVERALL THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE BUDGET IS SOLID-
OVERALL THE EARLY EDUCATION
BUDGET IS LIKE NOTHING WE'VE
EVER SEEN BEFORE. FRANKLY
EVERYTHING THAT IT WAS ASKED
FOR BY- ARE ADVOCATES ARE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS SO
WE THINK THIS IS. REALLY AND AN
AMAZING OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST
IN OUR IN OUR YOUTH. THE OTHER
END OF THE OF THE EDUCATION
SPECTRUM AS MISTER. BUDGETARY
TEAM MENTIONED EARLIER IS
HIGHER AND- WE KNOW THAT MORE
AND MORE STUDENTS NEED HIGHER
EDUCATION TO FILL. THE JOBS OF
TODAY AND TOMORROW SO WERE WHO
WERE FIGHTING RECORD AMOUNTS OF
SUPPORT TO EXPAND. ENROLLMENT
AT OUR UC AND CSU CAMPUSES. I
WOULD YOU SEE MORE FULLY
FUNDING THE UC BUDGET REQUEST
AND DOING MORE. WE'RE
SUPPORTING AN ADDITIONAL SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO ENROLL IN
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
THE LARGEST EXPANSION EVER PUT
FORWARD BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE- WE ALSO HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT TOO MANY OF OUR
UC CAMPUSES. ARE ELUSIVE FOR
STUDENTS WHO HAVE AMAZING
GRADES. AND AND ACADEMIC
CREDENTIALS BUT CAN'T GET IN TO
THE UC ESPECIALLY AT THE
MARQUEE CAMPUSES OF UCLA SAN
DIEGO AND BERKELEY. SO WE'RE
GOING TO LOWER THE NUMBER OF
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS. IS THE
TOP PRIORITY FOR MANY OF US.
FOR THE LAST DECADE. MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE INCREASED
ACCESS FOR A CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES ABOUT. FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED MORE CALIFORNIANS
WILL BE ABLE TO ENROLL AT
BERKELEY UCLA. AND SAN DIEGO.
WE ALSO RESOURCES TO EXPAND-
ACADEMIC OUT REACH PROGRAMS. TO
HELP MORE ON REP CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS- TO USE. AND CSU WE
FULLY FINE THEIR BUDGET%
REQUESTS. PROVIDED JUST SO TO
AN- IN A NINE FIVE STILL. AT
THE C. SO- THIS AGAIN WILL MAKE
SURE THAT ALL CSU APPLE. THAT
ARE CALL HAVE CHANCE TO. THE
THIS IS A AN OP. TO MAKE SURE
WE FOCUS ON ACCESS FOR THE CSU-
AS WLL AS PROVIDING RESOURCES
TO FUND THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE. TO BRING DOWN
GRADUATION RATES TO HELP
STUDENTS GRADUATE WITH LESS
DEBT AS WELL AS FREE UP SPACE
FOR THE NEXT GENERATION OF KIND
OF STUDENTS AT OUR
COMMUNICATORS WE FULLY FUND
THEIR BUDGET REQUEST. WITH THE
FULL FUNDING OF THE COLAB
PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
FOR OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE FULL
TIME FACULTY PART TIME FACULTY
OFFICE HOURS. WE DO NOT FUNDS
THE CALIBRATOR OF RAM- WHICH WE
THINK IS A FAILED EXPERIMENTS
THEIR ONLINE EDUCATION WE THINK
OUR EXISTING COMMUNICABLE JUST
CAN DO. THIS WORK MORE
EFFICIENTLY- AND THEN LASTLY
LAST BUT NOT LEAST. WE HAVE A
REALLY EXCITING PROPOSAL WE'RE
ASKING THE GOVERNOR TO EMBRACE.
THAT MAKES COLLEGE- I DEBT FREE
IN CALIFORNIA THAT SOUNDS LIKE
SOMETHING THAT- IS ELUSIVE. BUT
WE THINK THAT BY INCREASING
FINANCIAL AID TO OUR CAR CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS. IN THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS ARE
GETTING AMPLE FINANCIAL AID. IN
ADDITION TO THEIR TO THEIR
APPROPRIATE PARENT
CONTRIBUTIONS AND THEN WORKING
FIFTEEN HOURS- THE WEEK
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL YEAR AND
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO GRADUATE-
DEBT FREE. SO THIS IS AN EFFORT
TO REALLY MAKE COLLEGE MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE SO
STUDENTS AREN'T AREN'T SHOULDER
WITH. SO MUCH DEBT THAT IMPACTS
THEIR ABILITY TO- TO MOVE ON
AFTER GRADUATION BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY. IT PROVIDES ENOUGH
GRADUATES. TO FILL- THE JOB
THAT WE HERE OUR STATE TO
THRIVE SO WITH. IS AND- REALLY
ROBUST SUB TO. A P. THREE.
SIXTEEN AT. BUDGET AND- AGAIN-
THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND OUR STAFF ROBBINS BUT THE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR WE GO
TO SUB THREE WORKING KALRA.
TANG HERE FONG. AROUND BENNETT
BLOOM CARILLO CHIU COOPER
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
GARCIA JONES SAWYER KILEY
LACKEY YOUR LEE MATHIS MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN. NAZARIAN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON RAMOS REYES
RIVAS RUBIO SMITH STONE
VALLADARES WOOD. COULD YOU
RECALL MR COOPER. MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM ALSO
JUST TO NOTE I KNOW WOULD BE
HAVING PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER
BURKE QUESTIONS TO DEPARTMENT
FINANCES WELL AS TO L. A. O.
JUST A REMINDER TO THE PUBLIC
THE TOLL FREE NUMBERS ON THE
WEBSITE OR ON THE BROADCAST
THAT YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW
IT'S. 877-692-8957 IN THE CODE
IS TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN HAVE ANY PROBLEMS CARD
CONNECTING INTO THE TOLL FREE
LINE PLEASE CALL OUR ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO
NINE NINE. IT WITHOUT WILL MOVE
TO MISTER BLOOM. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR.
THE LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET PLAN
FOR SUBCOMMITTEE THREE I'M
REALLY CAPTURES ON OPPORTUNITY
AND I LIKE I SEE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY BUDGET-
PARTICULARLY- IMPORTANT- IN SUB
THREE AS WERE GONNA BE
PREPARING FOR WHAT COULD BE
WHAT I WOULD SAY NO DOUBT WILL
BE A CHALLENGING YEAR. OF
DROUGHT AND LIKELY WILDFIRE. I
AND OF COURSE. WE ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I AS I THINK
YOU'LL SEE REALLY EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS. THE
BUDGET PROVIDES RECORD STATE
GENERAL FUNDING FOR BOTH FIRE
PREVENTION CLEAN DRINKING WATER
AND OTHER WATER PROJECTS TO
BLUNT THE DAMAGE OF- ARE
DROUGHT AND WILDFIRE DISASTERS
THAT WE- EXPECT TO HAVE ACROSS
THE STATE. WHEN THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION BEGAN I
ASKED THE SUB COMMITTEE TO BE
RENAMED TO INCLUDE THE TERM
CLIMATE CRISIS AND IT HAS BEEN
SO RENAMED AYE I WANTED TO
SIGNAL THAT WE NEEDED TO DO
MORE THAN JUST REACT TO THE
CHANGING CLIMATE WE NEED TO
ACTIVELY RESIST THIS
DESTRUCTIVE TREND. AND THIS
BUDGET DELIVERS I'M VERY HAPPY
TO REPORT THAT THIS BUDGET
ALLOWS US TO BE PROACTIVE ON
ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE CRISIS
WILL INVEST IN CLIMATE
RESILIENCY INCLUDING ADAPTATION
PLANNING AND PROJECTS AND OPEN
SPACE. IMPROVE OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
ESPECIALLY FOR OPTIONS THAT
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
LIKE TRANSIT AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION WILL BUILD UPON
OUR CLEAN ENERGY SYSTEMS
CONTINUE OUR WORLDWIDE
LEADERSHIP ON CLEAN VEHICLE
INNOVATION AND ADVANCES TO
AGRICULTURE AND WILL MAKE
INVESTMENTS TO BRIDGE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. SO THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. HAVE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND. THAT LONG SOUGHT
AFTER GOAL THAT'S A LONG TO DO
LIST AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE TAKE OUR TIME MAKING
SURE THAT EVERY DOLLAR WE SPEND
MAKES A DIFFERENCE AND SO IN
THIS BUDGET WE'VE- COMMITTED TO
INVESTMENT LEVELS WITH OUR
FRIENDS IN THE SENATE. AND WILL
DISCUSS SPECIFIC FUNDING
PRIORITIES WITH THEM AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR ACTION LATER
IN THE YEAR. WE'VE LSO TAKEN A
DIFFERENT APPROACH THIS YEAR
WORKING TOO HEAVILY INVOLVED
THE POLICY COMMITTEES IN THE
CONVERSATION SO. THESE AND
INVESTMENTS ALSO REFLECT THE
GREAT WORK OF THE CHAIRS MS
RIVAS MISTER GARCIA MISTER CORK
AND IS FRIEDMAN. IN OUR BUDGET
ACTIONS. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
KEEP THESE CHAIRS AND OTHER
INTERESTED MEMBERS IN THE
CONVERSATION AS WE WORK THROUGH
EACH OF THESE PROPOSALS THIS
YEAR AND I INVITE MEMBERS HERE
TO CHECK IN WITH ME. AS
FREQUENTLY AS POSSIBLE HI- OR
PERHAPS AS INFREQUENTLY AS
POSSIBLE- AS THESE DISCUSSION
PROGRESS I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS AS
THE NEXT- VERY SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME. LIKE A WILDFIRE PACKAGE
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE WILL BRING
THOSE AGREEMENTS BACK TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THE UPCOMING
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR
DROUGHT AND WATER RESILIENCE A
BILLION DOLLARS MORE FOR
WILDFIRES. YOU'LL RECALL WE
ALREADY DID AN EARLY ACTION
AND- A PLAN ON WILDFIRES I
THINK THAT WAS ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. AT LEAST THREE
POINT SEVEN BILLION FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCE THREE POINT NINE
BILLION FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
OF CAP AND TRADE SPENDING SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS FOR BROADBAND.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
MILLION FOR SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE. EIGHT HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR CLEAN
ENERGY TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR ADDITIONAL PARKS
INVESTMENTS AND A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS. TO
ADDRESSED THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY.
THERE'S A MAJOR INVESTMENT
PACKAGES AND CHANGES TO
RESOURCES THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE JUNE BUDGET AND
TRANSPORTATION THERE ARE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN NEW
SPENDING FOR TRANSPORTATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE- THERE'S THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS AND- PROJECTS THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED FOR COMPLETION.
PRIOR TO TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
WHEN THE OLYMPICS WILL BE IN
LOS ANGELES THERE'S TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR STREETS ROADS AND
HIGHWAY PROJECTS AND FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION FOR A STATE AND
LOCAL TRANSPORTATION ADAPTATION
PROGRAM. ON TOXICS SOMETHING
THAT HAS LONG PLAGUED US A
SUITE OF REFORMS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL. THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ADVOCATES HAVE BEEN AND
INDUSTRY HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR YEARS WE NOW HAVE
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO REFORM THE
GOVERNANCE OF THE DEPARTMENT.
BY CREATING THE BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY.
PLACEHOLDER TRAIL TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO REVISE THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE FEE RATES AND
STRUCTURE. AND THIS WILL FIX
THE DEPARTMENT STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT WHILE REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF BUSINESSES YOU MUST
PAY THE FEE BUT INCREASING THE
FEES ON THE REMAINING HAZARDOUS
WASTE PRODUCTS. THIS IS
COMBINED WITH FUNDING FOR
CONTAMINATED SITE REMEDIATION.
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR CLOSURE OF
THE EXITE PROPERTY AND CLEANING
UP NEIGHBORING HOMES THAT WE
PRIORITIZE NOW FOR SEVERAL
YEARS IN SUB THREE. AND
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR CLEAN UP
OF THE STATE'S NATIONAL
PRIORITIES LIST AN ORPHAN SITES.
ON A DRESSING FIRE WE'VE
PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT NEW
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS AND AT CAL
FIRE. A THIRTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TO KEEP OUR FIRE CREWS
GOING THROUGH DECEMBER BECAUSE
OF THE FIRE SEASON IS SO LONG
NOW WE FIND SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN POSITIONS SIXTEEN
FIREFIGHTER CREWS AND THIRTY
HAND CREWS TO PROVIDE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT HAZARDOUS
FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS AND
WILDLAND FIRE SUPPRESSION. SO
MUCH MONEY THAT WE'RE PUTTING
NOW INTO PREVENTION IN ADDITION
TO JUST FIGHTING FIRE. TWENTY
TWO POSITIONS SO ARE ADDED FOR
THE WILDLIFE FORECAST AND
THREAT INTELLIGENCE INTEGRATION
CENTER. THERE ARE- IS- LITTLE
OVER TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR AVIATION CONTRACTS MONEY TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ON THE FIVE
FOOT AMBER RESISTANCE ZONE
AGAIN VERY IMPORTANT FOR
PREVENTION. FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS ALLOCATED TO
CSU SAN MARCOS TO STUDY AND
HANTS FIRE FIGHTING SO WE STAY
UP WITH BEST PRACTICES. AND
EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT DR WOODS
AB THIRTY EIGHT. THERE'S
FUNDING TO ADDRESS WATER IN
DROUGHT SSUES THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES- WILL
RECEIVE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CLIMATE VULNERABILITY
ASSESSMENT FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN
BASIN AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
POSITIONS TO ADDRESS AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE STATE
WATER PROJECT AS WELL AS SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. AT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD THERE'S A BILLION DOLLARS
TO ADDRESS WATER DEBT THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY ONE
STAFFER WATER CONTAMINATION
CLEANUP INCLUDING P. FIVE THREE
MINUTE REMEDIATION. AND TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN REVIEW.
THERE IS FUNDING FOR EXPANDING
GREASE GREEN SPACE AND
PROTECTING OUR CLOSE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING- TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO ADDRESS SEA LEVEL
RISE. AT THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY TO EXPAND PUBLIC
COASTAL ACCESS AND TO THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL FOR OUR
ONGOING INVESTMENT FOR THE
MARINE MAMMAL CENTER. AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IS
ALLOCATED TO BUILD NEW LOCAL
PARKS EXPAND PUBLIC ACCESS TO
STATE PARKS AND REBUILD AFTER
WILDFIRES. THIS WILL INCLUDE
INVESTMENTS IN TESLA PARK INDIA
BASIN THE SACRAMENTO RAILYARDS
AND CULTURAL CENTERS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN HERITAGE
CENTER AND MUSEUM OF TOLERANCE.
I WANT TO THANK MY SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISTER BENNETT MS
FRIEDMAN MISTER MOLLEN MR
PATTERSON MS RIVAS AND MR
SMITTY SMITH WHO ALL OF WHOM
HAVE CONTRIBUTED- THROUGHOUT
THE COURSE OF THIS YEAR. AND OF
COURSE WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
DO THE WORK THAT WE DO WITHOUT
THE INCREDIBLE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN MADE SO MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF-
THE COBRA COVERED PANDEMIC I
WANT TO THANK. KIRSTEN KOPECKY
SHY FORBES GENEVIEVE MORELOS
SUSAN CHAN. CHRISTIAN GREY.
THANK YOU THE COMMITMENT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND GOOD AFTERNOON TO
EVERYONE I'M EXCITED TO PRESENT
THE PLAN FOR SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR
ON STATE ADMINISTRATION OUR
PLAN IS TO PROTECT OUR PLANET
THE PRODUCT OF COMPREHENSIVE
HEARINGS AND INVALUABLE INPUT
FROM MY FELLOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACKNOWLEDGING. THE MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CHIU COOPER TO
SYRIAN AND LACKEY THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR CONTRIBUTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AND FOR
PUTTING UP WITH MY LEARNING ON
HOW TO CHAIR BUDGETS OF FOUR
IT'S BEEN A VERY INTERESTING
FIRST FEW MONTHS OF THIS YEAR-
WE HAVE SEVERAL- CATEGORIES
THAT I LIKE TO GET INTO WILL
START WITH HOMELESSNESS-
MEMBERS THE THOUGHT FOR PLAN
INCLUDES A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS
BUT I WILL FOCUS MY COMMENTS.
ON THE LARGER PROGRAMS FOR
HOMELESSNESS THE PLAN INCLUDES
THE FIRST MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT
TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS THE
BUDGET PROVIDES EIGHT POINT
FIVE BILLION WITH A B. IN NEW
FUNDING FOR HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR PROJECT
HUNKY. AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
THE PLAN INCLUDES ONE BILLION
AND ONGOING SUPPORT FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO RESPOND TO THEIR
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND TO ALLOW
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PLAN
OVER A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME
RATHER THAN YEAR BY YEAR THIS
HAS BEEN A CONSTANT.
COMMUNICATION AND SENTIMENT
SHARED BY MANY OF US IN THIS
BODY THE HOMELESSNESS PLAN
INVEST INVEST IN FUNDING FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH AND INCLUDE
STRONGER ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES THAT WILL PRODUCE
RESULTS WE ALL HAVE THE GOAL OF
HOUSING EVERY CALIFORNIA AND
TOGETHER WE CAN ACHIEVE THIS
GOAL I STRONGLY BELIEVE LIKE
MANY OF YOU THAT HOUSING IS IN
FACT HUMAN RIGHT. ON EDT
ADDRESSING ISSUES AT THE E. D.
D. R. DOMINATED OUR
CONVERSATIONS THIS YEAR AND
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR AS A RESULT WE
HEARD CLEARLY FROM MEMBERS AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY FROM
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT FRUSTRATIONS
OVER DELAYS AND BACKLOGS FROM
EDT. THE ITEMS ADOPTED AND
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL PROVIDE
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
EXPRESSED INCLUDING FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A DIRECT DEPOSIT
OPTION ELEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION WITH SIX POINT A EIGHT
MILLION ONGOING. PROVIDE
INCREASED LANGUAGE AXIS ELEVEN
POINT EIGHT MILLION TO
MODERNIZE SYSTEMS AND IMPROVE
THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE. ELEVEN
POINT FOUR MILLION. FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
NAVIGATORS AT AMERICA'S JOB
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA LOCATIONS
AND- THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION FOR TEMPORARY EDT STAFF
TO ADDRESS. WORKLOAD BACKLOG
AND ONGOING WORK. ON THE ISSUE
OF ECONOMIC STIMULUS AND SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF THE SUB FLOOR
PLAN BUILT ON PROGRAMS AND
INVESTMENTS CREATED EARLIER
THIS YEAR TO STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY. AND PROVIDE SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF POST CODE. THIS
INCLUDES A GREEN AND APPROVING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS TO PROVIDE EIGHT
POINT ONE BILLION IN TAX CUTS
TO CALIFORNIANS WITH INCOMES UP
TO SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND. THIS
WILL PROVIDE TAXPAYERS WITH
PAYMENTS OF 500-600-1000 AND
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS DEPENDING ON THEIR
FILING STATUS. WHILE WORKING ON
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS WE
FOUND THAT THERE WAS A GREAT
NEED FOR OUT REACH FOR
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAD ACCESS TO
RESOURCE. TO NAVIGATE THE I.
TEN N. E. I. T. C. PROCESS. AS
A RESULT OUR BUDGET INCLUDES
FIFTEEN MILLION. ONGOING FOR
OUT REACH EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT OUT REACH ALSO MEANS
KNOWING HOW. AN INDIVIDUAL CAN
BECOME AN I. TEN TAX PAYER. A
GREEN AND APPROVING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION AND
SMALL BUSINESSES AND NONPROFIT
GRANTS BRINGING THE TOTAL
INVESTMENT IN THE SMALL
BUSINESS COVER NINETEEN RELIEF
GRANT PROGRAM. TO A WHOPPING
FOUR BILLION. DOLLARS AND
LASTLY. ON THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS PROVIDING TWO BILLION
OF TAX RELIEF OVER THE- NEXT
TEN YEAR OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES TO
MITIGATE IMPACTS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FOR
PAYMENTS. BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THIS REPLACES THE
GOVERNOR'S ONE POINT ONE
BILLION PROPOSAL THAT WOULD NOT
TARGET RELIEF TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WILL NOT HAVE A
PRACTICAL BENEFIT TO ANY
BUSINESS UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY.
ON THE ISSUE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. ARE BUDGET PROVIDES
ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION TO
ALLEVIATE THE BACKLOG IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
THREE HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
PRESERVATION OF EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLION FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT MAINTENANCE
MAINTENANCE AND PRESERVATION OF
FARMWORKER HOUSING. AND SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS TO HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PLAN FOR AND
MEET THEIR GOALS UNDER THE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGIES. ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT THIS BUDGET
PROVIDES OVER ONE BILLION AND
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR WORK FORCE
PROGRAMS THE ASSEMBLY PLAN
COMMITS US TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND THE SENATE ON A WORKFORCE
PACKAGE THAT FOCUSES ON WORKERS
MOST IN NEED EDUCATION AND
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR GOOD
PAYING JOBS AND EFFECTIVE
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE WE SUPPORT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND BUILDING
SUSTAINABLE FUTURES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LABOR INDUSTRY
AND OUR EDUCATION SYSTEMS THIS
CONVERSATIONAL ICAL INCLUDE
REVISITING THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR YOUTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISION. WE DEFERRED ACTION TO
ALLOW FOR MORE DISCUSSION PART
OF THESE FUNDS WILL SET ASIDE
THE FUND FOR THE SUCCESSFUL
CITY YEAR PROGRAM ON THE ARTS
WE CONTINUE TO WORK TO SET
ASIDE FUNDS TO BUILD BACK THE
ARTS AND CENTERS OF CULTURE
INCLUDING FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
MUSEUM AND RENOVATIONS TO THE
NATIONAL LGBTQ CENTER WE ALSO
PROPOSE OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILLION IN SUPPORT FOR ARTS
INCLUDING FUNDS TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO COMPLY
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF AB
FIVE. ON CANNABIS THIS BUDGET
PROVIDES OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THE PROCESS OF
BRINGING MORE BUSINESSES INTO
THE FULLY REGULATED LEGAL
MARKET AND SUPPORTING LICENSEES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED. BY
THE WAR ON DRUGS. ON VETERANS
THIS BUDGET PROPOSES TWENTY
FIVE MILLION SPECIFIC FOR
VETERANS TO ADDRESS ISSUES
RANGING FROM HOMELESSNESS AND
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT TO
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND SMALL
BUSINESS ASSISTANCE. ON THE
FILM TAX CREDIT. THE LAST ITEM
I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT IN
THE ADDITIONAL IS THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN THE
FILM TAX CREDIT. THIS
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL NINETY
MILLION FOR TWO YEARS FOR
ADDITIONAL FILM TAX CREDITS BUT
THIS INVESTMENT STILLS STILL
FALL SHORT OF ACHIEVING
DIVERSITY AND EQUITY.
COLLEAGUES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
TINSELTOWN WERE GREAT MOVIES
ARE MADE WHERE DREAMS COME TRUE
IF YOU CAN MAKE IT IN HOLYWOOD
YOU CAN MAKE IT ANYWHERE. BUT
THE REALITY IS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS TRENDING HASHTAGS LIKE
OSCARS SO WHITE HAVE REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE LACK OF
DIVERSITY IN EQUITY IN
PRODUCTION. IF WE ARE INVESTING
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. TO KEEP AND
BRING BACK PRODUCTION TO
CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD ENSURE
THAT WE ARE COLLECTING THE DATA
NECESSARY ON ETHNICITY GENDER
AND RACE A BELOW THE LINE CREWS
WRITERS PRODUCERS DIRECTORS. AN
ONSCREEN TALENT I BELIEVE THAT
ART IMITATES LIFE AND HOW
STORIES ARE TOLD AND WHO TELLS
THEM IS IMPORTANT. FINALLY I
WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
SO FOURTEEN THAT INCLUDES MY
CHIEF OF STAFF TINA AND BRIAN
FINKEL FROM THE REPUBLICAN
POLICY OFFICE. AND OF COURSE
GENEVIEVE MICHAEL CHRISTIAN AND
JESSICA FROM OUR BUDGET OUR
BUDGET TEAM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL NOT GO TO MISS GARCIA.
THANK YOU I WANT TO START OFF
BY THANKING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MISTER JONES SAWYER LACKEY DOWN
AND MRS VIA THAT IS AS WELL AS
FAR AS I STAFF MISS CAME IN
THIS MITCHELL I LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM L. A. WANT TO.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AS WE JUMP INTO THIS MANY YEAR
PROCESS AND THE LEARNING CURVE
HAS BEEN STEEP BUT THE TEAM IS
ALL MADE IT EASIER. THE
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED MANY
CHALLENGES IN THE AREA PUBLIC
SAFETY. FOR COURT USERS SUPPORT
OPERATIONS PRESENT INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN CRIME SURVIVORS.
DESPITE THESE CHALLENGES BUT
DOES THE COMMITTEES BY PLAN TO
CONTINUE THE TRAJECTORY OF
PROGRESS THEY'VE BEEN MAKING
OVER THE YEARS AND THE AREA
PUBLIC SAFETY CONTINUES. A
LARGE PART BECAUSE OF THE MANY
ADVOCATES WHO HAVE BEEN
STEADFAST IN THEIR WORK IN THIS
BILL AND I WANT TO THANK THEM
AS WELL. BEGINNING WITH THE
COURTS WE ARE AUGMENTING THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH'S BUDGET AND
TRIAL. COURT OPERATIONS OF THE
P. PANDEMIC RESOURCE LEVEL WE
ARE INCREASING INVESTMENTS
INDEPENDENT TO COUNSEL. THE
EQUAL ACCESS FUNDING COUNTY.
LAW LIBRARY SUPPORT VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND INDIGENT COURT
PLANS. IN ADDITION WE INCLUDE
AN INCREASE TO THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR COURT
REPORTERS AND PROVIDE COURT
REPORTERS FOR INDIGENT CLIENTS.
IN FAMILY LAW AND CIVIL LAW
PROCEEDINGS. WE'RE CONTINUING
EFFORTS TO REDUCE RELIANCE A
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS TO FUND
GOVERNMENT SERVICES. BILLION A
PROCESS UPON PREVIOUS PROGRESS
IN THE AREA OF FINES AND FEES
WILL BE ELIMINATING ADDITIONAL
FEES INCLUDING THE CIVIL
ASSESSMENT. AND PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT BACK WITH THE
SUPPORT THE LIMITATION OF THE
SPECIES. THIS APPROACH TO
PROVIDE MORE AND MORE EQUITABLE
LONGER TERM ECONOMIC RELIEF
ACROSS THE STATE. IN THE AREA
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES WE ARE
PROVIDING RESOURCES TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
COVER THE LOCAL SHARE THE
HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT PROGRAM.
FOR SURVIVORS THE CRIME WE
INCLUDE RESOURCES FOR
PREVENTION AND PROGRAMS FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE. AND SURVIVORS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING. WE ALSO
INCLUDED RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THE BACKLOG OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
KITS AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. AS WELL AS INCREASING
REIMBURSEMENT FOR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS TO PROCESS SEXUAL
ASSAULT KITS. AND FINALLY WE
HOPE THIS YEAR TO PROVIDE
REPARATIONS TO SURVIVORS OF
INVOLUNTARY FOR STERILIZATION
IN STATE INSTITUTIONS AND I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LA FOR LEADERSHIP IN THE SPACE.
FOR THE YOUTH JUSTICE FOR YOU
YOUTH YET DOES JUSTICE WE ARE
INVESTING THIRTY MILLION. ON
GOING TO THE NEW OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
TO IMPROVE YOU THOUGHT BECAUSE
THEY REDUCE RACIAL DISPARITIES.
ALL ALONG THE YOUTH JUSTICE
SYSTEM CONTINUUM. FOR LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY WE ARE INVESTING
IN PUBLIC DEFENDERS MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED MILLION OUT OF
READY OF GUN VIOLENCE
REDUCTIONS AND A PILOT TO
VALLEYPROSECUTOR INITIATING.
RESENTENCING FOUR JUSTICES OF
THE MODERN THE VISUALS WE ARE
MAKING A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
IN SUPPORTING SUCCESSFUL RE
ENTRY INCLUDING MORE FUNDING
FOR HEALTH SEEM. AN EMPLOYMENT
SUPPORT REMOVING BARRIERS TO
HOUSING AND EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING FAMILY CONNECTION ALL
OF THESE THINGS THAT RESEARCH
AND DATA INDICATED REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. AND FINALLY WE ARE
ENHANCING THE OVERSIGHT OF THE
PERSON TO THE INSPECTOR OF THE
GENERAL THROUGH THE OFFICE OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL. AND
REQUIRING CDCR TO CREATE A LONG
TERM PERCENT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT IN CLOSER PLAN TO
AVOID WASTEFUL SPENDING. AS A
WHOLE WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. FOR THE COMMUNITY AS A
WHOLE AND ENSURING THAT WE ARE
MEETING OUR PROMISES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS OUT THERE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I ALSO WANTED
TO ECHO MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
THE SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS GAVE ON
TO THANK FIRST OUR OUR VICE
CHAIR WHO PUT IN A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WORK THIS YEAR AS
WELL AS OUR FIVE CHAIR FIVE
SUBJECT TO JUST PRESENTED VERY
THOUGHTFUL- BUDGET APPROACHES
IN EACH OF THEIR SUBCOMMITTEES
I ALSO WANT TO THANK JESUS IS
NETHER SPEAKS THE SPEAKERS
BUDGET DIRECTOR AS WELL AS
JOCHEN STOCK IN THE REPUBLICAN
FISCAL TEAM. ALSO WANTED
KNOWLEDGE CHRISTIAN GRIFFITH
NICOLE VASQUEZ IS HERE ON THE
REST OF OUR ASSEMBLY THOUGHT
BUDGET STAFF AS WELL AS MY
PERSONAL STAFF WHO HAD TO PUT
IN AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
WORK THIS YEAR I ALSO WANNA I
THANK SENATOR SKINNER AND HER
SENATE BUDGET STUFF AS WELL AS
THE TEAM AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE TEAM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THESE HEARINGS WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO BE HELD WITHOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER
ASSEMBLY TV LET'S COUNCIL ARE
SERGEANTS AND OF COURSE THE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS. SO THOSE
THANKS LET ME GO AHEAD AND OPEN
IT UP TO QUESTIONS I BELIEVE
AMY JARVIS AND- SONYA PADDOCK
ALL ARE HERE THE MAJORITY FROM
FROM THE FINANCE AND MISS
BENNET FROM LET THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S. OFFICE ANY QUESTIONS
MISTER CHIP. LET ME JUST START
BY ALSO EXPLAINED THE MANY
THANKS- FOR OUR CHAIR FOR
VERTICALLY FOR BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FOR OUR OUR
CHAIRWOMAN. OUR STAFF AND ALL
OF US FOR ENGAGING WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS DURING THIS
PROCESS. I'M JUST GONNA MAKE A
COUPLE OF BRIEF COMMENTS ON TWO
TOPICS HAVING TO DO WITH BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR. UP
FIRST WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS I AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE THAT THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. FINALLY BEGINS TO MAKE
A HISTORIC COMMITMENT TO AN
ONGOING INVESTMENT. IN
HOMELESSNESS SOLUTIONS AND
HOUSING. AND I'M PARTICULARLY
PLEASED- TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE WILL BE CRITICAL
ACCOUNTABILITY ELEMENTS WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR HOMELESSNESS
EXPENDITURES AND PRIORITIES.
THIS IS SOMETHING I'VE HEARD.
CONSISTENTLY IN RECENT YEARS IN
THE MIDST OF. THE MOST INTENSE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS INTERSTATES
HISTORY THAT AS WE ARE. MOVING
OUT HISTORIC INVESTMENTS- THAT
WE DO IT WITH WITH KHIMETRICS-
AND REAL ACCOUNTABILITY- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WILL BE-
ELEMENTS OF HOW WE FUND A DATA
DRIVEN SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT. LIKE
REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE GAPS
NEEDS ANALYSIS WHICH WILL HELP
PROVIDE US WITH TOOLS TO
SUPPORT LONG TERM PLANNING
EFFORTS. AND TO REALLY IDENTIFY
WHAT IT'S GONNA TAKE TO
FUNCTIONALLY AND HOMELESSNESS.
EIGHT THAT THERE ARE ALSO GONNA
BE ELEMENTS OF HOW WE LEVERAGE
EXISTING INVESTMENTS TO CREATE
BETTER REGIONAL COORDINATION
AND ALSO HOW DO WE CREATE REAL.
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES THAT
INCENTIVIZE REALISTIC GOAL
SETTING AND CARROTS AND STICKS
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
SPEND FUNDS WITHURGENCY AND
WITH AN EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACH. I ALSO WANT TO JUST
TAKE A MOMENT AND APPRECIATE
THE FOCUS IN THIS BUDGET ON THE
ON GOING CHALLENGES AT EDT. I
THINK FOR MANY OF US ON BUDGET
SUB FOR WE'VE SPENT COUNTLESS
HOURS PREPARING FOR AND
PARTICIPATING IN OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS. AND IT'S REFRESHING
TO SEE SOME REAL SOLUTIONS AND
MEANINGFUL FUNDING IN THIS
BUDGET- AND THE FACT THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE. IS ASKING- THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE EVEN
MORE INVESTMENTS IN THIS AREA-
I WANTED JUST PARTICULARLY CALL
OUT THE FUNDING TO ADDRESS
ISSUES OF LANGUAGE ACCESS. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE. OF LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY HAVE CONTINUED
SUPPORT DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD. I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO BE DONE
AND THAT THE PROPOSAL'S IN THIS
BUDGET WON'T SOLVE EVERYTHING
OVERNIGHT. BUT THESE ARE
IMPORTANT FIRST STEPS AND I
REALLY WANTED JUST AGAIN THANK
OUR LEADERSHIP. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THIS
CONVERSATION WITH THAT- I WILL
PASS BACK TO THE CHURCH. THE
COMMISSION SHE WOULD GO TO GO
TO MR MEDINA NEXT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR JUST A SHORT
COMMENT TO COMMUNICATE HOW
PLEASE I AM WITH THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE BUDGET- IN
PARTICULAR I AM THANKFUL TO THE
BUDGET CHAIR. AND THE CHAIR OF
SAID TO FOR THE FOLLOWING. THE
EDUCATOR AFFECTED OF BLOCK
GRANT WHICH INCLUDES ETHNIC
STUDIES PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION. RELATED TO
ETHNIC STUDIES THE RESTORATION
OF UC AND CSU FINES AND THE
FUNDING OF YOU SEE PRIME. THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. THE SUPPORT FOR
PROJECT REBOUND STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS AND FOR LIMITING
ELIMINATING THE CALIBRATE
COLLEGE. INCREASING SUPPORT FOR
WEDNESDAY AND MESSA. FINALLY
I'M ALSO GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSAL FOR
FUNDING AND REFORMING. CAL
GRANT. THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE
CHAIR AND TO THE STAFF FOR ALL
THEIR WORK AND FOR ENGAGING ON
THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES. THANK
YOU WERE GOING TO MISTER RAMOS
FROM THEM TO MISTER FRAZIER.
KIM MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK
YOU TO- SUB ONE CHAIR JOAQUIN
ARAMBULA. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THERE- I HAVE A SOME COMMENTS
ON ON A- ON A BUDGET ITEM THAT
CAME OUT IN THE MAY REVISION IT
DEALS WITH LPS AND
CONSERVANCIES- THAT STARTING ON
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. N.
PHASE IN THE RETURN OF ALL LPS-
CONSERVANCIES- SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY IN
THE STATE HOSPITALS TO THE
COUNTIES OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. THIS IS A SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO PUT A BURDEN ON
THE COUNTIES THAT WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT WITHIN THE MENTAL
HEALTH COMPONENT THAT WE'VE
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR ON THESE
ISSUES- CERTAINLY IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO. LOOK
AT- INTO THE POPULATION THAT'S
THERE IN UNDER THE PROPOSAL
DOES EXIST TODAY COUNTIES WOULD
BE EXPECTEDTO FIND LOCAL
PLACEMENTS FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS. OUT OF THE STATE-
HOSPITALS INTO THE COUNTY THEN
GIVING A BURDEN TO THE
COUNTIES- TO FIND AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IN MANY
TIMES DOES NOT EVEN EXIST.
THERE IS GREATER PLANNING- WHEN
COUNTIES WERE EXPECTED TO
TRANSITION INTO THIS ROLE WITH
OTHER- ITEMS OTHER ISSUES THAT
CAME FORWARD. BUT NOW PUTTING
ALL THIS BURDEN AT OUR CUNTY
LEVELS TO EASE THE BURDEN THAT
OUR STATE HOSPITALS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD. BE
LOOKING AT AND ADVOCATING FOR
ESPECIALLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHEN THIS INFRASTRUCTURE ISN'T
THERE YOU'VE HEARD ME SPEAK ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH COMPONENT I
WANT TO THANK- THE COMMITTEES
IN THIS BUDGET FOR.
ACKNOWLEDGING THE YOUTH IN THE
MENTAL SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED
BUT IF WE HAVE TO NOW START TO
LOOK AT A INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MANY TIMES DOES NOT EVEN EXIST
AND LET THE LOCAL LEVELS NOW.
TAKE ON THAT BURDEN OF THOSE-
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN THE
TATE HOSPITALS THEN WE'RE
GOING TO SEE A BIG- DRAIN AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL ON THOSE
SERVICES THAT ARE THERE. AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE A MORE ADVOCACY
TO BRING THAT TOPIC UP FOR A
GREATER PLAN. WHEN THESE TYPES
OF THINGS CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD TO THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER ROBERTS MR FRAZIER
AND THE MYSTERY OF US. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. YOU
KNOW FIRST AND FOREMOST I NEED
TO THANK. ALL MY SIBLINGS HERE
MISTER RANDALL- AND ALSO OUR
BUDGETARY MR TANG- FOR
ABSOLUTELY EMBRACING. A
COMPASSIONATE NEED FOR FUNDING
FOR THE SPECIAL NEEDS
POPULATION THE IDT OF
POPULATION THREE DDS. I'VE BEEN
A BROKEN RECORD FOR MANY YEARS
AND- AFTER THE RATE STUDY HAD.
HIT THE STREETS AND WE HAVE
BEEN ACKNOWLEDGING THAT WE HAD
BEEN DEFICIENT FOR SO MANY
YEARS. OF THIS FUNDING FOR THIS
POPULATION OF QUALITY OF LIFE
AND ADVANCING THEIR ABILITY TO
BE SUCCESSFUL. THAT THE
POLITICAL WILL HAD TURNED INTO.
A OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS
POPULATION. THE ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IS PHASED IN
OVER FOUR YEARS WITH A FEDERAL
MATCH SO IT'S NOT JUST A HIT ON
THE GENERAL FUND. BUT I WILL
LIKE TO SAY I LOVE THE ABILITY
FOR. A BEING PHASED IN BECAUSE
AS MY COLLEAGUE. OF OVER THERE
AS STATED. THAT THE SAN MANUEL
TRIBE- THAT IT WAS. ABOUT A
PHASE IN ABOUT AN ABILITY TO DO
SO AND EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT
PREPARED FOR THAT INFLUX OF
MONEY THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY
HAVE TO SPEND IT ALL IN ONE
YEAR THEY CAN ROLL OVER TO THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR TO AUGMENT
THAT THAT. THAT YEAR. ON ONE OF
THE OTHER THINGS IS THAT- WITH
THE DESPERATE NEED FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION EARLY START.
SOCIAL WRECKING CAMP. ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
DEPLETED. IN THE STATE HAS BEEN
AFFECT FITTED FROM THE
DECIMATION OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS OVER THE YEARS. THERE
WAS NO RECIPROCATION TO THE
POPULATION. AND I WOULD JUST
ADD THAT KNOWING THAT. THE
SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATION WE ARE.
THE LEGISLATURE THEIR CARE
CARETAKERS FIRST AND FOREMOST
TO COME FROM HERE HOW WE FUND
THE ABILITY FOR THEM TO BE
TAKEN CARE OF ALL ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MEMBERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE. FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND I CAN'T THANK
THIS BODY ENOUGH FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS
POPULATION HAS BEEN. IN
DESPERATE NEED AND NOW. WE CAN
BE PROUD TO SAY WE STEPPED UP.
AND WE DID OUR JOB. MISTER
CHANG THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR HELP THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL YOU HAD A. TWENTY SO.
SO SOME OF THE DATA SECOND
THANK YOU OF. WE'RE GONNA
BEFORE WE GO TO- MISS REVERSE I
BELIEVE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DID WANT TO MAKE A BRIEF
STATEMENT SO LET ME START THIS
MAKE THAT STATEMENT. AND THE
QUESTION MAKE IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
CAROTENE VICE CHAIR FONG AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
JARVIS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANKS FOR GIVING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT ON
THE ASSEMBLY'S BUDGET PLAN I
WILL BE BRIEF. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY TO COME TO
A FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS. THAT IS
STRUCTURALLY BALANCED MAINTAINS
BUDGET RESILIENCE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY INVESTMENT AND
MEETS THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY THOSE HOUSEHOLDS
MOST IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC.
LIKE THE MERRY VISION THE
ASSEMBLY'S PLAN PROJECTS
REVENUE GROWTH ALBEIT AT A
HIGHER LEVEL GOING TO ABOUT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS MORE
THAN THE MERE ENVISIONED BY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. IN OUR
ESTIMATION THE USE OF HIGHER
REVENUE PROJECTIONS INTRODUCES
A GREATER DEGREE OF FISCAL
RISKS TO THE BUDGET IN THE OUT
YEARS. ESPECIALLY IF THOSE
FUTURE PROJECTED REVENUE
SUPPORT FURTHER ONGOING
SPENDING. CALIFORNIA'S REVENUE
PROJECTIONS ARE SUBJECT TO A
HIGH LEVEL OF VOLATILITY THIS
IS DUE TO THE FACT THAT THE
HIGHEST INCOME CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUE TO PAY A SIGNIFICANT
SHARE THE STATE INCOME TAX. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE TOP 1% OF
EARNERS ACCOUNTED FOR OVER
FORTY BURKE 46% OF ALL PERSONAL
INCOME TAXES. THAT'S JUST OVER
A HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND TAX
RETURNS. A CORRECTION IN THE
STOCK MARKET NOT EVEN A
RECESSION COULD RESULT IN
SERIOUS NEGATIVE IMPACTS TO
REVENUES. ON TOP OF THIS
NATURAL VOLATILITY THERE'S ALSO
MUCH UNCERTAINTY AROUND
BUILDING THIS BUDGET COMPARED
TO OTHER BUDGETS. BECAUSE OF
THE INFLUX OF SIGNIFICANT
FEDERAL FUNDING AND THE
INCOMING RULES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE USE OF THESE FUNDS. THIS IS
EVIDENCED IN EVENTS HAVE
UNFOLDED SUBSEQUENT TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A REVISION. THE
RECENTLY RELEASED FEDERAL
GUIDELINES FOR THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT OR ARAFAT THE
ADMINISTRATION LEARNED THAT TO
CHILD CARE PROPOSALS INCLUDED
IN AMERICA ASIAN. CANNOT RELY
ON THOSE FUNDS AND THEN OUT
WILL NOW REQUIRE I'M PLAN
GENERAL FUND BACKED BILLS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. AND BEYOND TO
MAINTAIN THESE IMPORTANT
PROPOSALS. THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE UNCERTAINTY
BEHIND PROPOSALS FOR WHICH
GUIDELINES WILL BE PROMULGATED
LATER THAT COULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT HELP YOUR IMPACTS
EVEN AFTER FINAL BUDGET HAS
BEEN PASSED. THE MERE INVASIONS
OF REVENUE FORECAST IS MORE
CAUTIOUS THAN THE ALLEY OWES TO
COUNT FOR THESE RISKS. THE MAIN
REVISIONS BUDGET STRUCTURE
LIKEWISE IS PROMISED ON ONE
TIME SPENDING OVER ONGOING
SPENDING WITH 90% OF
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING BEING
ONE TIME. AND ONLY 10% INVESTED
IN TARGETED ON GOING
PRIORITIES. THIS APPROACH
ENABLES US TO PULL BACK REDUCE
ONE TIME EXPENDITURES WHILE
ONGOING COMMITMENTS MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT TO QUICKLY
UNWIND OR CUT ONGOING
ENTITLEMENT STATUTORY OR
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATIONS.
SHOULD THE STATE NEED TO
RESPOND IMMEDIATELY TWENTY GOLD
NEGATIVE FISCAL. THAT SAID
THERE ARE MANY SHARE PRIORITIES
ON BOTH THE ASSEMBLY'S PLAN IN
THE MAY REVISION AGAIN THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE DETAILS OF THIS
EXTRAORDINARY ONCE IN A.
GENERATION BUDGET THAT WILL
SUPPORT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT THESE
COMMENTS THE COMMITTEE MY
COLLEAGUES AND I ARE AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU MR
AS WE GO BACK TO. THIS REVERSE
AND THEN TO MISTER SMITH. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- FIRST I'D
LIKE TO START BY THANKING. OUR
CHAIR- AND ARE. ALL THE BUDGET
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK. ON
THIS AMAZING BUDGET A ONCE IN A
LIFETIME I THINK. A BUDGET I'M
VERY PROUD TO SERVE ON THIS
COMMITTEE. I WANT TO ALSO
THANK. OUR BUDGET SUB TO CHAIR
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO.
FOR SUPPORTING UNIVERSAL SCHOOL
MEALS- THAT THAT HAS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE WORKED ON
AND IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME AND
I'M GLAD. THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT NO CHILD. IS
HUNGRY IN A CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
AND THAT WE WILL BE THE FIRST
IN THE NATION TO DO THAT- I WAS
ALSO VERY HAPPY TO SEE. AN
INVESTMENT- AT CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE WHICH IS-
VERY CLOSE TO MY DISTRICT IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. FOR A
CENTER FOR EQUITY AND
INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY- VERY
PROUD- THAT THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY WILL HOST. OF THIS
INNOVATION CENTER THAT WILL
HELP YOUNG PEOPLE ACROSS THE
STATE. ARE IN TERMS OF. ANOTHER
ISSUE AREA THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON HAS BEEN
HOMELESSNESS- I'D LIKE TO THANK
OUR CHAIR AND OF COURSE OUR
BUDGET SUB CHAIR- FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR THE SIGNIFICANT
WORK ON HOMELESSNESS. THIS YEAR
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS- AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN FIGHTING
TO ENSURE WITH THAT WE INCLUDE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS. TO
COMBAT HOMELESSNESS BOTH
THROUGH POLICY AND THROUGH THE
BUDGET. I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS OF THE
BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
COALITION. AND OUR MAYORS FOR
THEIR AMAZING ADVOCACY I'M
THANKFUL THAT OUR ASSEMBLY
LEADERSHIP RECOGNIZE THAT NOW
IS THE TIME TO INVEST HEAVILY
IN PROGRAMS THAT ARE PROVEN. TO
REDUCE OUR HOMELESS POPULATION.
WE STILL HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF WORK AHEAD OF US OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT THE LANGUAGE.
ACCOMPANYING THESE BUDGET
INVESTMENTS ENSURES
ACCOUNTABILITY IN LOCAL AND
STATE USE OF THE FUNDS AND
ADVANCES NECESSARY STRUCTURAL
REFORMS TO ENSURE EFFICIENCY.
OF THESE ALLOCATED FUNDS. I'D
LIKE TO BE CLEAR THAT. ARE AS
WHEN WE STARTED THIS YEAR
THINKING WE WERE GOING INTO A
RECESSION AND ENDED UP WITH A
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BILLION
SURPLUS YOU KNOW. I THINK IT
SHOWS THAT OUR OUR STATE
REVENUES FLUCTUATE GREATLY AND
WE NEED AN ONGOING BUDGET
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS EVEY YEAR- I
SERVE I AM VERY LUCKY TO SERVE
ON BUDGET SUB THREE- I'D LIKE
TO THANK OUR CHAIR FROM SANTA
MONICA- NOW THAT I AM CHAIR OF
NATURAL RESOURCES IT'S GREAT TO
SERVE ON BOTH. THE BUDGET AND
POLICY COMMITTEES I'M AND YOU
KNOW. I I'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON
PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE- WE HAVE SUFFERED THE
MOST. ESPECIALLY DURING COLD
BED WITH MUCH HIGHER RATE OF
LOST JOBS EVICTIONS AND
UTILITIES THAT. NO CURRENTLY
THERE HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS IN
EXISTING FUNDS FOR SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO THESE COMMUNITIES
BUT WE'RE NOT EFFECTIVELY.
CONNECT IN THESE INDIVIDUALS
WITH THESE FREE RESOURCES LIKE
UTILITY BILL SAVINGS CLEAN
AFFORDABLE ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION REBATES. ARE
IT'LL ALSO- I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
CONCERNS ON. THE ABANDONED
WELLS THE BUDGET THAT THE
BUDGET ITEM. AB IF THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL TO
SHIFT WHO PAYS FOR THE PLUGGING
AND ABANDONING OF OIL AND GAS
WELLS- TRADITIONALLY WE'VE MADE
OIL COMPANIES PAY TO PLUG AND
ABANDON ORPHANED OIL AND GAS
WELLS- BUT THIS YEAR- THERE IS
A SHIFT ON WHO'S PAYING FOR THE
PLUGGING AND ABANDONING OF
THESE WELLS- SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THIS
RATIONALE FOR THE SHIFT AND
EVALUATE WHETHER IT MAKES
SENSE. AND I HOPE THAT IN THE
NEXT COMING WEEKS WE CAN COME
UP YOU KNOW SOMEONE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN EXPLAIN THE
SHAFT AND MAKING OF THE PUBLIC
FISCAL. RESPONSIBILITY FOR OIL
COMPANIES ABANDONMENT OF AN
UNUSED OIL WELL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO GO TO
MR FONG AND THEN MISTER SMITH.
I THINK WE SHOULD CARE- I DID
WANT TO ASK A FEW QUESTIONS
SINCE WE HAVE FOLKS- THE MEDIAN
AND I'M- MISTER PECK AB. ON THE
OTHER LINE MAYBE ACCESS- MR
PADDICK. YOU'VE DONE AN
ANALYSIS- ON THE GOVERNOR'S
REVISION WHAT IS YOUR INITIAL
TAKE ON THIS FRAMEWORK. GOOD
EVENING- CAROLINE SHOOT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
IN JAPAN I'M SORRY MISS MR
PANIC I WAS IN THAT THE SENATE
HEARING AND THEREFORE COULD NOT
LOG ON TO ON TO THE HEARING-
THIS AFTERNOON NO WORRIES CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY I'M SORRY
WE HAVE WE ARE ONLY RECEIVE THE
DETAILS OF THE LEGISLATURE
PACKAGE- A DAY OR TWO AGO WE
HAVEN'T HAD AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
ABSOLUTELY- GET OUR ARMS AROUND
THE WHOLE THING YOU DO IS YOU
ARE SPENDING PLAN. OUT ONCE-
THE FINAL PACKAGE IS- ADAPTED
AND SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
WHICH WE TEND TO DO LATER IN
JULY. I AND THEN FINAL ACTIONS
IN OCTOBER. SO I KNOW YOU I
KNOW IT'S REAL TO ME DO YOU DO
YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
THOUGHTS OR- IN TERMS OF. WHAT
KIND OF. SPEEDING THROUGH THIS
REVIEW BUT WE'RE NOT REALLY
DOING A REVIEWS SO I LIKE AND
IF THEY'RE SENT. IF THERE'S A
THE PERSPECTIVE FROM THE L. L.
A. IT CERTAINLY WOULD BE- IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. SURE SO WE
AGAIN WE HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO A FULL
ASSESSMENT OF THE EXPENDITURES
ARE OR GET OUR ARMS AROUND THE
ENTIRE THING- I COULD. YOU KNOW
KNOW THAT THEIR PACKAGE DOESN'T
DROPPED OUR REVENUE ESTIMATES
ON WHICH AS THE- WORK WAS
ALREADY NOTED ARE- A GROWTH IT
FASTER THAN BY THOSE- PRESENTED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION AND AS
WE'VE NOTED IN. OUR VARIOUS
WRITE UPS- WE BELIEVE. I HAVE
UP HAVE ESSENTIALLY A FIFTY
FIFTY CHANCE OF- MATERIALIZING-
AND SO THEY ARE BASED ON THE
HISTORICAL GROWTH RATES AFTER
REVENUES IN THE STATE ACTUALLY
A LITTLE BIT LOWER- ACCOUNTING
FOR SOME POLICIES THAT WILL
TURN OFF SO WE ASSUME REVENUES
WERE GROWING ABOUT FOUR
PERCENT- IN THE- OUT YEARS-
WHICH- WHICH CAN SUPPORT-
HIGHER. SPENDING THEN UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S ESTIMATES- AND AGAIN
AS WE'VE STATED HISTORICALLY
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD CHOOSE
ITS REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES
BASED ON ITS- ON ITS RISK
TOLERANCE AND WANTING TO SPEAK
IS WILL HAPPEN IN FUTURE YEARS.
OKAY LET OF THEM ASK YOU A
SPECIFICALLY AND IN TERMS THE-
TO YOUR PREVIOUS ANALYSIS SO
THE- THE CERTAINLY THE THAT. MR
PECK MADE SAM HEADLINES- IN
TERMS OF. BEING L. SOMEWHAT
CRITICAL OF THE GOVERNOR'S
VISION. OF USING- BUDGET TOOLS-
RESERVE WITHDRAWALS AND
BORROWING- BUT THEN ALSO- WITH
THE GOVERNOR WAS ALSO USING
THAT TO CONTINUE SPENDING THAT-
THIS FRAMEWORK MY UNDERSTANDING
DOESN'T UNDO THAT SO THAT WAS
THAT WOULD THAT CONCERNS STILL
REMAIN. REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
IT'S THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OR
IN THIS FRAMEWORK. THIS PACKAGE
TAKES SOME SOME DIFFERENT
ACTIONS IN ORDER TO- AT BUILD
SOME ADDITIONAL BUDGET
RESILIENCY SO IT- UNDERLIES THE
REMAINING DEFERRALS- TO SCHOOLS
WHICH IS ABOUT TWO POINT SIX
BILLION I BELIEVE IT ALSO
PREPARES ABOUT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF BOND DEBT. AND
MAKES AN ADDITIONAL- SAFETY NET
RESERVE DEPOSIT- I BELIEVE
AROUND AROUND A BILLION
DOLLARS- SO IT TAKES DIFFERENT
ACTIONS TO PROVIDE MORE BUDGET
RESILIENCY- AND THE LEGISLATURE
FACES CHOICES ABOUT HOW IT
WANTS TO PREPARE FOR A FUTURE
RECESSION. OKAY IN TERMS OF-
AND I AGREE I THINK THAT THE-
THE PROPOSAL TO PAY DOWN- THE
DEFERRALS IS- IS A COURSE THAT-
WE AS THE LEGISLATURE WE SHOULD
DO HI SO I CERTAINLY OF- I
THINK THAT THAT'S- A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION- IN TERMS.
OF. THE MAYBE I CAN MAYBE THIS
QUESTION IS BETTER DRESSED- TO
THE POVERTY FINANCED BUT- WHAT
IS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OR
THE JUSTIFICATION OF NOT- OF
NOT REVERSING THE- TO TAX
INCREASES FROM FROM LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- WE SIR I THINK THE
FRAMEWORK AND IN THIS BUDGET
DOESN'T- THE TAXI HOUSES AS
WELL SO. MAYBE YOU CAN MAYBE I
CAN JUST UNDERSTAND THE
PERSPECTIVE OF WE WERE AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION LAST YEAR
THE PROJECTIONS WERE WHAT THEY
WERE AND THEY WERE ENDED UP.
BEING TOO LOW BUT NOW THAT
WE'RE KIND OF IN THIS NEW
ENVIRONMENT WHY WOULD WE NOT-
UNDER THE TAX INCREASES IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. AND I'M GONNA
TURN THIS ONE OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE RYAN MILLER. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RYAN MILLER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD YOU
MIND PERHAPS CLARIFYING WHICH
TAX INCREASES ARE ARE YOU
REFERRING TO- I BELIEVE THAT-
THE LEGISLATURE TAKE ACTION ON
THAT OPERATING LOSSES ON
REMOVALS OF TAX CREDITS AND
CLEAN THE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT- SO. THAT I THINK
WAS A NINETY NINE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN. HAND TAX
INCREASES IN THE PREVIOUS
BUDGET I WAS DONE NOW THAT
WE'RE IN THIS NEW ENVIRONMENT
WHY WOULD WE NOT AND DO THOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION- SO AS YOU NOTED-
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET DID. AND
CERTAIN TAX CREDITS AVAILABLE-
GENERALLY TO LARGER
CORPORATIONS I THINK I THINK IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S JUDGMENT-
THOSE ACTIONS- AFFECTED-
ENTITIES THAT- TENDED TO BE AS
I SAID KIND OF LARGER
CORPORATIONS INTENDED TO- ALSO-
IN MANY CASES BE ENTITIES THAT
WERE SORT OF WEATHERING THE
PANDEMIC RELATIVELY WELL AND IN
OUR- JUDGMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET NAY REVISION- WE
ATTEMPTED TO FOCUS MORE ON. A
SMALL BUSINESSES- CERTAIN- YOU
KNOW BUSINESS ENTITIES THAT MAY
BE STRUGGLING TO A GREATER
EXTENT IN THE PANDEMIC- SO I
THINK THAT'S ESSENTIALLY AND
NOT SHELL AND THAT AND THAT'S
WHY WE PRIORITIZE THINGS LIKE-
YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES PROPOSAL- THE FILM
CREDIT EXPANSION AND- AND OTHER
SIMILAR PROPOSALS OVER
RESTORING THE- THE ACTIONS THAT
YOU MENTIONED. SO WAS THAT A
JUSTIFICATION OF THAT YOU'D
THAT THOSE TAX INCREASES OR
DOES HE USE A POSTPONEMENTS
THEY'RE NEVER GOING AWAY- OR IT
WITH. THE GOVERNOR. AGREE THAT
AT SOME POINT THEY NEED TO GO
AWAY FOR THE THEY NEED TO BE
REVERSED. I BELIEVE THEY WERE
TEMPORARY SUSPENSIONS I DON'T
KNOW IF- CAROLINE ARE YOU FROM
THE ELLIA COULD SPEAK TO THAT-
BUT BUT- YES THIS IS CAROLYN
SURE AGAIN THEY ARE TEMPORARY
TAX INCREASES UNABLE TO TURN
THEY WERE FOR THREE YEARS- SO I
BELIEVE THAT MEANS IN TURN OFF
AND- TWENTY. THREE TWENTY PARK.
OKAY BUT BUT THOSE THAT THREE
YEAR TIME FRAME WAS OF COURSE
THE UNCERTAINTY OF LAST YEAR.
SO NOW WE HAVE THE REVENUE
PROJECTIONS THIS YEAR HICH IS
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER SO IS
THERE OF. HIS AT SOME POINT
WHAT WHEN WOULD THAT BE
REASSESSED. BY THE LEVI YEAH I
FIGURED OUT THAT IF YOU LEAVE
THE TAX INCREASES TO FOR THEIR
FOR TWO MORE YEARS. I THINK I
WOULD JUST GO BACK TO MY PRIOR
COMMENTS ABOUT SORT OF THE
RELATIVE FOCUS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TAX PROPOSALS
AND IN THIS BUDGET MAYOR
VISION. OKAY THEN THAT ACTUALLY
TO ME TO THE NEXT QUESTION I
THINK YOU TEED IT UP VERY WELL
SO THE FOCUS ON SMALL
BUSINESSES. SO THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES- BUT PROPOSED ABOUT
ONE POINT ONE BILLION TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S TWENTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FUND DEBT. AT THIS
FRAMEWORK I THINK TAKES A
DIFFERENT APPROACH AND-
PROVIDES TRY TO PROVIDE THEM
ASSEMBLY- ASSISTANCE TO SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND IN A DIFFERENT
WAY- BUT- AS WE'VE SEEN FROM
PREVIOUS SITUATIONS WHERE BOND
DEBT OR THAT YOU HAD YOU I FIND
THAT- OCCURRED TO AND IT I
THINK IT TOOK TEN YEARS TO PAY
OFF THE DEBT FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION BEFORE- AND- THAT
LEAD THAT THE DEBT RIGHT NOW
WILL LEAD TO A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN BUSINESSES. PAYROLL
TAXES- SMALL BUSINESSES AS YOU
MENTIONED. SO WHAT WOULD THE
GOVERNOR SAY IN TERMS OF SICK
PUTTING MORE MONEY. OR TAKING
CARE OF THE TWENTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR DEBT. THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS IN THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FUND. AND I'M GONNA
TURN THAT WENT OVER TO MR CHRIS
COOK. COULD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO NUMBER IT IT MAYBE
IF YOU CAN HELP ME CLARIFY YOUR
QUESTION AND FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND- FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE IS PROPOSING TO PROVIDE
TO TWO BILLION OVER SEVERAL
YEARS- FOR- TAX CREDITS FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES. RIGHT SO I
LOOK I'VE MICHAEL I HAVE MY
CONCERNS WITH THIS LEGISLATIVE
FRAMEWORK AS WELL I THINK THAT
THIS ARE LEGISLATIVE FRAMEWORK
SHOULD OFFICE ALSO TAKE CARE OF
THE TWENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
YOU I FIND IT SO AS THE
LEGISLATURE NEGOTIATES WITH
YOU- I GOT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. IS THERE AN AGREEMENT
THAT THERE SHOULD BE- A
SIGNIFICANT- INVESTMENT IN
TAKING CARE OF THE DATE OF THE
TWENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR.
DEBT THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS IN
THE U. I. FUND OR DO YOU
DISAGREE WITH THE FRAMEWORK.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS PUT
TOGETHER AND YOU WOULD GO BACK
TO- WHAT YOU GUYS PROPOSED. WHY
I THINK THOSE CONVERSATIONS YOU
KNOW. HAPPY TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IN THE COMING
WEEKS ON YOU KNOW THE
PRIORITIES. I WILL SAY THAT THE
ONE BILLION- IN THE- FEDERAL
DOLLARS OVER SIXTY TWO ARCA.
WAS BALANCE SEEN THE OTHER
PRIORITIES THAT THAT THEY ADMIT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAD
WITH THE USE OF THOSE FUNDS.
AND SO WE FELT THAT ONE BILLION
ABOUT ONE BILLION DOLLARS WAS
AN INVESTMENT THAT COULD BE
MADE OUT TO HELP ALLEVIATE SOME
OF THE PRESSURE ON THE U. LIKE
THAT. BUT AGAIN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE IN
THE COMING WEEKS ON. WHAT THOSE
PARTIES LOOK LIKE BY THE WAY.
OKAY I WOULD JUST ARGUE THAT
THAT MAY WAITING WE SHOULD WE
AS THE LEGISLATIVE BODY AND WE
AS AN INDIGO STATIONS IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU SHOULD.
LOOK AT A MORE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT AND I THINK THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS OF THE CHAIR WILL
HAVE- WITH THE SENATE AND WITH
THE WITH THE MINISTRATION I
JUST. THINK THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT- CHALLENGE THAT
WHERE WE SEE WE UNDERSTAND IT'S
HAPPENED IN THE PAST AND-
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO- THE HAVE TO ADDRESS I
ALSO ONE ECHO- THE ISSUE THAT
IS PART OF MY COLLEAGUES AROUND
US- THE LPS- ISSUE IS. IS THIS
THE BEST THING TO FIGURE OUT
WHETHER WE'RE GONNA DEAL WITH
AS WELL I JUST WANNA AND BY
SAYING THAT- IN TERMS OF-
PUBLIC SAFETY IS THIS A FIVE-
IF. IF I COULD ASK- THE
DIFFERENT FINANCE IN TERMS OF
THE OFFICE OF YOU THINK
COMMITTEE RESTORATION AND THE-
DJJ REALIGNMENT- WHAT IS THE
CURRENT PROCESS- CURRENTLY-
WITH THIS NEW OFFICE AND WHAT'S
THE CURRENT STATUS IF YOU DON'T
ME ASKING. I'M SO THE OFFICE IS
ESTABLISHED ON JULY FIRST
PURSUANT TO STATUTE AND WE HAVE
A MAJOR REVISION PROPOSAL I'M
THAT AUGMENTED THE OFFICE- IN
ADDITION TO WHAT WE HAD
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. I THINK ADAM DORSEY
MIGHT BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO THE
DETAILS OF THAT PROPOSAL AND
WITH THAT SAID THE LEGISLATURE
HAS ADDED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR THE OFFICE- ANYTHING WE'RE
STILL WORKING THROUGH THE
DETAILS OF THAT- THAT
AUGMENTATION. OKAY GO IT IS
THERE IS ANY MORE INFORMATION
THAT I YOU MUCH AS SOMEONE ELSE
I APOLOGIZE IF I GOT THE ONE OF.
SURE THIS IS ADAM DORSEY-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- THAT
REVISION AT INCLUDE SEVEN POINT
SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND- IN
THE BUDGET YOU'RE IN THIRTY
THREE POSITIONS FOR THE OFFICE.
OKAY I DID WANT TO APPLY THE A
TEN MILLION DOLLARS EMERGENCY
FUNDING THROUGH THE OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES- TO SUPPORT-
THE ACTIVITIES TO PREVENT.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING I THINK
THAT'S- NEEDED INVESTMENT.
ESPECIALLY DURING THE DOWNTURN-
YOU KNOW NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAPPENS-
SERVING HIS VICTIMS THEY'VE
BEEN- AFFECTED AS WELL. AND YOU
KNOW HUMAN TRAFFICKING HAS
CERTAINLY GOTTEN WORSE AND
AFFECTING COMMUNITIES OF OLOR
OVER THE PANDEMIC- I DID WHAT I
ALSO WANT TO JUST SAY THAT THE
DROUGHT- IN RESILIENCE PACKAGE
AND THE- THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION RESILIENCE. PACKAGE%
THOSE DETAILS OF THEM HAVEN'T
BEEN FLESHED OUT SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT AS WE VOTE FOR.
THESE PROPOSALS THAT WE DON'T
KNOW HOW THAT'S- HOUSE WHAT THE
SPECIFICS ARE AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
EMPHASIZE- AND ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO DROUGHT AND WATER
RESILIENCE- AND SIGMA. WE NEED.
TO BE INVESTING IN WATER
STORAGE. AND WATER AND FIRST-
WE HAVE OPPORTUNITY IN THE
PAST- THAT I BELIEVE THE STATE
WASTED- WITH THE WATER FOR THE
WATER BOND THAT THAT WAS
PASSED. THAT DID NOT- PUT IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN THIS
WATER STORAGE- AND SO I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD- LET
THIS OPPORTUNITY GO AND IF WE
IF WE DON'T INVEST IN WATER
STORAGE. WITH THE WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW- I THINK OUR STATE WILL
REGRET. THE LACK OF INVESTMENT
FOR THE NEXT DROUGHT COMES
AROUND. AND AND I THINK IT'S A
AND THE EFFECTS OF. A SIGMA
WILL BE- MORE SEVERE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE WE CANNOT
GET TO SUSTAINABILITY WHICH IS
WHAT SIGNAL WANTED. WITHOUT
THESE NEEDED INVESTMENTS SO.
WHILE WE HAVE THIS DEBATE-
RIGHT NOW- A LOT OF DETAILS ARE
STILL. NOT DONE AND THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE TO THE
PUBLIC- THAT A LOT OF WORK
STILL REMAINS IN SO WE AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY- NEED TO COME
TOGETHER TO FIND THOSE
SOLUTIONS SO I I'M OUT I'LL
TURN BACK OVER THE CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. IF YOU
WERE GONNA MISTER SMITH. THANK
YOU- I JUST WANT TO PUBLIC THAT
SO WATCH IT AT HOME THAT THE
THIS BUDGET HERE'S FOUR HUNDRED
PAGES. WE RECEIVED IT YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON ABOUT FOUR O'CLOCK SO
LITTLE OVER TWENTY FOUR HOURS
AGO TO GO THROUGH ALL THIS OF
BUDGET. PROPOSALS AND WERE
EXPECTED TO VOTE ON IT TONIGHT.
WHAT I WANT TO A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS WE HAD A
OF. THE PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING FOR CHARITY. AND THE
DEFERRALS FOR THE SCHOOLS- WE
WERE TOLD THAT THEY WERE ALL
PAID OFF OR WHEN ACID
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IF ALL
THE DEFERRALS THAT WERE OF
MONEY FROM THE SCHOOLS LAST
YEAR IS ALL BEING PAID BACK.
CHRIS FERGUSON WHAT FINANCED
UNDER THE ASSEMBLY SENATE
PACKAGE THERE ARE REPAYING ALL
THOSE DEFERRALS- THE
ADMINISTRATION PACKAGE STILL-
PUT FORWARD A SMALL REMAINING
TO PEARL IN THE K. TWELVE
SECTOR. BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL I WANTED CHAIRED THANK
CHAIRED PAYING FOR MAKING SURE
THAT THAT HAPPENS TO PAY OFF
THE DEFERRALS BECAUSE WE BORROW
MONEY AND WE DON'T PAY IT OFF
WE'RE NOT GETTING AHEAD OF THE
GAME HERE- IN THE COMMENTS
REGARDS THE WATER IN DROUGHT
RESILIENCE. THE THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN ROOM
OF BIKESHARE FONG JUST MENTION
IT THERE'S NO MINCING OF WATER
STORAGE. IS THERE ANY LANGUAGE
OR ANYONE CAN COMMENT TO THAT
FOR WATER STORAGE. NOW BECAUSE
OF PROP ONE A. BONDS- TEN YEARS
AGO WE GOT NO WATER STORAGE OUT
OF THAT IS ARE ANY. I THINK
ANYBODY THAT WANTS WATER
STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA. IN IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL THOSE
WE HAVE NOT IRONED OUT ALL THE
DETAILS IN THE WATER PACKAGE I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT IF THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD ANY- WATER
STORAGE IN THEIR PROPOSAL- AND
THEN- WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT WE
WOULD HAVE INPUT ON THIS
PACKAGE. I DON'T NOT SURE WHEN
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO VOTE ON IT
THIS EVENING AND I KNOW WE GOT
TILL- JUNE FIFTEENTH TO GET
THIS BUDGET. WHEN ARE WE GONNA
HAVE SOME LANGUAGE. THE
INCLUDES SEVERAL PACKAGES ALL
OVER TWENTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. BUT THERE'S NOT NOT NO
DETAILS. TO TELL AS A WONDER
WE'RE GOING TO BE A PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION. I GUESS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE A PART OF
A LAWSUIT YOU ARE- YOU'RE PART
OF THE CONVERSATION TODAY TO BE
A PART OF THE CONVERSATION
BETWEEN NOW AND- WHEN WE VOTE
ON THE BUDGET FOR JUNE
FIFTEENTH. KERN I WANT TO CHECK
THIS THANK MY CHAIR BLOOM FOR
SUB THREE FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK THIS YEAR. THE END OF IT'S
NOT EASY- EXPECTED FROM MY
POINT OF VIEW AND ANOTHER OF
THE SITUATION FOR THE BROADBAND.
THE OF IT WAS MENTIONED FROM
CHERRY BLOOM IT'S SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS OVER SEVEN YEARS. BUT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT MY RURAL
DISTRICT GETS OF ITS
PERCENTAGE. OF THAT MONEY. FOR
BROADBAND BECAUSE WE REALLY
NEEDED OUT THERE WITH THE KIDS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN TO SCHOOL IN
THE LAST YEAR. AND NOT HAVING
THE RESOURCES OF BROADBAND. UP
FOR EDUCATION THEY'VE LOST OVER
SIXTEEN MONTHS OF THEIR
EDUCATION BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT THEY WILL EVER GET BACK UP.
AND HOPEFULLY WE STAY IN THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE ARE GOING TO GO TO-
MISTER BENNETT AND INTO MR
GALLAGHER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR FOR MY PARTNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
pOUT THAT I APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
REMINDING US OR POINTING OUT TO
US JUST. OF THE IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION BETWEEN ONE TIME
FUNDING AND ONGOING FUNDING
BETWEENONE TIME REVENUE AND
ONGOING REVENUE AND THE
PARTICULAR NEED THAT WE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THAT BECAUSE OF
THE VARIABILITY. OF OUR BUDGET
BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME
THINGS THAT ARE BUDGET THAT ARE
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL THAT WE
FUND AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THAT CUSHION SO
THAT WE CAN ALWAYS KEEP THAT
FUNDING- MOVING FORWARD. SECOND
AB I REALLY APPRECIATED HEARING
FROM THE OTHER SUBCOMMITTEES
AND THE ISSUES THAT THEY'VE
BEEN WRESTLING WITH WALL HAVE
WE BEEN IN SUBCOMMITTEE THREE-
AND SO I WANT TO POINT OUT HOW
MUCH I APPRECIATE. OF SUB
COMMITTEE FOR SO PROVE OF THE
SHOW SERENA A FARMWORKER
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM- THAT'S A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR NEW FARM WORKER
HOUSING PROJECTS. THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FOR EXISTING
PROJECTS- AND- THAT IS THE KIND
OF INVESTMENT THAT I THINK
CALIFORNIA REALLY NEED TO KEEP
MAKING. HOUSING THAT WE KNOW IS
GOING TO BE AFFORDABLE IS
FARMWORKER HOUSING AND THAT
KIND OF HOUSING IS WHERE WE
OUGHT TO FOCUS OUR ENERGIES- I
ALSO. WANT TO APPLAUD THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE- FOR THE-
EFFORTS TO PUSH FOR DEBT FREE
CALIFORNIAN TO KEEP THAT ALIVE
AND KEEP THAT MOVING IT'S WHERE
WE REALLY. NEED TO END UP- AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THERE- I
ALSO REALLY APPLAUD THE- PUSH
FOR IN STATE STUDENTS TO BE
ABLE TO ATTEND UCLA AND
BERKELEY AND SAN DIEGO- AND-
THEN THE- OTHER POINT. OF WHAT
TO MAKE IS THE HOMELESS.
FUNDING IS CERTAINLY A LOT OF
OUR MIND RIGHT NOW. I WOULD
OFFER YOU THAT PROBABLY NEXT
YEAR AT THIS TIME WE'LL BE
TALKING ABOUT DROUGHT FUNDING
ALSO AND DROUGHT RESILIENCY
FUNDING- AND THAT WILL BE A NEW
PATIENT. AND SO WE SHOULD
ANTICIPATE THAT- IN ADVANCE I
DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS BUT I
DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THIS SO I
WILL ASK THOSE. OFF SITE BUT
THEIR QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
IMPACTS ON ON CHILD CARE FROM
THE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM- WILL HOW
MUCH REAL DECREASE THAT'S ALL
I'LL TALK TO THE CHAIR- SOME OF
THE ISSUES ON FEE INCREASES AND
SUB SUB COMMITTEE THREE- THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT BUT I'LL DO
THOSE OFFLINE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOISTURE THANK YOU WILL GO
TO MISTER GALLAGHER THE
MISGUIDED OR- YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANTED
TO YOU- FIRST OFF SAY. MY
APPRECIATION TO YOU AND THE
VICE CHAIR- THE GUNS AND- YOU
KNOW VERY GOOD WORK THIS YEAR
ON THE BUDGET. I THINK ITWAS
SAID EARLIER HOW. I THINK
AMONGST ALL THE COMMITTEES THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE HAS WORKED IN
A VERY BIPARTISAN MANNER-
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS I THINK
WE HAVE A LOT TO REALLY- BE
PROUD OF AND THE WORK THAT WAS
DONE THIS YEAR AND- CERTAINLY
WORKING IN THE- IN BUDGET SUB
TWO. ON EDUCATION ISSUES OF
APPRECIATED THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE I THINK WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DO SOME GOOD WORK IN. CUTTERY
ALREADY RE ORDERING- THE
PRIORITIES OF THE GOVERNOR HAD
HAD SET OUT AND I THINK.
MAKING- GETTING BACK TO SOME OF
THE BASICS THAT WE KNOW WE NEED
TO TAKE CARE OF BUT ALSO MAKING
SOME. SMART INVESTMENTS IN THE
FUTURE SO- HAPPY ABOUT THAT
WORK MY ONE QUESTION IS JUST
ON- AS YOU CAN PROBABLY IMAGINE
ON THE WILDFIRE- FRONT- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THEY HAD
PROPOSED A- TRAILER BILL TO
CONTINUE THE ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. AND G. R. F. PURSUANT
TO SB NINE A ONE. THROUGH THE.
TWENTY EIGHT. TWENTY NINE
FISCAL YEAR IN OTHER WORDS IN
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS OF
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION- I
BELIEVE THE STAFF COMMENTS-
FROM THAT WAS THAT THAT
LANGUAGES WAS UNNECESSARY- IS
THERE A REASON FOR THAT MAYBE
JUST A STAFFER IF THAT MAYBE
SOMEBODY CAN ANSWER I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE US. TRY TO
MAKE THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE MAKE THAT
COMMITMENT TO A CONTINUOUS-
APPROPRIATION FOR THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS- ON THAT. ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A BEGAN
TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. THAT BEGAN WITH- SB
NINE A ONE. THE. AND I AM I'LL
TURN THAT WENT OVER TO STEVEN
BENSON FOR COMMENTS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE SERVER
MINISTRATION STANDPOINT THAT WE
HAD PROPOSED THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- IN ORDER TO LIKELY TO
USE IT TO SAY THAT YOU SAID
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I HAVE TO
CONTINUE THAT COMMITMENT I WILL
NOTE. THAT THE ACTUAL SB NINE
NO ONE DOESN'T RATE THE FUNDING
IT EXPRESSES THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE YOU THAT- BUT I'LL
DEFER TO BE YEAH. ASSEMBLY
STAFF IN TERMS OF ITS ACTION TO
SAY THAT THE TV I WAS
UNNECESSARY I THINK THAT WAS
REALLY- TENSION AS WELL ALL THE
PARTICULAR ACCOUNT SO THAT. MR
CARTER CAN YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION FOR ASSEMBLY STUFF.
JUST RESTART WHY WE KIND OF
WANTED TO REJECT THAT I GUESS
AND SAY IT'S NOT NECESSARY I
GUESS I WOULD PUSH- FOR US TO
IN OUR FINAL BUDGET THAT WE
PASSED TO. MAKE THAT COMMITMENT
TO A FIVE YEAR CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION. YEAH I THINK
THERE'S A HESITATION- ACCORDING
TO A BUNCH OF STUFF TO DO A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION AS WE
HAVE DONE WITH SOME OTHER ITEMS
I KNOW IT'S BEEN A SOURCE OF
FRUSTRATION- WHETHER WE AGREE
OR DISAGREE WITH. THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL APPROPRIATION AND
THE- HE HAS GOT PRODUCTION
FUND. I THINK SIMILAR TO THAT
THERE WAS HESITATION TO DO
FURTHER- FOR THE CONTINUED
APPROPRIATIONS. I THINK IT IS
THE IT IS DEFINITELY. THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR. TO STICK BY THAT
AGREEMENT. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU BYE THERE'S. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I WANT TO
THANK ALSO- MY SEVEN TWO CHAIR
CHARM MCCARTY AND MY SEVEN FIVE
CHAIR- ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA-
FOR REALLY SOME GREAT
LEADERSHIP- WE HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED SOME GREAT THINGS
IN A BIPARTISAN FASHION THIS
YEAR THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
WORK TO DO AND THERE ARE STILL
NO MANY CRITICAL CRISIS LEVEL
ISSUES THAT OUR STATE IS
DEALING WITH- AND THIS BUDGET
DOES YOU KNOW ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE- HER BY
PROVIDING. NECESSARY RESOURCES-
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS HERE THE
ONE THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A LOT TO
SUPPORT HERE- BUT I WAS CURIOUS
TO KNOW WHETHER ANYTHING IN
THIS BUDGET PROVIDES FUNDING TO
HELP REDUCE THE NEED AND THE
NEED FOR AN TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFF I KNOW THAT IN OUR-
PACKAGE WE HAVE A BILLION. A
BIT OF ONE BILLION DOLLARS
ASIDE FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND RESILIENCE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I THINK
THERE'S ONE POINT NINE BILLION-
BUT THOSE DETAILS OF HOW THOSE
BILLIONS. THE MOMENT SO I'M
WOOD THE BOTH- IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CAN TELL
ME- IS THE- DISCUSS ARE ARE WE
SPOKE PREVIOUSLY- AT ASKING YOU
PREVIOUSLY IN SOME OF OUR
BUDGET HEARINGS- IF THE-
DEPARTMENT FINANCES
CONSIDERING- REFUNDING MONEY
FOR THE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
GRANTS- WHICH FOR DEBT WHICH
DIRECTLY IMPACT PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS- AND THAT THAT
ACCESS TO SORRY AND NEED FOR
THE ACCESS TO FUNDING FOR.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. STEVEN
BENSON WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE DID NOT PROPOSE
FUNDING SPECIFIC THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS THIS
YEAR HOWEVER THE ADMINISTRATION
DID PROPOSED TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE MORE
GENERALLY AND THE IDEA BEHIND
THAT WAS TO. BASICALLY WORK
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NOT
ENOUGH I WITH THEIR GREATEST
NEED DARK IN BEEN A DRESS THOSE
NEEDS WITHIN THAT LARGER PART
OF FUNDING SO PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF. MAYBE THE
GREATEST NEED IN THE GREATEST.
DEFICIENCY PERSEVERATION BUT
IT'S NOT FOR ALL. SO RATHER
THAN HAVING ONE SPECIFIC
SMALLER PART OF MONEY LIMITED
TO THAT ONE PURPOSE WE PROPOSED
A LARGER APPROPRIATE A LARGER
CORPORATION. THAT COULD BE USED
FOR MORE GENERAL ALL HAZARDS
APPROACH AND THAT WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY WORKING WITH
LOCAL SENECA REGIONAL BASIS-
IDENTIFY THE GREATEST NEEDS AND
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS. I WILL
NOTE THAT ARE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL HAS
BEEN REDUCED BY BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE DOWN TO A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. SO THE
ABILITY TO ADDRESS. AND THOSE
NEEDS A THE STATE IS GONNA BE
HAPPY REDUCE- PORTLAND. SO
WOULD CITIES AND TRIBES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR GRANTS FOR. SOLAR
POWER SOLAR POWER BATTERIES
BACKUPS- GENERATORS- IN WHAT
THE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION AND THAT PROPOSAL. YES
THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL WAS VERY FLEXIBLE IN
GENERAL TO ALLOW FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE- RESILIENCE AND
PARDONING AND A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS SO THAT THOSE
WOULD BE POTENTIALLY NOT
APPLICABLE. OBJECTS AND DOES
THE L. A. O. HAVE AN OPINION ON
BOTH A NEED AND- THE ACTUALLY
THE NEED AND THE WORTHINESS OF
INVESTING A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- OR IN ANY NUMBER
REALLY- FOR CALLIAS COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE GRANTS SPECIFICALLY
TO HELP WITH PS PS- MEDICATION.
I I'M SORRY GO HEAD HELEN- THIS
IS NINE THIRTY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THAT-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS BEEN
A PRIORITY IN HAD BEEN FOUND IN
THE PAST TO THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS THERE'S BEEN FUNDING FOR-
YOU KNOW FOR THOSE PUBLIC POWER
SHUT OFFS- AT THIS POINT THOUGH
MY COLLEAGUE I'D PROBABLY BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE AND I
UNFORTUNATELY HE'S NOT HERE SO
WE'LL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
IF YOU HAVE MORE FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON. THAT SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL- AND I WILL JUST
RECOGNIZE THAT THE CHAIRMAN I
HAVE SPOKEN PREVIOUSLY ABOUT
THIS AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
STILL OPEN AND WE'RE DISCUSSING
HERE IN IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU
JUST A- COOL I STILL ICED ICE
TWO TWO SHORT ONES. AND IN.
REGARDS TO- SPECIAL EDUCATION I
WANTED TO- I ALSO THINK YOU
KNOW BOTH THE LEGISLATURE AND-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
REALLY ALLOCATING MORE FUNDS
THERE I DO HAVE A QUESTION AND
I'M NOT SURE- IF YOU WOULD BE
ABLE TO ANSWER THIS AND MAYBE
THE CHAIRMAN CAN- CHARTERS SO
THERE IS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THE INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION PROGRAM.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
MILLION TO DOUBLE COUNTY SCHOOL
DISTRICT KINDERGARTEN ADA AS A
PROXY FOR PRESCHOOL ATTENDANCE
I'M OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS EXCO
EXCLUDED FROM FUNDING AND IF
SO- SHOULD WE- ERSTER SCHOOL
ACTUALLY EXCLUDED FROM FUNDING
FOR TWO K. EXTENSION. TWO WEEKS
IS ANYONE HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
THAT. MAKING CHRIS FERGUSON FOR
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE CAN HELP
WITH THAT ONE. IN GENERAL OF
THE CHARTER SCHOOL IS OFFERING
KINDERGARTEN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN IS CONSIDEREDTHE
FIRST YEAR OF A TWO YEAR
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM. SO IN
GENERAL YES THEY SHOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
MEDICAID EXPANSION. I THINK
MORE IMPORTANTLY TK'S BEEN
EXISTENCE FOR TEN YEARS FOR
KIDS BORN IN THE FALL AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
OFFERING TKA THROUGH THAT COLOR
SO THIS WOULD JUST EXPAND. WHAT
THEY CURRENTLY DO. OKAY AND
THEN LASTLY I JUST I NEED SOME
CLARIFICATION- FROM. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AND THE
GOVERNOR'S YOU KNOW MAY REVISE
ON YOU KNOW ADDRESSING THE
TWENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS N
DEBT THAT THE EIGHTY D. HAS A
CURED- WHAT'S THE PLAN I IT'S
NOT VERY CLEAR TO ME IN OUR
CONVERSATION TONIGHT IN
PREVIOUSLY IN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A UPWARDS OF
TWENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR-
DEBT HERE. AND WE'RE ALLOCATING
ANYWHERE BETWEEN A BILLION TO
YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD SEVEN
BILLION- BUT IT'S TWENTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS SO WHAT'S THE
PLAN BECAUSE THIS IS ONE YEAR
BUT TWENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY. TO BE
PAYING BACK OVER SEVERAL YEARS.
PRESS CLUB WHAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO AS YOU NOTED THE IN
MINISTRATIONS- PLANNED FOR THE
U. I. DEBT WAS TO PICK TO USE
ABOUT ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
ARCA. CHIU TO PAY DOWN A
PORTION OF THE BALANCE- AND AS
YOU NOTED EXPECTED TO BE TWENTY
ACCESS TO TWENTY FOUR BILLION
AT THE END OF THE CALENDAR
YEAR- SIMILAR TO- AS OF RIGHT
NOW THE APPROACH WITH- AT THIS
CURRENT BUDGET WISE TO. USE
SOME OF THE FEDERAL DOLLARS TO
BUY THAT DOWN- OBVIOUSLY YOU
KNOW CONVERSATIONS ON THE
FUTURE IS ONGOING- BUT AS I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT. BASED ON
THAT THE GREAT RECESSION- THE
PAY DOWN OF THAT DEBT- WAS-
DONE THROUGH THAT GRADUAL
INCREASES TO THE- FEDERAL- TAX
CREDIT FOR EMPLOYERS TO PAY SO.
OVER TIE THAT WOULD BE- BORNE
BY I'M INCREASES TO EMPLOYERS
SO TAX CHANGES WERE MADE SO IN
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
TAXPAYERS BUSINESSES ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO FORK OVER THE MONEY
OVER THE NEXT YOU KNOW DECADE
PLUS. TO PAY DOWN YOU KNOW WHAT
SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED IN THE
FIRST PLACE. SO ABSENT IN
CORRECT SO ABSENT ANY CHANGES
TO THE- THE FINANCING STRUCTURE
OF THE U. R. PROGRAM- THOSE
ADS. THAT THE RATES WILL BE
INCREASING OR THAT THAT CREDITS
WOULD BE REDUCED TO EMPLOYERS.
AND THEN- THEREBY INCREASING
THE TAX THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
PAY TO GO INTO THE- YOU ARE SO
THIS IS REALLY DISTRESSING ONE
THIS IS AN EXTREMELY DISTURBING
TO ME ESPECIALLY WHEN WE LOOK
AT. WE HAVE A PROPOSED- TWO
HUNDRED BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY AND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET THIS YEAR
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET- WAS HALF OF
THIS. AND WHETHER IT IS EASY D.
DEBT WHETHER IT IS DEFERRALS-
WHETHER IT IS A YOU KNOW A-
PENSION LIABILITIES WHETHER IT
IS LOOMING FINANCIAL CRISIS
THAT ARE- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
GONNA BE FACING ARE FACING- WE
SHOULD BE USING THIS AS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO BECOME
FINANCIALLY SOLVENT THIS IS A
LOT OF MONEY AND IT'S REALLY
UPSETTING THAT WERE NOT BEING
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE THANK
YOU- I WOULD JUST. RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE WHAT
YOU JUST STATED- THE STATE IT
IS IN A STRONGER. FINANCIAL
CONDITION AS IT'S BEEN IN THE-
ALMOST NINE YEARS I'VE BEEN IN
THE LEGISLATURE- AGAIN WE POINT
TO THE TWENTY OF THE RECORD-
NUMBER AMOUNT OF RESERVES
TWENTY FIVE BILLION. IN TERMS
OF THE U. I. TAX THE STRUCTURE.
OF THE TAX REMAINS IN TERMS OF
THE INTEGRITY OF THE TAX
REMAINS WHICH IS. IS A TAX THAT
IS PAID. BY EMPLOYERS FOR.
THEIR EMPLOYEES WHEN THEY ARE
UNEMPLOYEDAND THAT IS WHAT THE
TAXES AND THAT IS WHAT- REMAIN
SO IT IS UP TO US IF WE WANT TO
DEBATE THE- PURPOSE OF THE
TAXES WAS THE USE OF THE TAX
FOR THE FUTURE. BUT I THINK THE
FISCAL FACTS REMAIN THAT THE
STATE IS IN A STRONGER
FINANCIAL POSITION AS IT'S BEEN
IN A VERY LONG TIME WHEN I GO
TO THE DOCTOR WOULDN'T MISTER
LACK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THIS
BUDGET EITHER SO MUCH TO BE
HAPPY ABOUT AND- AND THE
COLLECTIVE WORK OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEES AND- I KNOW
THE SENATE ON THE OTHER SIDE AS
WELL. IT'S GREAT TO SEE US IN
AGREEMENT HERE ON ON THIS I
PARTICULARLY WANT TO. BE SAY
HOW THANKFUL I AM TO SEE THE
MONEY FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT I THINK IT'S CRITICAL AS
WE MOVE FORWARD- ALSO- THRILLED
TO SEE FUNDING FOR A BILL THAT
I PASSED A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
AROUND HOME HARDENING AS WE
ENTER WILDFIRE SEASON HERE- IT
SOMETIMES THESE THINGS TAKE
AWHILE WAITED A COUPLE YEARS
FOR THAT AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
SEE PROGRESS. PROGRESS THERE. I
DIDN'T WANT TO SAY A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT. AROUND JUST JUST
RESOURCES IN GENERAL AND AS I
THINK ABOUT THIS THIS IS. THIS
IS PROBABLY A ONCE IN A
LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY FOR US
WITH THESE KINDS OF RESOURCES
WERE SEEN NOW. AT CERTAINLY A
ONCE IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE OF US WHILE WE'RE
HERE- IN THE LEGISLATURE. AND I
REFLECT THAT- I HOPE AND I KNOW
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE. IN OUR
OVERSIGHT ROLE WILL REALLY. TRY
TO PUSH FOR THIS. BUT SOMETIMES
JUST HAVING A LOT OF MONEY AND
PUSHING IT OUT INTO PROGRAMS
ISN'T GOING TO SOLVE ALL THE
PROBLEMS AND- I BELIEVE THAT-
THERE ARE A LOT OF- SILOS IN
GOVERNMENT. THERE'S A LOT OF
LACK OF COORDINATION AND
ESPECIALLY AND I'VE I KNOW I'VE
BROUGHT THIS UP ON THE FLOOR
MAYBE YESTERDAY OR OR FRIDAY.
JUST THE CHALLENGES AROUND HOW
WE DEAL WITH HOMELESSNESS
THERE'S SO MANY FACES OF
HOMELESSNESS OR SO MANY. CAUSES
OF HOMELESSNESS. AND THERE
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THERE'S A LOT
OF COORDINATION- AND SO THIS
IS- THIS IS KIND OF A PLEA FOR
THAT- AND I KNOW THAT IN WE
ALSO SEE A LOT OF DUPLICATION.
WELL A LOT BUT MAYBE THAT'S
MAYBE THAT'S A STRETCH THERE IS
DEFINITELY DUPLICATION OF
THINGS IN. STATE GOVERNMENT WE
FOUND THAT IN TO OUR AUDITING
PROCESS WORK ONE DEPARTMENT
DOESN'T REALIZE THE OTHER
DEPARTMENT IS DOING THE SAME
THING. AND THEY'RE NOT TALKING
TO ONE ANOTHER. SO THAT'S
WASTE. THAT'S WAYS THEY CAN BE
AVOIDED SO I HOPE WITH THIS
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES GOING IN. TO PROVIDE
SOME REALLY VALUABLE SERVICES
THAT IS COORDINATED. THAT
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
THAT WE GET IT RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO MISTER
LUCKY AND THEN TO MISTER MATHIS.
WELL THANK YOU I DON'T HAVE.
ANY OF BURNING QUITE WELL I
HAVE SEVERAL BURNING QUESTIONS
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO BE LABOR
THEM AT THIS POINT I DID WANT
TO MAKE IT. A COMMENT THAT- TO
THIS POINT OUR BUDGET PROCESSES
HAD VIGOROUS DISCUSSIONS AND
EXCHANGE OF PERSPECTIVES HAS
BEEN SOMETHING I'M VERY VERY
PROUD TO HAVE PARTICIPATED IN.
IT IS AN HONOR TO WITNESS THIS
LEVEL OF LEADERSHIP AS WELL BY.
BOTH THE STRUCTURES AND I
PARTICIPATED IN BOTH AND SUB
BOARDS OF FIVE. HOWEVER IN.
THIS PART OF THE PROCESS I'D
SAY WERE. SOMEWHERE AROUND HALF
TIME- AS WELL AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER TODAY THIS IS STILL
VERY EARLY. AND IN THE DECISION
MAKING TREE AND THERE'S BEEN
HOURS AND HOURS AND HOURS OF
REVIEW. A PERSPECTIVE SHARED.
AND I FEEL LIKE IN YEARS PAST.
THIS PARTY FROM THIS POINT BACK
IS SOMETHING TO BE VERY PROUD
OF WHAT WHAT HAPPENS FROM THIS
POINT FORWARD. AS A IT SEEMS
LIKE. THE PROCESS AND
INFORMATION BECOMES WAY MORE
GUARDED. AND LESS OPENLY SHARED
AND LESSENING GAUGING AND I
DON'T WE DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH
CONTROL OVER THAT BUT IT IS A
OF RUSTRATION FOR ME THE SO
MUCH WORK GETS PUT IN. TO OUR
ENGAGEMENT AND ITS ROBUSTNESS
NOT BE VERY PROUD OF AND THEN A
LOT OF IT JUST KIND OF GOES UP
AND- SMOKE FOR LACK OF A BETTER
TERM AND- IT'S A- IT'S A STRONG
FRUSTRATION OF MINE AND I JUST
WANTED TO. EXPRESS IT BECAUSE
IT MAKES ME FEEL BETTER. BUT IT
BUT IT IT REALLY IS A
FRUSTRATION. I WOULD SAY BURKE
YOUR IT'S A VERY IT'S A VERY
FAIR POINT AND I WOULD SAY-
WITH- THE SIZE OF THE BUDGET
THAT WE HAVE THE SIZE OF THE
STATE WHAT WE HAVE IN THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE. INVOLVED THAT
GO INTO DISCUSSING DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE MINUTIA I THINK
YOUR YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN I
THINK WE DO TRY TO MAKE IT- AS
TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE. BUT AT
THIS POINT- THERE ARE DECISIONS
THAT DO NEED TO BE MADE. AND I
HAVE A GOOD IDEA TO UNDERSTAND
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE YOUR FRUSTRATION I
THINK WE DO TRY TO BALANCE
THAT. TRANSPARENCY IN THE VERY
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS BUT AT THE
SAME TIME TO NOT BE PARALYZED
BY IT AND TO BE ABLE TO- MAKE
SOME FINAL DECISIONS BUT I
THINK YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN.
MR MATHESON THE MASTERS ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANTED
TO START OFF BY THANKING THEM
MY FELLOW MEMBERS OF BUDGETS OF
ONE- THANK MY- PARTNER IN THE
BATTLE FOR THE LETTERMAN ACT MR
FRAZIER- FOR PUSHING TO MAKE
SURE WE DO GET THESE. RATE
INCREASES TO MATCH THE STUDY
ORDERED THANK. OUR CHAIRMAN MR
TING FOR HEEDING OUR CALL OUR
CRY FOR HELP- HEATING THE
COMMUNITIES HELP- TO GET THESE
RATE INCREASES PUT IN HERE-
LOOKING DEEPER I ALSO WANT TO
THANK OUR OUR FOLKS OVER ON
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE- FOR HAVING
SOME DEEP CONSIDERATIONS ABOUT
DROUGHT RESILIENCE- MY
COMMUNITY IS HEAVILY
AGRICULTURAL BASED. AND WITHOUT.
WATER WE HAVE NOTHING AND WE'RE
GOING INTO A HEAVY DROUGHT
WE'RE GOING INTO ISSUES WHERE
NOT AS SEVERELY THIS YEAR. BUT
NEXT YEAR AS WE HAVE TO CUT
CROPS IN CROP PRODUCTION THIS
YEAR THAT WE CAN BE LOOKING AT
FOOD SCARCITY THIS TIME NEXT
YEAR. AND HAVE DEEP CONCERN
ABOUT THAT AND MY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS DO AS WELL SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTIVENESS TO
THAT. I DO SHARE A LOT OF THE
OTHER CONCERNS- THAT MEMBERS OF
MY CAUCUS. HAVE AS FAR AS THE
TRANSPARENCY THIS YEAR COMPARED
TO WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN THE
PAST WITH IT WITH CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE AND HAVING. A BIGGER
MORE OPEN DISCUSSIONS AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT COLD HAS HAD
THAT IMPACT ON ALL OF US. AND I
DO APPRECIATE- YOU MISTER CHAIR
ON ON TRYING TO BE TRANSPARENT
ON TAKING YOUR PERSONAL TIME TO
BRIEF MY CAUCUS MEMBERS. ON
WHAT'S GOING ON BUT I KNOW A
LOT OF FOLKS WOULD REALLY KIND
OF WANNA SEE AIR OUT FOUR
HUNDRED PAGES A LOT TO GO
THROUGH- ALEC FORD TO THE GOOD
THINGS THAT ARE IN THIS AND I
KNOW A LOT OF US HAVE HEARTBURN
IN SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS.
AND I WILL CLOSE WITH THAT
THANK YOU. PRECIADO THANK YOU
MISTER ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I DON'T WANT TO BE TRIED
AND REPEAT WHAT EVERYBODY ELSE
HAS BEEN REPEATING BUT BUT
THANK YOU'S ALL AROUND TO
EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN WORKING
VERY DILIGENTLY IN A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME GIVEN ALL THE
UNANTICIPATED SURPRISES THAT
THIS YEAR HAS BROUGHT A THIS
YEAR AND LAST BUT THREE THINGS
THAT I JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT
AND THINK FOR IS FIRST OF ALL A
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING. OF ALL THE VARIOUS
REQUESTS FOR THE DISABILITY AND
AGING COMMUNITIES ARE THAT THAT
IS A CRITICAL- A STEP IN MAKING
SURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING HAS THE RESOURCES THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO- MOVE
FORWARD IN ADDRESSING THE
GROWING NEEDS OF OUR SENIORS
AND OUR ELDERS AS THEY BECOME
WITHIN THE NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS
25% OF THE STATE'S POPULATION.
OF ONE TWO I'M EXTREMELY-
THANKFUL TO BOTH THE BUDGET SUB
CHAIRS WELL AS THE- CHAIR IN IN
YOUR SUPPORT OF- THE CAL KIDS
INVESTMENT NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION AS WELL AS A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY MILLION ONGOING I
KNOW THAT'S A CONTINUES
CONVERSATION FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL WEEKS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AT LAST BUT
NOT LEAST I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THERE ARE. A MODICUM OF
INVESTMENTS MADE AN EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION SEVERAL OTHER
PROGRAMS INCLUDING C. A. R.
GIVEN GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY WE
HAVE OF WHAT WE ARE WHAT WE
WHAT MONEY HAS COME FORWARD
RIGHT NOW TO MAKE ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS I WOULD JUST. ASK
AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
OF YOU IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT DOWNPAYMENT
ON. PROGRAMS SIMILAR TO FOR
EXAMPLE IS MISTER DOCTOR WOULD
MENTION HOME HARDENING BUT
APPLYING IT TOWARDS SEISMIC
SAFETY RELATED PROGRAMS SO THAT
WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
VULNERABLE BUILDINGS THAT HAVE.
THE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN
OUR URBAN SETTING CITIES- ARE
PROTECTED AND THAT WE'RE NOT
ADDING TO GREATER HOMELESS
NUMBERS AS WELL THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU- ARE THERE ANY
MORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. MR FRAZIER I
APOLOGIZE MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANTED TO REITERATE SOME OF THE
COMMENTS ON THE STATE
HOSPITALS- TALKING ABOUT THE
ABILITY FOR SOME OF THE
COUNTIES TO AUTOMATICALLY AS OF
JAN ONE TAKE OVER THE
RESPONSIBILITY THE KAISER HAS
BEEN DOING IN MY- COUNTY IS
SOLANO AND ALSO SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. KAISER DOESN'T WANT TO
DISCONTINUE THE SERVICE AND
SOLANO IN SACRAMENTO IS NOT
READY AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND THAT
ARE CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A
PHASES. OF SERVICES OR WHAT OF
THESE TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL
FOLKS THAT WILL BE ABLE TO GET
SERVICES APPROPRIATELY. IN A
PHASE IN PERIOD I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE DON'T WITH THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS MR FONG I JUST WANT TO
GIVE MOMENT A THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK I
KNOW DOES NOT PROBABLY NOT. A
GLORIOUS THAT- THING TO- SPEND
YOUR WEEKENDS THAT WORKING ON
THIS BUT I DO WANT TO PUBLICLY
KNOWLEDGE WORK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR MUCH APPRECIATED- ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I
THINK WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND I THINK
WE'RE READY TO. CALL THE ROLL.
TANG HAI FONG. FROM NOW
ARAMBULA. THEN IT. BLOOM
CARILLO CHIU COOPER FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
NO GARCIA. I'M SORRY GALLAGHER
NOT VOTING GARCIA. JONES SAWYER
OUR- KILEY. KILEY NO LACKEY-
THANK YOU LEE. MATHIS. MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN. NAZARIAN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON. PATTERSON
NOT VOTING SORRY W. SIERRA
RAMOS. RAYOS RIVAS RUBIO SMITH.
WITH NO STONE. CALAVERAS WOOD.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE MOTION
PASSES. THANK YOU WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT ON STRUCTURE. SO ARE
THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
GALLERY THE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THE GALLERY. IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT OPERATOR ON THE
PHONE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
CONNECT COMMAND AGAIN IS ONE.
SEVEN ZERO. NINE SIXTY FIGURE
MY COULD UP. I'M. SIXTY SIX.
MARK MULLEN ARE ON THE MAP ON
THE MOST MULLIN AYE. AND THEN
BEFORE I FORGET THE LINE MISS
ROBERT BEFORE YOU BEGIN- WE ARE
ASKING PUBLIC COMMENT- FOR ONE
MINUTE SO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
EIGHTY FOUR. THE CHAIR- MARC
PRAYER- ON BEHALF OF- CHARGE
POINT WE SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE DOES HAVE PACKAGE
PROVIDING THREE POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THREE
YEARS INCLUDING TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO CLARIFYING
PROGRAMMATIC ALLOCATIONS OF
THESE FUNDS CHARGEPOINT
ENCOURAGES THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR TO ALLOCATE THE
MAJORITY OF SEVEN FOR STRUCTURE
FUNDING. SPECIFICALLY TO
SUPPORT LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ALLOCATE FUNDS
WHERE THEY WILL BE IMMEDIATELY
USED BY CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
AND TRAVELERS MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY INFRASTRUCTURE ARE ALSO
IMPORTANT COMPONENTS OF SAYS
CALIFORNIA'S OF STRATEGY THE
CDC CAN PROVIDE IMPORTANT
INCENTIVES TO HELP REDUCE THE
COST OF THE OF INSTALLING THIS-
INFRASTRUCTURE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO PLAYING A CONSTRUCTIVE ROLE
IN WORKING WITH YOU AND THE
GOVERNOR- AND- YOU COLLEAGUES
IN THE SENATE TO DEVELOP THE
FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT. Q.
THANK YOU. LINE AT. NINETY ONE.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS COUNTY DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM I WISH TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE KERR
INCLUDING FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE BRIDGE LOAN PROGRAM FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FOR THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DIFFERENT HOSPITAL
THE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT IT BE
INCLUDED IN THE FINAL BUDGET ON
BEHALF OF KIMBERLY CLARK- WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION OF
FIFTEEN TWENTY EIGHT THANK.
WIDE DIAPER BANKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. LINE IN.
NINETY THREE. HI AS THIS IS
DONNA PENSION WITH THE LOS
ANGELES CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTER AND I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS WHICH SUPPORT THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING- CREDIT
THE NUMBER. WHICH IS CARE
GIVING THAT WORKS. THEIR BELLY
T. TO PROVIDE SERVICES FOR THE
UNPAID FAMILY CAREGIVERS VERY
IMPORTANT IN CALIFORNIA AND TO
STABILIZE THOSE SERVICES WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE AT
NINETY FIVE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BRANDON TO LOOK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION DISAPPOINTED WITH
THE SUBCOMMITTEE THREE ACTION
REJECT THE EPA CLEAN AIR
PROGRAM FUNDING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. WHICH INCLUDES THE
CARL MOYER AND LOCAL EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY THREE INCENTIVE
PROGRAM TO. RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU RECONSIDER AS BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE. BECAUSE
APPROVING THE EXTENSION THIS
YEAR WILL ALLOW FOR PROGRAMS TO
CONTINUE SEAMLESSLY HELP INFORM
STATE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
DEVELOPMENT AND PROVIDE
BUSINESS AND MARKET CERTAINTY
SECONDLY IN LIGHT OF THE BUDGET
SURPLUS WE ASK YOU TO FURTHER
PRIORITIZE INCENTIVE FUNDING
FOR THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
AND FORMER PROGRAMS. AND LAST
BUT WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION FOR AIR DISTRICT EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN PLANTATION IT
DOES NOT COVER CURRENT COSTS
ARE ACCOUNT FOR NEW COMMUNITIES
ADDED TO THIS IMPORTANT STATE
MANDATED PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE AT. SEVENTY
FIVE. GOOD EVENING MY NAME THE
NAME COLBERN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION WE ARE
HUGELY APPRECIATIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AND THE ACTIONS
OF UP TO FOR THE PROPOSED
INDEFINITE IN ACCESS TO CHILD
CARE SPOTS OF WORKING FAMILIES.
WAITING FAMILY FEES AND BRING
PERFORMED FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WHO CENTERS WE JUST
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT YOU
HAVE THE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
BLOCK WITH A WELCOME GREAT
INCREASE THEN YOU MUST ALSO
FUND THE COMMUNITY PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE AGENCIES THAT CONNECTS
FAMILIES THE CHILD CARE AND
OTHER SOCIAL SUPPORT. THE
PROPOSED INCREASE DOT WILL
TRIPLE THE EXISTING NUMBER
ABOUT HER LIFE HOWEVER NO
FUNDING IS PROVIDED TO AGENCIES
TO EXPAND THEIR SUPPORT YOUR
FAMILIES BY HIRING FAMILY
CASEWORKERS AND INVOLVEMENT
NATIONAL WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS FAMILIES WILL BE UNABLE
TO ACCESS THESE NEW PLOT.
COMPOUNDING THE ISSUE ARE
AGENCIES JUST RECEIVED THEIR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
CONTRACT AND ARE FACING AN
IMMEDIATE SYSTEM MOMENT OF
FAMILIES FROM ACCESS TO ROUGHLY
ELEVEN THOUSAND CHILD CARE
SLOTS. STARTING JULY ONE. THE
SHORE UP THE- COMMUNITY THEY
PRO THAT. THEM TO MAKE THE NEED.
THE WELCOME DEMAND AN
AFGHANISTAN AND- COURTS TO
WORKING DOWN THE CHILD CARE
YOUR INVEST OKAY LIVES THANK
THANK YOU. FOR LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN. SACRAMENTO CALIF
REPRESENTING TO CLIMB TODAY AND
WE HAVE A CHILDREN NOW I WANT
TO GIVE GREAT LAKES REYES AND
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THAT
FUNDING FOR THE MARKET CHILD
CARE BRIDGE PROGRAM ABOVE THE
RESTORATION OF THE TOWER
HOMEBUILDING PROGRAM AND AS
WELL AS YOUR ROBOT CHILD CARE
PACKAGE WHICH IS GOING TO BE
PHENOMENAL FOR THE FIELD AND
GET A THREE OPEN AND WORKING
AGAIN. AND WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEARS
WE ARE EXTREMELY THE PART OF
THE LEGISLATURE COLUMNIST
PACKAGE INCLUDES FUNDS TO
SUPPORT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AS
WELL AS THAT FIFTY MILLION IN
FUNDING AND- YEAH FOR THE WHOLE
OF YOU TO MAKE THE SERVICE OF
THE HOUSING PROGRAM THAT
TECHNICAL SUPPORT BPO TO
ARGUING THAT THE MEDIA WORK AND.
EXPAND THE REALLY. I PROGRAM
THAT THE- YEAH HOW THE COMES IN
JUST A FEW REALLY GREAT IT AND
FILLING THE GAP AND HAVE THAT
BUT- FUNDING THAT. NEEDED NOW
AND NOT SUPPORT IN MANY OTHER
AREAS. AS WELL AS A LOT OF YOUR
INVESTMENT IN HUMAN SERVICES
STATE. SUPPORT OUR CHILDREN AND
THE FATHER CARE ACT WITH THEM-
WHO'VE BEEN. SUFFERING A
PANDEMIC IN ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT SERVICES THANK YOU. THE
LINE IN. NINETY SEVEN. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DOES HE HAVE PRESIDENT OF THAT
POINT. WE CAN POINT THE
PROPOSED ACTION IN THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET DIVIDE DOWN ALL OF THE
K. TWELVE DIFFERENT. WE SUPPORT
THE AUGMENTATION TO CLEAR
TECHNICAL EDUCATION FUNDING AND
WE ALSO BELIEVE THE L. A. O.
REVENUE ESTIMATES ARE
REASONABLE. THANK YOU. LINE AT.
NINETY EIGHT. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS KILEY RIGHT BY ME CALIFORNIA
ON BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING IN THE
BUDGET AN UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT
OF THREE POINT NINE BILLION FOR
INVESTMENT IN ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES THIS IS VITAL AS WE
FIGHT AGAINST AIR POLLUTION AND
THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND THESE
FUNDS WILL MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE AND THE DIFFERENCE
IN A COMICAL. CURRENTLY CLEAN
VEHICLE EQUITY PROGRAMS ARE OUT
OF FUNDING WAITING FOR THE
BUDGET FUNDS TO BE PHYSICALLY
DISTRIBUTED MEANS PARK AFTER
YOU CLICK WILL BE PURCHASED WE
ASK THAT YOU EXCEEDED I STATE
LEVEL FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS ARE THE SENATE
PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL IN
ENSURING THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS
TO CLEAN VEHICLES AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THE BUDGET
ME GREATLY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ALLOCATION OF. FUNDS TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED ONE. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER
DIANA DOUGLAS WOULD HELP TACKLE
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
STEP FORWARD TO EXPAND MEDICAL
TO UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE AGE
FIFTY AND OLDER IN THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL WILL SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO REMOVE THE ASSET
TESTS FOR SENIORS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES APPETITE MEDI
CAL IN THE CREATION OF A
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE BOND. THAT COULD
ALSO THANK YOU FOR THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL CONCLUSION ABOUT THE
FUNDING AND PEOPLE ARE TO BE
OFFERED OFTEN HEALTHCARE
PORTABILITY FINALLY WE
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO COVER CALIFORNIA
PORTABILITY IN THE INCLUSION OF
A REPORT THAT ONLY THE
GROUNDWORK FOR FUTURE
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE
ESPECIALLY TO REDUCE. COST
SHIPPING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BLIND HUNDRED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SHARE AN HONORABLE
MEMBERS EIGHTY HINDSIGHT WITH
WILDCAT CONSULTING REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST NETWORK. THANK YOU FOR
FINDING THE FIRST ITEM IN THE
ANTI DISPLACEMENT HOUSING
PRESERVATION PACKAGE ON PAGE
ONEHUNDRED FOURTEEN BULLET
POINT NUMBER THREE AFTER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
HOUSING PRESERVATION PROGRAM.
THIS ITEM WILL GREATLY ASSIST
CALIFORNIANS AFTER THE
MORATORIUM IS LIFTED WE ALSO
STILL SUPPORT THE SECOND ITEM
IN THE ANTI DISPLACEMENT
HOUSING PRESERVATION PACKAGE
FOR FIVE HUNDRED MILLION FOR
THE COMMUNITY ACQUISITION
PROGRAM CHAMPIONED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PLAN. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS. WHAT COLOR AT
THE DOCTOR GROUP I LIVING IN
CAN OF CHRIST STATED INTO NOT.
SHE- HAD INCORRECT AND SO WHO
HAVE A CAR A LOT ONES ON BEHALF
OF OUR MEMBERS I URGE YOU TO
READ THAT ARE WALK MILLION. LET
THE TRIAL INITIATIVE AT THE
MEMBERSHIP FEE OKAY IT THOUSAND
THE BILL THREE FOR ACROSS THE
STATE MOTHER DAY I THE MODEL IN
THE KIND OF PRE TRIAL COMMUNITY
LED QUITE THAT WE ARE DEMANDING
THAT USE THE PARK INSTEAD OF
PRE TRIAL. LED BY PROBATION
WELL FOLKS REALLY NEED A FREE
TRIAL THAT IS LED BY A PEER
NAVIGATORS FOCUSING ON
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES ALEX
HAWLEY COURT REMINDERS. AND
OTHER SUPPORT SERVICES. CENTRAL
PRESS THE COUPLE WELL I'LL COME
WE BELIEVE THAT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS NEED TO BE AT THE
HOME. TO WORKING PEOPLE THROUGH
THE PREOCCUPATION PROCESS NOT
PROBATION OFFICERS WHO ARE
POLICE BY ANOTHER NAME WHAT THE
GOVERNOR IS ASKING FOR WHAT
EXPAND THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT
WHICH IS ANOTHER ARM A LOT FOR.
THAT WE NEED TO OVERHAUL OUR
CURRENT CHRYSOPOLIS I'M IN THE
CORPORATE MARKET COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT AGAIN I URGE YOU TO
READ THAT IN PART ONE TWENTY
NINE DOLLAR. PROPOSAL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. LINE SIX FOUR.
THANK TERM MEMBERS SERVERS
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHEAST OF COP
HEALTHCARE I THINK THE FOR THE
SINK UNMET NEED A SPECIAL DISH
AND ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN CALL THE NINETEEN
RIDLEY THIRTY THE CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES OUTLINED IN
ISSUE EIGHT EIGHT SIX ZERO
UNDER SUB COMMITTEE FOR HOW CAN
DISTRICT HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE
TO WORK TIRELESSLY TO RESPOND
TO THE ONGOING COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND PUBLIC HEALTH
NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THE
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FUNDING. TO
CONTINUE ACCESS TO COMMON.
NINETEEN REALLY FUNDING IN THE
COMING YEAR THANK YOU. ALIGNED
AT. NINETY NINE. GOOD EVENING
RESEARCHER MEMBERS WENDY
REYNOLDS WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATE HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT MULTIPLE BUDGET
ALLCATIONS INCLUDING TWENTY
FIVE MILLION TO SUPPORT ALL
CHILDREN THRIVE THE STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE THAT SUPPORTS
EFFORTS TO MITIGATE THE
DISPARATE EFFECTS OF ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES ON
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ANNUALLY IN
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT. ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION TO SUPPORT
HEALTH EQUITY IN RACIAL
JUSTICE. TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE MILLION FOR YOUTH FOCUSED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TEN MILLION
TO FUND THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY AS CONTEMPLATED IN SB
SEVENTEEN. PJ EXPRESSES OUR
DEEP GRATITUDE TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE AND FUNDING IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PUBLIC
HEALTH INITIATIVES THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED TEN. GOOD
EVENING DHANGAR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK
THAT HE'LL AND ALL THE STAFF
FOR INCREDIBLE EDUCATION BUDGET
THAT THE KRIKALEV OF FIVE POINT
007% IT'S AWESOME BUT WE WANT
TO NOTE THAT COME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION IS NOT RECEIVING
A CALL AT AND IT HAS NOT
RECEIVED A CALL LESS THAN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE WE ASK THAT YOU
OUGHT TO PROVIDE EIGHTY FIVE
POINT 007% COLLECTOR. HOME TO
GO TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU.
LINE AT. NINETY FOUR. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
CANNOT SHOW THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION-
LUCRETIUS THE THREE BILLION
ONETIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND OF AVAILABLE
OVER SEVEN YEARS TO FURTHER
EXPAND IMPLEMENTATION AND USE
OF THE COMING SCHOOL MODEL-
LOCAL SERVICE HE'S GONNA
FIFTEEN BECAUSE THIS YEAR
CONTINUES CULTURAL MODELS AND
EFFECT OF THAT STRATEGY THE
JUST THE AND THAT NEED TO BE
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS. THROUGH A
HOLISTIC APPROACH HE'S CRITICAL
AND NOW DO THE MY MOTHER WAS ON
THE CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
WHICH FOR THE LAST DAYS BEFORE
THE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
DOLLARS FOR THE CAREER- TICKET
TECHNOLOGIES INTO TO THEM THAT
POSITION TODAY BECAUSE HIS
MOTHER DIDN'T ATTEND SCHOOL
MORE FREQUENTLY IN THE MORTGAGE
WHICH IMPROVES THE OVERALL.
ECONOMIC OUTCOMES. AND ALLOW WE
ARE OURSELVES. CAL OF-
TRANSPORT WAS THE PROPOSAL FOR.
WITH DISABILITIES. ESPECIALLY
THE PART OF THE ENTRY OF THE
CURRENT VERSION. FUNDING IS SIX
TO ARE GOING TO STRENGTH
PRESCHOOL OF DISABILITIES AND
ONE TIMES THAT THE JUDGE.
IMMEDIATE NEEDS THIS WITH THIS
MILLION OUR FAMILY DOT TO
ACCESS TO EDUCATIONAL SERVICES.
SUCH AS RETURN MORE POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS. FOR THE FAMILIAR
LIKE WITH THE STUDENTS HOSTED
BY THE PANDEMIC AND RIGHTFULLY
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE NEEDED
FOR THIS GROUP. IN ADDITION WE
HAVE TWO THAT ARE LOADED ON IT
WITH OUR BUDGET PRIORITIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. LINE
HUNDRED. HI MY NAME IS MARIE
MOXON AM A VOLUNTEER WITH THEM
THEY ARE JEWISH ACTION I'M
CALLING ON YOU TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS
PARTICULAR PRE TRIAL PILOT WAS
INITIATED IN PREPARATION FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB TEN
WHICH DID NOT HAPPEN AND THAT'S
LOGICALLY IT FOLLOWS WITH THIS
PILOT SHOULD BE TERMINATED
SINCE THE PILOT IMPLEMENTATION
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
GROUND HAS SHIFTED STUDIES OUT
OF HARVARD AND MIT HAVE SHOWN
THE INHERENT RACIAL BIAS THE
RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS. NOT ONLY
DO RISK ASSESSMENTS UNDER BY
THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE
MORE IMPORTANTLY THEY ROB THE
ACCUSED OF THEIR RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS IN THE PAST YEAR WE
HAVE WITNESSED THE CALL FOR
DIVESTING FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOR INVESTING IN COMMUNITY
BASED FLOOD SERVICES UTILIZING
PROBATION THIS PILOT AN ARM OF
CORRECTIONS DOES THE OPPOSITE
AND CREATING THE RESOURCES AND
POWER OF THE CARCERAL SYSTEM
THAT FOCUSES ON CONTROL AND
SURVEILLANCE NOT SERVICES. THE
VISION OF A TRANSFORMED
PRETRIAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS BEST
SERVED BY ENDING AS OF THE DATE
PILOT AND FUNDING REAL PRE
TRIAL SERVICES AND PRODUCTS
THAT WILL PROTECT THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE AND
THE RIGHT TO PRE TRIAL JUST PRE
TRIAL. RELEASE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. LINE. ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
ON BEHALF OF OUR MORE THAN
EIGHTY FIVE TRENTON RELIGIONS
MEMBERS ONE APOLOGY WILL FOR
YOUR STEADFAST SUPPORT FOR
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND SPECIFICALLY
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE INVOICE OUR
SUPPORT FOR ACTION TAKEN
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE TO
CONTINUE STATURE REALLY FOR
TRANSIT AGENCIES PROVIDE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
TRANSIT BUS AND RAIL
TECHNOLOGIES. AND TO BUILD
CAPACITY I AM TO IMPROVE THE
SAFETY OF OUR TRAINS AND RAIL
SYSTEMS THAT'S THE BUDGET
DISCUSSION CONTINUE WE URGE YOU
TO APPROVE THE FUNDING LEVELS
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR CLEAN TRUCKS AND BUSES AS
WELL AS FOR THE SATISFIED GROUP
YOUR MISSION BOXES
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FINALLY WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO PROVIDE
FUNDING SUPPORTS TWENTY
TWENTIES DIRECTLY TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. FOR BACK TO
TRANSIT STRATEGIES TO WIN
WRITERS BACK THEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
NETWORK WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE REPORTS CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
GREEN BUSINESS PROGRAM ALSO
APPROVED INTO COMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE ENCOURAGE. YOU TO MOVE IT
FORWARD TODAY THANK YOU. LINE
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS WENT AWAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER MOM POPPY
WE APPRECIATE LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP AND FUNDING VARIOUS
HEALTH EQUITY PROPOSALS TO
ELIMINATE THE MEDIC HOW ASSET
LIMIT EXTEND MEDICARE TO ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS AGE
FIFTY PLUS AS WELL AS
INVESTMENT AND CAL WORKS GRANTS
AND ELIGIBILITY PROCESS
STREAMLINING WE SUPPORT THE
GROUPS AL PROPOSAL AND AGAIN
CALLED FOR THE RESTORATION OF
AT THE SITE GRANT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SCHOOL RESTORATION
IN THE FUTURE. WE APPRECIATE
THE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
INVESTMENTS TO HELP PROTECT
TENANTS FROM EVICTION AND JOHN
WITH THE POINTY END OF SEVERAL
ATTACHMENTS IN CRIMINAL AND
TRAFFIC COURT LASTLY WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THE FINAL BUDGET
WILL INCLUDE AN EXTENSION OF
THE EVICTION MORATORIUM OTHER
TENANT PROTECTIONS AND MEDICARE
HOUSING SUPPORT. CAPACITY
BUILDING GRANTS THANK YOU.
BLIND OF. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY.
NUMBER DOLLARS TOWARDS HIS
STRATEGY THREE THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE OVER SIX HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THE NATIONAL KIND OF
ANY SSOCIATION CALIFORNIA ONE
PROPOSED ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVE EVENT REALLY- JUST TODAY
THE NEW YORK TIMES REPORTED ON
YET ANOTHER DELAY ON THE
FEDERAL SHUTTERED VENUE
OPERATORS GRANT ARE FEDERAL
LIFELINE- THAT WAS THE LIFELINE
OF STAGES THROUGHOUT THE NATION
AND CALIFORNIA THAT ALREADY
BEEN BOMBED AWAY. THAT THAT
THAT YOU DIDN'T CLUE THEN USE-
RELEASED BY THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY THAT HIS BABY THAT
COMIC PAGES A SMALL BUSINESSES
BACK CALIFORNIA ALLOWS THEM
HOPE ON THE HORIZON FROM OUR
HOME STATE AND ALSO WANTED TO
EXPRESS A SPECIFIC DEPARTMENT
TEAM MEMBER VENUES NAMELY L.
SAID SEVERAL LIKE LOUNGE BLOOD
DURING THE MONTH AND THE AND
FOLLOWED HERE IN SACRAMENTO ALL
MEMBERS OF THE ALL SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL TO GET THE
CROSS ONCE THEY BIG THANK YOU
TO. ASSEMBLY WOMAN CUT HER REAL
AS WELL AS A FEW OTHER MEMBERS-
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
NO LONGER CHILD CARE LAWCENTER
WE THINK THE ASSEMBLY AND IT'S
TREMENDOUS SUPPORT FOR CHILD
CARE IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THIS
BUDGET HELPED ESTABLISH A
STRONG FOUNDATION FOR LONG TERM
IMPROVEMENT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
INCREASING REIMBURSEMENT RATES
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF CHILD
KIDS CARE SPOTS AND WAITING
FAMILY FEES FOR ALL FAMILIES
REGARDLESS OF SHELTER IN PLACE
ORDERS AND ALL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND IMPLEMENTING AN ECHO
WILL BE STRUCTURE THEREAFTER WE
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN WORKS
BEST AS- AS PART OF A DIVERSE
MIX OF EVERY SYSTEM. AND THAT
PARENTS CHOICE MEANS THAT ANY
PARENT BACK WITH THE WEATHER
THEY HAVE CHILD CARE SUBSIDIES
CAN SHOOT EGGMAN SETTING FREE
OF CHARGE WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD TAKE ONE YEAR
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
PLAN THIS PROGRAM TO ENSURE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION
FINALLY WE WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE FEDERAL CHILDCARE
CIVILIZATION GRANT FUNDING
WHICH HAS VERY SPECIFIC FUNDING
PURPOSES TO SUPPORT PRIVATE AND
PUBLICLY UNDED CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THEY OPEN AND PAY FOR
COSTS RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC
CALCULUS CENTER HAS SUBMITTED
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TO
IMPLEMENT THESE FEDERAL. CHILD
CARE GRANTS THANK YOU. WELL I
DON'T WANT THIRTY NINE. HI
CHAIR AND MEMBERS IS TIFFANY
MOCK I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS CAP THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SUPPORTING THE
TRANSITION TO SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE IN FUNDING THAT
INCLUDES TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR UNDERSERVED FARMERS FARM TO
SCHOOL QUITE. CLIMATE MARK
AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS URBAN
AGRICULTURE BEGINNING FARMER
AND FARM WORKER TRAINING IN A
PESTICIDE. CATION NETWORK KATHY
URGES THE FINAL I DON'T THE
BUDGET TALKS INCLUDE TEN
MILLION VIRTUAL SHARING
LIBRARIES FOR SMALL SCALE
FARMERS AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY
MILLION FOR FOOD HELPS TO
DEVELOP MARKET PATHWAYS FOR
MARKET. IN AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION FOR BEGINNING FARMER
AND FARMWORKER TRAINING AS WELL
EIGHT MILLION COURT THAT THAT
PROGRAM. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
INCLUDING THE BUDGET BILLING
WHICH INSURANCE YOU CAN'T
BECAUSE THE SITE AIR MONITORING
NETWORK I JUST ALSO LIKE TO SAY
THAT ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR FOOD SAFETY WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THESE ITEMS. AND ADDITIONALLY
HER INVESTMENT IN THE
POLLINATOR HABITAT. T. S. S.
LIKE TO POSE JERRY DIED DOCTORS
THAT POLLUTE. AND ALSO- WE
WOULD CONTINUE TO SUPPORT IT
CURED PESTICIDE MELFI TO FIND
MORE INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
RESOURCES THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WHY NO. ONE HUNDRED FORTY SIX.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS UNDERESTIMATE AS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES
OF OAKLAND BERKELEY FREMONT
FAMILY ANDRO AND ST LOUIS
OBISPO EXPRESSING APPRECIATION
FOR LEGISLATORS BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR FLEXIBLE ALMOST NEXT
DOLLARS TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
WE STRONGLY AGREE WITH THE
SENTIMENT THAT AN ONGOING
COMMITMENT WITH STRONG
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES IN THE NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS STATEWIDE
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S GENEROSITY THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE. EVEN CERTAIN MEMBERS
STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION WE
APPRECIATE THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN NATURAL LANDS
BUDGET PARTICULARLY THE SENATE
CLIMATE PACKAGE THAT DIRECTS
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION TO THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD THE
PROTECTING FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND RESPONSE TO DROUGHT
CONDITIONS. AND WE URGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO SUPPORT THAT AMOUNT
IN THE FINAL AGREEMENT IN
ADDITION WE URGE YOU TO RESERVE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
THOSE FUNDS FOR NATURAL
COMMUNITY CONSERVATION PLANS
AND HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANS
WHICH IMPLEMENT SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT PRINCIPLES BY
FACILITATING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AT THE SAME TIME
THEY PROTECT WILDLIFE HABITAT
BIODIVERSITY AND CARBON
SEQUESTRATION THESE LOCAL
LANDSCAPE SCALE PLANS ARE
ALIGNED WITH THE STATE'S THIRTY
BY THIRTY CONSERVATION GOALS AS
WELL. AS ITS CLIMATE GOALS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. BLIND OF.
ONE HUNDRED FORTY THREE.
GALLERY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I JUST WANT
TO MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AN ITEM NOT YET
INCLUDED IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PLANS REGARDING FUNDING FOR
STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENT FOR
PHYSICIANS WHO COMMIT TO
SERVING MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
IN UNDERSERVED AREAS. INVESTING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING INTO STUDENT
LOAN REPAYMENT INCENTIVES FOR
NEW POSITION WOULD INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PROVIDERS TO TAKE ON
A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES IN THEIR PATIENT
MAC START PRACTICES IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS OR CHOOSE TO
PURSUE SPECIALTIES THAT ARE IN
NEED ALL OF WHICH WOULD HELP TO
DECREASE THE HEALTH CARE
INEQUITIES HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
COCA NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ALAINA. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS BARBARA GLAZER WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
CALLING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CONTINUATION OF THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PILOT PROJECT THIS IS A
CRITICAL TIME TO CONTINUE THE
SERVICES IF THERE HD BEEN AN
ALARMING INCREASE IN DRUG
OVERDOSES IN INCREASES IN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES. I WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY FOR
INCLUDING THIS REQUEST IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S JOINT BUDGET WILL
CALL FOR ITS CONTINUED
INCLUSION IN THE FINAL BUDGET
THANK YOU. LAINO. ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
TANK STACEY HER AMADO DIRECTOR
OF RAM COAL THE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION WE
SUPPORT THE ITEMS OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET UNDER
REBUILDING AND EQUITABLE PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM SPECIFICALLY
SIXTY THREE POINT ONE MILLION
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AS WELL AS THE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE INTERVENTIONS WE WOULD
LIKE TO SINCERELY THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PARTICULARLY DOCTOR ARAMBULA
FOR HIS UNDERSTANDING AND
ATTENTION TO ALL THESE MATTERS.
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
TWO. SOME OF THEM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR DEL TORO CHARACTER
RESOURCE CENTER. THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORT- THE CALIFORNIA CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS FAMILY
CAREGIVERS ARE THE BACKBONE-
ARE LONG TERM CARE SYSTEM AND-
WE JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS. THANK
YOU. SHE WHY NO. ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX. HELLO AT CHAIR
CANING AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARY SHARED AND I'M
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CARE GIVER RESEARCH
CENTERS AND I WANT TO. GET- THE
LAST SPEAKERS COMMENT AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIANS NEARLY
FIVE MILLION UNPAID FAMILY
CAREGIVERS BY STABILIZING
FINANCING FOR THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MODERATOR I'M THERMIC DATE ON
THE TOP OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
ASSEMBLY FOR- REJECTING THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL TO END
THE LPS PLACEMENT AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
THE SECOND COUNTY SUPERVISORS
ARE ALSO STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
NEED CONTINUE I'M
INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FACILITIES
FUNDING FOR LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND FUNDING FOR
LOCAL PUBLIC HOSPITALS. THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I ALSO WANT
TO SUPPORT- I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE IN GENERAL FOR ALL
THE GREAT INVESTMENTS YOU'VE
MADE A PARTICULARLY THE SIXTY
THREE POINT ONE MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION FOR HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE INTERVENTION I
ALSO AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
INVESTMENTS AND ASSET BY ASSET
HE PROGRAM- THERE A LONG TIME
COMING WE HOPE TO GET BACK TO
YOU- THE GRANT THAT THE LEVEL
THEY WERE BEFORE THE CUT.
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION BUT
THIS IS A GREAT START ALSO
THANKFUL FOR THE ELIMINATION OF
THE AFFECT TASK AND ALSO
FUNDING FOR- AND DOCUMENTED
SENIORS FIFTY PLUS AND LASTLY
THANK OVER THE BEST PLAN FOR
THE FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY SOCIAL
WORKERS- SAID THAT THEY ARE
PAID IN ADEQUATE GREAT AND WE-
DON'T HAVE TURNOVER SOCIAL
WORKERS WHICH GIVES THAT POORER
OUTCOMES. FOR FOSTER KIDS THANK
YOU. A LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO. GOOD EVENING
MISTER TERRY MEMBERS NOT YOUR
MAMA MAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION PARK DISTRICT THE
CALIFORNIA- FIRE DISTRICT
DISTRIBUTION. AND GLOBAL BASED
DISTRICT EACH OF THE CORE OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL OF A
HUNDRED MILLION CRITICAL RELIEF
TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ESPECIALLY STEPPED UP
TO SERVE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE KOPEN
NINETEEN RESPONSE I NEEDED
FUNDING TO HELP. OFFSET THE
IMPACT. OF THE CLOCK. THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE.
GOOD EVENING ALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU AS
A PERSON PAYING AND TO
EVERYBODY THAT IT SPENT HOURS
I'M SURE DAYS AND THOUSANDS OF
HOURS ON IT I AM SHERILYN ADAMS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT LARKIN
STREET YOUTH SERVICES AND A
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THAT
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH EMERGENCY
SERVICES. THOSE FUNDS WERE AND
ARE CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T SLEEP
OUTSIDE THE YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO BATHROOMS AND TO FOOD
AND TO AND MEDIA HOTEL AND
HOUSING OPTIONS. SO THAT. WE
CAN THE NEEDS ABOUT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHICH
ARE MOSTLY- YOUTH OF COLOR AND
LGBTQ YOUTH HELLO I AM FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS HUGE THANKS TO
HEAR KING FOR HIS SUPPORT
AROUND HOMELESS YOUTH. AND
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE INVESTMENTS IN YOUNG
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
WHO SHALL GIVE THEM WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES IS THE
VISION OF CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
COALITION BUT I THINK THAT'S
VERY APPRECIATION FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INVESTMENTS
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET AND IN
PARTICULAR THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. I AM NOTHING IN
PUBLIC HEALTH THE LEGISLATURE
IS INVESTING IN PROTECTING THE
HEALTH O ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
WE WOULD APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH IN EQUITY EFFORTS FUNDED
THROUGH THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
COORDINATED LOCALLY AT AGAIN
ONE EXPRESSED HER APPRECIATION
AND THAT PARTICULAR
APPRECIATION FOR FROM THE
NUMBER WENT THROUGH AS- AN
ACTOR. CHAMPION PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY.
HELLO MY NAME IS AQI PACKET AND
I'M PART OF THE- RACIAL ETHNIC
MENTAL HEALTH THIRTY COALITION
I WANTED TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE SUPPORT IN THE FIFTY THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLAR REFUND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING THE
THIRTY PROJECT THIS INVESTMENT
WILL ALLOW PROGRAMS THAT YOU
CAN MEET THE MAPLE WORKING FINE
AND EVEN EXPAND THE REACH MORE
DEMOGRAPHIC INSURED BY SOME. OF
THE CARPET CARE FOR ALL THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN. MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR THANKS
REGARDING A NUMBER OF ITEMS
DISCUSSED TODAY BUT IN
PARTICULAR FOR ADVANCING OUR
REQUEST FOR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE CREATION OF THE TRAINING R.
AND L. G. B. T. Q. CLASS
CULTURAL COMPETENCY TRAINING
FOR TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF.
THIS IS AN A LONGSTANDING
PRIORITY FOR US AND IT WILL
HELP TO CREATE AN EFFECTIVE AND
EQUITABLE TOOL THAT CAN BE
SCALED ACROSS THE STATE SO THAT
WILL EQUIP A LOT OF TEACHERS
HELP THEIR STUDENTS ARE THANKS
ALL THE MEMBERS AND HARD
WORKING STAFF HAVE A GREAT
EVENING. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON TIM
LYNCH WITH PLATINUM ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF LIBERTY DENTAL
CALLING TO THANK YOU FOR
REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE AND BY DOING SO
RECOGNIZING THE SIGNIFICANT
DISRUPTION THAT WOULD CAUSE
THAT WOULD BE CAUSED. BY THE
PROPOSAL TO OUR STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN SO THANK
YOU TO THE SUB COMMITTEE AND TO
THE FULL COMMITTEE FOR YOUR A
REJECTION OF THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU CARE AND
MEMBERS DO AND MILLER WITH UCLA
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CLIMATE
SCIENTISTS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE AT NINE UC CAMPUSES
CONCERNING THE WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE STRATEGY AND
YOU WORK THROUGH THE DETAILS OF
THE WELFARE PACKAGE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDING TO HELP
SUPPORT THE CLIMATE IN WILDFIRE
INSTITUTE A BOLD NEW AND
INNOVATIVE COLLABORATION WILL
PROVIDE LONG TERM SCIENCE BASED
MANAGEMENT THROUGH
INTERDISCIPLINARY ENGAGEMENT
SYSTEMATICALLY ADDRESSING BOTH
RESEARCH AND POLICY GAPS WITH
REGARD TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND
WILD FIRE. THIS IS A TWO WILL
HELP THE STATE ENGAGE AND
COORDINATE. TO ENSURE THE
LATEST SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY DATA AND TOOLS ARE
UNDERSTOOD AND AVAILABLE TO
POLICYMAKERS THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO.
SCHERING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SHOPPING QUITE CALLING ON
BEHALF THOSE TWO CLIENTS TO
ISSUES- OF PERSONAL BY COULD
SUPPORT THE MONEY INCOME FOR
THOSE INCLUDED COMPORTS THE
TURNER FIFTY MILLION ON BEHALF
OF THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO AND
THEN WITHIN THE SUB THREE
COMMITTEE- THE RETENTION OF THE
PEACE AND PRESERVATION PROGRAM.
UNDER STATE PARKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. A LINE. SEVENTY
THREE. GOOD EVENING MARTHA
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME BUDGET
INVESTMENT THAT WILL SUPPORT
AND SUCCESS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
WE APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
IS INVESTMENT IN THE UC AND CSU
BASED FUNDING AND ENROLLMENT
GROWTH- INCLUDING EXPECTATIONS
FOR INCREASED ENROLLMENT AT
EACH OF THEM AND WOOD FURTHER
ENCOURAGE THESE INVESTMENTS BE
TIED TO CLOSING RACIAL EQUITY
GAP. WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE LEGISLATURE FOCUSED ON
REMOVING BARRIERS TO CAL GRANT
ENTITLEMENT ACCESS ESPECIALLY
AT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
STEP IN ADDRESSING EIGHT. I
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT INEQUITIES
THAT WOULD REMAIN IF WE DO NOT
STREAMLINED CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY SERVE OUR
STUDENTS WITH THE MOST
FINANCIAL NEED WE URGE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARD A
REQUIREMENT THAT CALIFORNIA.
FULLY MODERNIZED STATE
FINANCIAL AID TO ENSURE
INVESTMENTS ARE TARGETED TO THE
MOST FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE
STUDENTS FIRST. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND TIME TODAY.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO.
BUT IT GETTING THE CHAIRPERSON
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
NINE BE GELBART HERE AND ON
BEHALF OF DANCE EVERYTHING WE'D
BEEN COALITION WE WANT TO THANK
THE SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE AND
APPROVAL AND ADDRESSED
COMMITTEE ON APPROVAL OF THE
THIRTY MILLION TOTAL ONGOING IN
ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER BUDGET
LANGUAGE AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY THE DUTIES
OF THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION. THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE. GOOD EVENING FOR TEN
MEMBERS TREAT THE ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARK AND UNITED
CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN PARTICULAR THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE HIMSELF ONE AS
WELL AS OUR STAFF THE BUDGET
STAFF FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
INVESTMENT PROPOSED FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. EITHER
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT AND GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT INVESTMENT WILL
BE WILL DIRECTLY IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THEIR FAMILIES
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS WE. THANK
YOUNG THE CORD TO CONTINUE
WORKING IF YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD
EVENING JEFF MEAL HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSION CREATE YOUR PATIENT
TODAY I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BROADBAND
PROPOSAL I APPRECIATE THE SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE PANT PLAN PUTS
TOWARD THAT. WOULD REALLY ADD
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING- BUT WE
APPRECIATE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL NOT ONLY THE FULLY
FLESHED OUT DETAILS IN THE
IMMEDIATE INVESTMENT- BUT
BECAUSE THIS IS THAT THIS IS AN
URGENT ISSUE- WEEK FOUR MONTHS
TO PASS THIS IT'S FOUR MONTHS
WE WON'T HAVE TO DO THAT
PLANNING TO STAFF UP TO DRAFT
GUIDELINES ETCETERA ALL WHICH
COULD BE DONE. BEFORE SEPTEMBER
IF THIS PLAN IS PASSED WITH THE
BUDGET IN JUNE- THAT'LL HELP IS
LINED UP FOR FEDERAL FUNDS WERE
DONE VERY POORLY DRAWING DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR BROADBAND IN
THE PAST AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
CORRECT THAT NOW. WE KNOW THAT
RATE SUBSIDIES PROVIDE SHORT
TERM BENEFIT AND THAT'S
FANTASTIC BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A
LASTING IMPACT- WEARS OUT OPEN
ACCESS MIDDLE MILE NETWORK
WOULD AND REMEMBER AS WE BUILD
IT EACH PIECE IS ACTIVATED. AND
HELPFUL AS SOON AS THIS BILL.
SO WE HAVE. WE WOULD- URGE YOU
TO REVERT THE GOVERNOR FULLY
FLESHED OUT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE FOR THE BROADBAND
COMPOSED THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN. MEDICARE
MEMBERS MARKET THAT WHILE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION THE FDA
CALLING ON CALLING CONCERNING
THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL
FUND BACKED BILL FOR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WHO CAN DEMONSTRATE
FINANCIAL NEED DUE TO THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE FDA
APPRECIATE THE STATE
LEGISLATORS RECOGNITION OF KOBE
NINETEEN IMPACT ON SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE INCLUDING A LETTER
SIGNED BY FORTY SIX STATE
LEGISLATORS STRONGLY URGING THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION TO
EXTEND ACCESS TO FEDERAL COVER
NINETEEN REALLY FUNDING TO
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AS AUTHORIZED
BY THE US TREASURY. GIVEN
ADDITIONAL STATE BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS UTILITY
REAR EDGES PORTS HARBORS AND
TRANSIT AGENCIES THE
LEGISLATORS PROPOSED ONE
HUNDRED MILLION SPECIAL
DISTRICT COVERT NINETEEN RELIEF
FUND ADDRESSES JUST OVER TWENTY
PERCENT. OF THE REMAINING
PROJECTED NEED INCLUDING LOCAL
FIRE PROTECTION HEALTHCARE AND
PARK SERVICES. FIFTY A LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE THE
GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS THAT
RESPONDED TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES DURING THE PANDEMIC
ARE PROVIDED TO SUPPORT
NECESSARY. TO MEET THE NEXT
CHALLENGES WE KNOW OUR AD THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAX CARRY ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF WEST SACRAMENTO IN
REGARDS TO THE BUDGET SUB FOR
COMMENT YOU'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR INCLUDING THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE TO THE REGIONAL
PLANNING GRANTS HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AM LEARN MORE
ABOUT YOUR SECOND. ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THIS IS CRITICAL
AND WE SUPPORT ALLOCATION FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO GO
DIRECTLY TO THE GREEN MEANS GO
PROGRAM FROM THE SACRAMENTO
AREA COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS.
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS MY NAME IS
OSCAR SAID OF ALL AND I BE
GOVERNMENT INTERVENTION- FOR
THE WHAT YOU KNOW COALITION FOR
A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
GOOD THANK YOU ALL FOR
SUPPORTING BE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE SPOT
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENSURE HEALTHEQUITY IS
INCLUDED IN THE NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. WE
URGE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
FOLLOW THE LEGISLATURE'S WE'D
IN FUNDING EQUITABLE HEALTH
OUTCOMES BUT ALSO LIKE A BIGGER
LEGISLATOR FOR INVESTING IN THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICAL TO INCLUDE
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS ABOVE AGE
FIFTY WE ENCOURAGE BOTH HOUSES
TO PASS A B. FOR WHICH
INSURANCE HELP FOR ALL. BY
TWENTY TWENTY SIX THANK YOU SO
MUCH. A LINE OF. ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN. ANYONE WITH THAT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA JUST
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN THE
COMMITTEE VEHICLES ACTIONS
RELATED TO THE AGE OF SEVEN IDT
COMMUNITY MANY OF THESE CHANGES
ARE LONG OVERDUE AND WE COMMEND
BOTH THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY FOR STANDING UP FOR
THE STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE AND
THOSE THAT CARE FOR THEM
PERFECTLY WE SUPPORT THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS RELATEDI JUST
AS THE DEPARTMENT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING TOOL THAN THE 10%
PENALTY TO COUNTIES. THE LONG
TERM CARE CAREER PATHWAYS TO
SEND THE PERFECT RESTORATION
RELATED TO IBD WE SUPPORT THEM.
IN THE NATION AND TO BREAK FREE.
AND APART INTENT PROGRAM DEAR.
WORKPLACE TRAINING AND- I DO.
THE NEEDS OF MARCH. MATTERS
THAT REGION OKAY. AND EMPLOY.
OF THE DUTY I RATES THE- AND
THEN FIND WITH. THE PROPOSAL TO
ESTABLISH OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY AS OUTLINED BY DR PENNED
SB SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU. I'M TO FLESH
OUT DETAILS. INTERNAL CONFLICT
WHICH THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALIGNED AT. GOOD EVENING
CHAIRED BEING A MEMBER MY NAME
IS MAY I HAVE THAT AND I AM A
MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN IN COSTA
MESA ORANGE COUNTY AND I AM
ADVOCATING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORK AND FAMILY COALITION WE
APPLAUD THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE ON THE ASSEMBLY AREN'T
PUTTING A ONE YEAR EXTENSION OF
CURRENT WEIGHT REPLACEMENT
LEVELS FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND BATES DISABILITY INSURANCE
IN THE BUDGET THESE PROGRAMS
ARE VITAL FOR THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIANS WE
CALL ON THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TO IN FACT IN THE
ACT YEAH I FIND TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA WORKERS TAXES. DO
NOT INCREASE. THE FUNDED
EXPANSION THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK
THE DAM SEN I'M THE ARTISTIC
DIRECTOR OF THE OPEN FIST
THEATRE COMPANY AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
THEATRICAL PRODUCERS LEAGUE OF
LOS ANGELES FIRST OF ALL WE
WANT TO THANK THIS COMMITTEE
AND SENT FOR ESPECIALLY AFTER
THE PROPOSED FUNDING TO HELP
SMALL ARTS ORGANIZATIONS COMPLY
WITH EIGHTY FIVE THE FUNDING
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED SHORT
TERM AID TO THOUSANDS OF
EMPLOYERS AS WE NAVIGATE RE
OPENING. HOWEVER A LONG SIDE TO
SHORT TERM- FUNDING WE WOULD
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER THE NEED
FOR A LONGER TERM SUPPORT
SYSTEM THAT WILL BUILD
SUSTAINABILITY IN OUR MOST
VULNERABLE ARTS ORGANIZATIONS
WE BELIEVE THAT SENATE BILL
EIGHT OH FIVE AUTHORED BY
SENATOR RUBIO IT'S THAT
SOLUTION IT CALLS FOR THE
CREATION OF AN EQUITABLE PAY
WILL FUND THAT WILL NOT SMALLER
ORGANIZATIONS CONTRIBUTIONS TO
PAYROLL ENABLING THEM TO COMPLY
WITH SB FIVE AND CREATING TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS FOR
EMERGING ARTISTS- IN OUR
COMMUNITY. OUR SMALL PERFORMING
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE SERVICE AN ARTS INCUBATOR
LIFTING UP THE STORYTELLERS OF
TOMORROW FROM COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE AND HELPING TO
FACILITATE EXPANSION EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY IN ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT SECTOR WITH THIS
ONCE IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY
TO INVEST IN OUR FUTURE WE ASK
YOU TO MAKE HUMAN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE ARTS PART
OF THAT INVESTMENT BUT SETTING
ASIDE SEVENTY MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR S. B. EIGHT OF.
THANK SO MUCH. LINE FIFTY FOUR.
HELLO GOOD EVENING THIS IS THE
BACK BAR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE ALS ASSOCIATION GREATER SAN
DIEGO CHAPTER I'M CALLING IN
TODAY TO THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING THE L. S. WRAPAROUND
SERVICES FUNDING OF THREE
MILLION A YEAR OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS. MICHAEL IS ALSO THE
REQUESTED EQUITABLE FUNDING
ALLOCATION STATEWIDE. TO ALL
FOUR CHAPTERS OF THE ALS
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA. AND
INCLUDE PROPORTIONALITY
FAIRNESS SUFFICIENT OVERSIGHT.
AN EQUITABLE ACCESS TO SERVICES
SO THAT NO A LESS PATIENT THE
TONIGHT APPROPRIATE CARE IN OUR
STATE. THE NAME MOST ASSOCIATED
WITH ALS LOU GERRICK TODAY. ALL
THIRTY TEAMS IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL. ARE HONORING LOU
GEHRIG WHO PASSED AWAY LAST
EIGHTY YEARS AGO TODAY. WHAT
SIGNIFICANT DAY TO MOVE THIS
REQUEST FORWARD TO SUPPORT ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITH A ALAS THANK
YOU SO MUCH. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
FORTY. GOOD EVENING CHARGING
AND MEMBERS OF THE STATE PLEASE
LET US ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
AND WERE A MEMBER OF THE STATE
WIDE COLLEGE FOR ALL COALITION
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING A SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR THE A TO G.
COMPLETION GRANT OUR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM SHOULD BE ACCESSIBLE TO
ALL AND THIS INVESTMENT BUT
SUPPORT EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE. THANK YOU. LINE.ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS JUDY PROMISE WITH THE
COALITION FOR COMPASSION CARE
CALIFORNIA. WE APPRECIATE AND
SUPPORT THE ONE TIME BUDGET
ALLOCATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL APPROPRIATION
OF SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH
OPERATE AND SUPPORT AND
STATEWIDE ELECTRONIC REGISTRY
FOR POLL. THIS WOULD PROVIDE
PEACE OF MIND. IF THEY'RE IF WE
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND THOSE WHO
CARE FOR THEM THAT THEIR
TREATMENT WISHES WILL BE
HONORED. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN. JUST CHECK.
GOOD EVENING YES UNDER THAT
MODEL- FROM PLANNED PARENT
AFFILIATE THE CALIFORNIA
CALLING THE COMMENTS ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE PLAN WE ARE
VERY GLAD TO SEE THE PLAN USE
AT THIRTY TWO IS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS THE NEED
FOR EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
TELEHEALTH IN MEDIC HOW MUCH
TAKE PLACE AFTER THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. I ALSO- WANT TO
SAY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PLAN TO REMOVE 80% OF MEDICARE
CAP ON LAP SERVICES A MEDIC
CAL. THE CAPTURED DOWN THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
HEALTH CENTERS FOR CORE
SERVICES SUCH AS STI TESTING.
THAT WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE AS
WELL AS THE PLAN TO ALLOCATE A
ONE TIME FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
ADJUSTMENT. RELATED TO THAT
ITEM- SO JUST WANNA APPRECIATE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR FOR
WORKING. VERY MUCH- HONEST
WITH. US AS WELL AS A FAMILY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS- WHO
PROPOSE BONTA ON BOTH OF THESE
ITEMS ARE CRITICAL FOR ADEQUATE
FUNDING OF PATIENT CARE- ALSO
JUST MENTION- SUPPORT FOR THE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
HEALTH EQUITY IN RACIAL JUSTICE
INTERVENTION. THE ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING AND EARLY INFANT
PROPONENT FOR EXPECTANT FOSTER
USED. WITH AND THEN ALSO WITHIN
THE SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE PLAN-
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE
INVESTMENT FOR SURVIVORS.
LASTLY I JUST WANT EXTRA
SUPPORT FOR AN ITEM THAT'S
RECENTLY COME UP- DUE TO SOME
ADDITIONAL CIRCUMSTANCES- AND
IS IN DISCUSSION- WHICH IS A
ONE TIME FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION TO SUPPORT. THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN INSTITUTE
FOR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH LAW AND
POLICY AT THE UCLA SCHOOL
BLOCK. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
MEMBERS THE CHAIR. AND ALL OF
THE STAFF FOR HER WORK. WELL I-ONE HI. SIX ONE. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE. GOOD EVENING
CHATTING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS PETER COMISKEY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS COALITION
AND AGENCIES WITH UNPARALLELED
STEEP AN EXTENSIVE
COLLABORATION AS PIC CORE
TENANTS IN THEIR EXISTENCE YOU
CULTURAL DISTRICT STRIVE
NONPROFIT MUNICIPAL OPS AND
SMALL BUSINESS ENGAGEMENT.
INVESTMENT IN CULTURAL DISTRICT
IS IMPERATIVE AND CAN BE BEST
ACHIEVED BY YOUR SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGEMENT OF THE ARTS
BUDGET PROPOSAL IS CHAMPIONED
BY SENATORS ALAN AND RUBIO AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRIEDMAN
NAZARIAN AND QUICK SILVA THIS
IS NOT CURRENTLY REFLECTED THE
BUDGET AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTED TO BE INCLUDED. IN
ADDITION TO OTHER AREFULLY
DEVELOPED PLANS THAT INCREASE
THE RATE OF RECOVERY FOR THE
CREATIVE SECTOR TO BRING BACK
JOBS REBUILD OUR COMMUNITIES
AND DRIVE ECONOMIC IMPACT THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL INCLUDES AN
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS TO PERMIT
THE INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
CULTURAL DISTRICTS TO AN
ESTIMATED SIXTY TRULY HELPING
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO RECOVER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR POSSIBLE. SUPPORT OF THE
CULTURAL DISTRICTS. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
BOTH THE LAND AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF LARKIN STREET
YOUTH SERVICES WHICH IS SAN
FRANCISCO'S LARGEST PROVIDER OF
HOUSING AND SERVICES YOU'D
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF A
COMMITTEE FIVE ACTION ON THE
HOMELESS YOUTH EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND HOW THE PROGRAM
AND ITS INVESTMENT OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS I WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR COUNTRY TO
PRECISION FOR ALL OF THE
LEGISLATURE LEADERSHIP AND A
SPECIAL THANKS. PARTICULARLY
BITTER PERSON PAYING FOR HIS
LONGSTANDING COMMITMENT TO USE
EXPECTING HOW MUCH THAT THE
PART OF THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM
ALLOWS PROVIDERS LIKE BACK IN
ST LOUIS QUICKLY TO ADDRESS
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS LOTS
OF THESE WERE. RIGHT THE
SERGEANTS TO BE DEVASTATING. I
CAN ST IF PROVIDES AN FROM
MEALS TO EMERGENCY SHOP STAYS.
YOU CRITICAL TRAINING TWICE TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE HIGHLY
SKILLED TO ADDRESS. NEEDS AND
WHEN PEOPLE. FINALLY I APPLAUD
THE HOME A PACKAGE OVERALL AND
IT CONTINUED SET ASIDE FOR YOU
WHICH ARE CRITICAL TO ENSURING
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE AND
PARTICULARLY YOU CAN COLOR AND
YOU IDENTIFY IT. YOU ARE OVER
REPRESENTED AMONG THE EXPANSE
IN HOMICIDES. ARE NOT FORGOTTEN
BY HOMELESS RESPONSE SYSTEM
ACROSS. THE STATE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT. YOU MISTER CHAIR
MISTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JEFF AND RAZA ON
BEHALF OF WITH THE CHANGE OF
PUBLIC AT PROGRAM OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE WE APPRECIATE
THE COMPANY'S LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT FOR THE AGRICULTURE
PACKAGE SPECIFICALLY INVESTMENT
BUT THE THING OF ALL
AGRICULTURE AND MISTER CHAIRS
CHAMPIONING OF THE HEALTHY
STARS REFRIGERATION GRANT
PROGRAM IN THE CALIFORNIA
TRISTIAN INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER WHICH AGAIN APPLIES THE
LEGISLATORS LEADERSHIP FOR
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
ONE CALIFORNIA OFFICE FUNDING
FOR FOOD FOR ALL IN SETTING THE
HEALTH FOR ALL EXPANSION AT
FIFTEEN UP AND WE ALSO WANTED
TO SAY THAT FOR SUB FOR WITH
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS TWO
POINT OH. NOW WE HAVE THE%
LEGISLATURE WE CONTINUE TO
CONSIDER INCLUDING NON I TEND
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS FOR
BENEFIT AND THEN LAST BUT NOT
LEAST ON BEHALF OF WORKER ON
RECOVERY CALIFORNIA- WE- I.
ALLEGE THE CAN TO CONSIDER
CONVERSION OF SMALL BUSINESSES
TO WORKER OWNERSHIP. AS A VERY
REAL PATHWAY TOWARDS AN
INCLUSIVE. AND EQUITABLE
ECONOMY IT WAS A MEMBER HAS
COMMITTED BOTH BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AND SENATOR BACK
IN THE OTHER HOUSE THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE ABSOLUTE CHARM
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE FUNDING FOR THE
UNIVERSAL FOR MEALS PROPOSAL AS
WELL AS MEDICALLY TAILORED
MEALS AND IN THOSE FIFTEEN I
PACKAGE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA NUTRITION INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AND THE FUNDING FOR
THE HEALTHY STORAGE
REFRIGERATION. GRANT PROGRAMS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED FORTY NINE. YOU MEAN
GOOD EVENING SHARE CHIANG AND
HONORABLE MEMBER MY NAME IS
MICHAEL SARGODHA I MADE
POSSIBLE TO THE COUNCIL MEMBER
AND I ALSO CHAIR SAY COG POLICY
AND INNOVATION COMMITTEE. I
WANT TO THANK- THE SUB FLOOR
ENSURE GUARDIA- FOR THE WORK
FOR THEIR WORK AND THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN THE REGIONAL
PLANNING GRANTS- AT MY
COLLEAGUES FROM- WEST
SACRAMENTO MENTIONED EARLIER
THIS FUNDING IS CRITICAL AND WE
URGE- AND ALLOCATION OF ONE
HUNDRED MILLION TO GO DIRECTLY
TO THE GREEN MEANS GO PROGRAM
UP IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA.
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED NINETY
ONE. GOOD EVENING BALLET WITH
THE CANADIAN POWER NOW LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND IF YOUR
PURSE CALIFORNIA COALITION I
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S PRE
TRIAL PROPOSAL AND SAID INVEST
THOSE DLLARS INTO COMMUNITY
BASED PRE TRIAL SERVICES IN
ALIGNMENT WITH FAR MORE
EFFECTIVE MODELS LIKE THOSE IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHAT WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S INTENT OF REDUCING
PRE TRIAL INCARCERATION WHICH I
HOPE WE CAN ALL AGREE IS A
BLIGHT ON OUR STATE. THE
PROPOSAL IS MISGUIDED AND
REINFORCES RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
BIAS CEMENTING A FLAWED AND
HARMFUL PRITAM MODEL ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
CALIFORNIA VOTERS REJECTED WHEN
THEY VOTED DOWN TOP TWENTY FIVE
IT COUNTER TO OUR DEMOCRATIC
VALUES AND LACK VISION L. A.
COUNTY LIKE MANY OTHER COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE WHAT THE MORE
INNOVATIVE APPROACH THEM WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ALLOWS
AND FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY BASED
PRE TRIAL SERVICES WOULD GO A
LONG WAY AND REDUCING OUR
DEPENDENCE ON INCARCERATIONS. I
URGE YOU TO REJECT THE PRE
TRIAL PROPOSAL. BY THE GOVERNOR
THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS KATHLEEN
COOKER THAILAND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SECOND STREET YOU
SERVICES IN SAN FRANCISCO I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT THAT THANKS
COMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE ACTION ON
THE HOMELESS YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING HE SERVICES AND HOUSING
PROGRAMS ANY INVESTMENT OF
FIFTY MILLION FOR ITS PROGRAM I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE AND- APPRECIATION FOR
THE LEGISLATORS LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT AT THIS CRITICAL
PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWS US. TO
ADDRESS IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN ADDITION INSIDE
THE HOME OF THE PACKAGE AND.
SET ASIDE FOR YOU ARE YOU.
PREVENT BREAKING AND I'M
OBSESSED YOU HAVE A GOOD
EVENING. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
NINETY TWO. HI IN THE FUTURE
MEMBERS COUNTY AGAIN OFTEN
REPRESENTING THE EUREKA POLICY
AND RESEARCH CENTER- JUST
WONDERED EXPAND- HEARTFELT
THANK YOU FOR THE INCLUSION OF
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
PROVIDER RATE STUDY. STATING
THAT IN OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD AND IT'S GOING TO MAKE-
JUST A MOMENT IT'LL MAKE A
MONUMENTAL SHIFT AND DALY-
DELIVERY OF SERVICES- Q. I. D.
I. D. D. COMMUNITY AND WE
APPRECIATE SOMEONE CRAZIER AND
RANDALL AND- RUBIO AND RAMOSE
IN THEIR THEIR EFFORTS TO- TO
BRING THIS SIDE TO THE BUDGET
AND OF COURSE THANK YOU SO MUCH
GERMAN TEAM FOR. YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND INCLUDING DESK
ON BEHALF OF JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YEARS COULD JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR EXPECTANT
FOSTER USE- AND OF COURSE
SHERMAN TAINING- YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND- SUPPORTING THE
TRANSDUCER PRINT THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAMS-
AN INCLUDING THE SUPPLEENT-
FOR- HIGH COST CITIES. AND THE-
SUSPENSION OF THE EXTENSION SO-
OR THE EXTENSION OF THE
SUSPENSION SORRY AND HOW WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP-
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
FOR PROVIDE SHOOTS-
TRANSITIONING. INTO ADULTHOOD
SO THANK YOU. LEVINE NINE. HI
MY NAME IS GABRIEL CALLING ON
OF OUR HALL THE PANAMANIANS
ABSENCES THE NUMBER OF NEW
CAL'S SICH IN OUR INDUSTRIES
WITHOUT HOW FROM THIS MANY MORE
INDEPENDENT VENUES AND
PROMOTERS NOT MAKE IT TO THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE ENDEMIC WE
ARE EXCITED TO SEE MUCH NEEDED
RELIEF FOR OUR STATE'S ICONIC
INDEPENDENT VENUES IN THE JUNK
PROPOSAL WE APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THE DETAILS FINALIZED
THIS. PROGRAM PASSED IN THE
BUDGET THANK YOU. SLIDE. ONE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MR VICE CHAIR
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF MY
CLIENT THE COALITION TO ABOLISH
SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING I WANNA
BEGIN OUR MARK BY THINKING
CHAIRWOMAN CRISTINA GARCIA FOR
HER TIRELESS COMMITMENT IN
FIGHTING FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS AND POURING COLLUSION
OF THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIM. AND THE
BUDGET BOB FIVE AGENDA I ALSO
WANT TO THANK CHAIRMAN TEAM FOR
COMMITMENT TO FIGHTING FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA AND
LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST WE
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY. MIGUEL
SANTIAGO FOR SUBMITTING A
BUDGET REQUEST TO HELP IN OUR
FIGHT AGAINST HUMAN TRAFFICKING
IN CALIFORNIA WE CANNOT ALLOW
HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIM TO BE
THE ONLY GROUP BLACKED OUT OF
EMERGENCY CALLS AT NINETEEN
BUDGET RELIEF WE INVITE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY TO JOIN US IN OUR
FIGHT TO STOP TRAFFICKING. IN
ITS TRACKS THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR. JERRY
MEMBERS JERRY DEATH MEANT OUT
THE HELP OF RECREATIONAL
BOATERS OF CALIFORNIA WITH
REGARD TO THE STATE PARKS
BUDGET AND THE ISSUE OF FISCAL
STABILITY HER VOTING PROGRAMS
WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION NOT TO INCREASE
THE BOAT REGISTRATION FEES NOW
UNTIL THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
DEVELOPS PLAN FOR ONGOING
STABILITY OF THE HARBORS OF
WATERCRAFT INVOLVING FUND AND
WE URGE THAT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SET FORTH THE
TRANSPARENT INCLUSIVE AND
MEANINGFUL STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE. SENATOR MEMBER OF%
KOBE PROVIDING CALIFORNIA
THIRTY EIGHT CAN AFFECT AFTER.
I HAD LIKE THE CHAIR UMPIRE.
YEAH THE. YEAH WELL- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OR REJECT- YEAH YOU
THEM IN ORDER STANDARD THE
DEBATE THERE'S- HE WILL RUN AN
ETHICAL LAST MINUTE MAY YOUR
CALL. THE ACTOR RAM. YEAH MODEL.
FROM A ARE A MODEL OF TREATMENT
RELATED OKAY MODEL- THE
INDEPENDENT. REALLY LIKE TO
THANK YOU HURRICANE ARM AT-
BOTH WILL REMAIN OUT OF THE
THERE ARE. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
NINETY SIX. GOOD EVENING MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE PROP UP ON
BEHALF OF BE UPSET. AND DARRELL.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR GOING CORRECT
MONEY TO LOOK HAVE MY TO
ADDRESS HOMELESS. ISSUE LIKE
THIS PRESS OUR GRAD THAT
MILLION DOESN'T FOR SACRAMENTO
RAILYARDS THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE HEAR YOU. A
YEAH GOOD EVENING MY NAME'S
NATALIE READERSHIP COUNCIL
PROJECT BY CAVITY AND I'LL BE
GOING TO OUR BUDGET PRIORITIES
THANK YOU LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND EXPENSE
EXPECTED RED SEA PORTS
INCLUDING A THIRTY MILLION
APPROPRIATION FOR THE
ADDITIONAL VOICE MOBILE HOME
PARK RESIDENTS NEXT IT'S JUST
BEEN A GLOBAL RECOVERY FROM THE
PANDEMIC REQUIRED NOTHING HELPS
IT IMPACTED AFFECTS THE
RECOMMEND EIGHT POINT TWO
BILLION SB PUT. MORE THAN A
MILLION RENT AND COUNTY BLACK
AND WHITE TWENTY MILLION FOR
LEGAL DEFENSE OF ONE OF A KIND
OF WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS TO THE
BOARD FOR FUNDING. FOR THE-
PROGRAM. A TO A HIGH FORTY
NINE. COMMUNITY THIRTY UNDER
THE CRITICAL COMEDIANS. I THANK
YOU RECOMMEND. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. PEOPLE MORE THEIR
RECRUITMENT. ON UPGRADE
ECONOMIC ASSUME ON MUST BE.
USING A- BUDGETING A GROUP OF
FIVE FOR YOU. VERSION JUST
CHECK THIS BY IN THE COMMUNITY
WITH ABOUT. THIRTEEN HELLO
FAMILY CORD THE WHITE OF THE
SENATE REJECTED AND I SCHOOL
MILLION WITH THE TOWARD AT THAT
YOU VERY ABOUT THE- VISION.
BECAUSE THEY AFFECT BE THANK
I'M HERE FILE. BIOMASS
COMBUSTION AND ACTUAL GAS WHICH
IS MOSTLY EMPTY WOULD HAVE. I
DID. ARE PACKED WITH ME WHILE
I'M THINKING STRONG URGE THAT
LEAST THIRTY UPON SUPPORT. THAT
THE RALLY THAT THE ABOUT
COMMUNITY WE ALSO URGE HM FOR
THE BECAUSE OF THE. THE SUPPORT
ANYTHING GIVEN ON THING GROWTH
NOT ACTIVITY. NINE ONE NINETY.
GOOD EVENING CARE I MEMBERS
INSTEAD MY NAY IS MARGARET AND
I WERE VERY WIDE FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY AND ACT YOUR T. P. PER.
I TO EXPRESS MY SINCERE
GRATITUDE FOR YOUR TIME AND
WORK ON THE LEGISLATURE BUDGET
WHICH SUGGESTED MEDIAN URGENT
NEEDS OF SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST AT RISK CHILDREN AND
AGENCIES AND FAMILIES BAND IN
PARTICULAR I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING AND
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT AS AT THAT
DATE POSTAL WORKERS. REDUCE
TURNOVER WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
FOSTER YOUTH PERMANENCY COVERED
RELIEF TO S. T. R. T. P. CARE.
FOR HIGH NEED TO FOSTER YOUTH.
OVERSTATEMENT FOURTHS. AND IN
IN BEHAVIOR HEALTH FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES THANK YOU AGAIN.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS NICOLE RIGHTS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL GAS VEHICLE COALITION
FIRST I WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
CANADIAN STAFF ON THE WORKING
DURING YET ANOTHER
UNPRECEDENTED BUDGET YEAR. AS
BUDGET DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE WE
URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO INCLUDE IN
ITS FINAL PACKAGE I NEAR TERM
EMISSION REDUCTION STRATEGY AS
LAID OUT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN IN HER CLEAN TRUCKS
BUDGET REQUEST. THIS WOULD
INVEST SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION TO REMOVE DIRTY HEAVY
DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS ALL
CALIFORNIA ROADS AND REPLACE
THEM WITH LOW KNOCKS TRACK
BETTER 90% CLEANERTHAN THE
DIESEL COUNTERPARTS AND ARE
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE TODAY.
THIS STRATEGY COMPLEMENTS THE
STATE'S LONGER TERM GOAL TO
ACHIEVE ZERO EMISSIONS BY
MAKING GOOD ON THE POLICY
PROMISED TO PROVIDE
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WITH BETTER AIR
QUALITY INSTEAD OF MAKING THEM
WAIT ANOTHER FIVE TO TEN YEARS
WHEN HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY IS WIDELY AVAILABLE
IN THIS VEHICLE CLASS. WE
GREATLY THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS EFFORT AND THE TWENTY TWO
STATE LEGISLATORS WHO SIGNED ON
TO THE CLEAN TRACK BUDGET
REQUEST LETTER. IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE NINETY
NINE. THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND STAFF
FOR ALL OF YOUR DEDICATION AND
HARD WORK REALLY TO SUPPORT OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IT'S A
REALLY TERRIFIC BUDGET MY NAME
IS JACKIE RETIRED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LINE TO CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND THIS BUDGET
PACKAGE STRONG WE FILLED IN SO
MANY OF THE GAPS NEEDED TO FILL
OUR COMMUNITY. IN PARTICULAR I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING
THE FSA SOCIAL WORKERS TO
REDUCE TURNOVER AND INCREASE
PERMANENTLY FOR FOSTER YOUTH AT
THE BASE SERVE 1100% OF USED.
IN INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER
CARE. ALL THE COVER AFTER G. P.
THAT ARE CRITICAL IN PROVIDING
THERAPEUTIC INTERVENTIONS FOR
FOX NEWS NEEDING A HIGHER LEVEL
OF CARE TO ADDRESS THEIR
TRAUMA. IN PARTICULAR THE CARE
GIVER STIPEND TO RESOURCE
PARENTS WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN
BEING THE SAFETY NET DURING
CONDEMNING. WAS GREAT TO SEE IN
THE BUDGET AND SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND THE CHILDREN YOUTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INITIATIVE THAT
WILL BRING UNPRECEDENTED
FUNDING AND FOCUS ON ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE THERE TO TWENTY FIVE
WITH THE PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION MEANT. FINALLY WE
WANT TO CALL OUT THE CHILDREN
NINE DOLLARS SCHOOL LINKED
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDS TO SUPPORT
COMPETITIVE GRANTS FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
TO ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES TO SERVE
POPULATIONS THAT LACK ACCESS OR
DIFFICULT TO REACH- A SPECIAL
SHOUT OUT IN THE COLD BATH CANS
WHO HAS JUST BEEN. AMAZING OVER
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS AND I
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR HELP. AND
THANK YOU TO- CHAIR KING WHILE
MOST. AND TO ARAMBULA AND-
ESPECIALLY TO OUR CHAMPION
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. RUBIO THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH. A LINE TWO
HUNDRED. AS CHAIR MARKER PRAYER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION WE WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY FOR
APPROVING THE HOMELESS HIRING-
TAX CREDIT WE ALSO WANT TO ASK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AS YOU FINALIZE
YOUR WORK FORCE DEVELOPMENT
BUDGET THAT YOU- INCLUDE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
BREAKING BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM THOSE FUNDS WERE
DEPLETED IN JUNE OF LAST YEAR
AND HAS THE STATE LOOKS TO
EMERGE FROM THE- PANDEMIC
RECESSION. REEF REPLENISHING
THE FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM IS
GOING TO BE ESSENTIAL- AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR EDUARDO
GARCIA THIS PROGRAM ESTABLISHES
A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM
WITH THE GOAL OF PROVIDING
SERVICES TO TARGET POPULATIONS
WHO ARE OFTEN NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
OTHER STATE AND FEDERAL
PROGRAMS FINALLY IN ON ANOTHER
TOPIC WE'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO THE WORKFORCE
BOARD TO FUND REGIONAL EQUITY
IN RECOVERY PARTNERSHIPS. AS
DESCRIBED IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISED WE ARE PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT SUBSEQUENT TO OUR
LETTER OF MAY TWENTY ONE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
HAVE COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON
LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE CLARITY SO
THAT WHAT LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS KNOW WHAT
THAT WHAT THAT PROGRAM WILL DO
WHAT'S EXPECTED OF THEM AND
WHAT OUTCOMES ARE- ARE
ANTICIPATED WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIND A WAY THAT
THAT LANGUAGE MAY BE INCLUDED
IN A FINAL. ADOPTED BUDGET
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. BLINDED.
TWO HUNDRED TWO. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER SIR JERRY
CALL WITH MARICELA CORNIA LIKE
THAT THANK THE COMMITTEE
EXPRESSED HER STRONG WORK FOR
THE FOLLOWING ACTIONS FROM
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE EIGHT FOR OUR
FOOD BANKS THAT PROVIDE
CALFRESH APPLICATION PROCESS
FOR SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. SUED FOR ALL TO
EXPAND ACTORS IN THE CALIFORNIA
COULD ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND
THE ON GOING IN AND ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE CHILD AND ADULT
CARE FOOD PROGRAM. I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR THE HISTORIC IN
EQUITY FOCUSED INVESTMENT IN
THE STATE YOUR QUESTION. THANKS.
FIND ONE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR.
HE. YES GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR OF LORI KAMMER SMALL
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENTED THE OVER FOUR
MILLION SMALL AND MICRO MICRO
BUSINESS- ORGANIZATIONS AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE GREAT
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE AND
HELPING THE SMALL BUSINESSES I
WANTED TO BRING UP A POINT TO
YOUR ATTENTION THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THE DREAM FUNDED
PROPOSAL DOES NOT SEPARATELY
ACCOUNT FOR THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS TO RUN ENTREPRENEUR BOOT
CAMPS AND DYSTER AND
DISTRIBUTING THE GRANTS AS
DRAFTED THE PROPOSED BUDGET
TRAILER BILL EXPANDS THE TYPE
OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT APPLY THE
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSOCIATION EXPANSION PROGRAMS
THAT WE CALL KATE T. H. E. P.
WITHOUT ADDING ANY NEW MONEY TO
THE OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAMS. IT
WASN'T UNTIL LAST WEEK THAT WE
LEARNED THAT THE DREAM FUND
WOULD PROVIDE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS- THAT WOULD NOT
SEPARATE THE FUNDING FOR
ADMINISTRATION AND OUTREACH AND
INSTEAD WOULD DIVERT THESE
FUNDS FROM THE SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM TO COVER GRANT PROGRAM
COSTS AS YOU GO THROUGH THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE GOES THROUGH-
TO COMPLETE YOUR WORK ON THE
TRAILER BILL WE'RE ASKING THAT
YOU CONSIDER THESE ISSUES. WE
NEED TO LOOK AT ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS. SMALL BUSINESS CAL ALONG
WITH SEVENTEEN ASSOCIATION WHO
REPRESENTS THE SMALL AND MICRO
BUSINESSES HAVE PROVIDED OUR
CONCERNS TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE STAFF. SHE YOUR
REVIEW AND APPROVAL OF OUR
REQUESTED FUNDING TO KEEP THE
STATE PROGRAMS- THAT TAPE
PROGRAM ADEQUATELY FUNDED- THE
BILLS THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS- AND
THE ASSEMBLY JOCKS COMMITTEE-
JEDI COMMITTEE ON WE WOULD
GREATLYAPPRECIATE YOU LOOKING
AT THIS I IN ORDER TO KEEP
THESE ARE. PROGRAMS WELL FUNDED
AND HELPING THE SMALL
BUSINESSES- THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE LINE. TWO HUNDRED ONE. HI
THIS IS MARTHA MILLER CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PURGATORY DA'S-
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
ALLOCATION- THAT WAS PUT IN THE
BUDGET FOR ELEVEN HI A PUBLIC
PARK IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
LINE. TWO HUNDRED FIVE. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS ME IN A WHILE A
HORRIBLE WITH A. R. P.
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT TO HIT
ON SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS AND
WE THOUGHT IN THE PROPOSAL WILL
EVOLVE THE STATE BUDGET- WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS MUCH TO
CELEBRATE IN BOTH PACKAGES THE
NAY REVISED AS WELL AS THE-
BUDGET DOCUMENT THAT WAS
RELEASED YESTERDAY INCLUDING
INVESTMENTS IN PROGRAMS THAT
SERVE OVER CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING THE MASTER PLAN AGING
NUTRITION PROGRAM TERMINATION
OF THE I. INTO THAT 7% OUR TIME
THE SUSPENSION. AND MANY
HOUSING GOGGLES WE DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
INCLUDING IN THE PROPOSAL OF
THE FUNDING FOR THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO- PROGRAM FOR
OUR MEMBERS MANY OF WHOM DO
NOT- CANNOT CANNOT APPLY TO
WILL NOT QUALIFY FOR OTHER
TYPES OF PROGRAMS. WE ALSO
SUPPORTS OF THE FRAMEWORKS CALL
FOR THE CALPERS SIMPLIFIED
APPLICATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS WELL AS A SORT OF FUNDING
FOR THE MULTI DIFFERENT SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS
ON THE PHILIPPINE WHICH WAS ALL
OF THE WOMEN IN THE LAST YEAR-
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THIS AND
SO MUCH MORE IN THE PROPOSAL
AND. LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU. LINE TO HER EIGHT. GOOD
EVENING CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE
BILLY ENVIRONMENTS WITH THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
I'M CALLING ABOUT THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE PACKAGE INSIDE
THREE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR SPENDING
PROPOSALS REQUIRE CRIMINALLY
AND DOLLARS DIDN'T EAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOR THE
MULTI YEAR FUNDING PROPOSAL FOR
THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROJECT. WE ARE CLEAN HOWEVER
WE BELIEVE ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR C. B. R. P.
AND THE PROPOSAL TO MAKE IT LOW
INCOME ONLY MAKE IT
INSUFFICIENT TO ENSURE THE
STATE WILL TRULY TRANSFORM THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION MARKET WE
URGE SUCH ACTION ON THE THAT
PACKAGE YOU TELL TO AVOID.
PROGRAM DESCRIPTION THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE.
HI HND CHECK ON BEHALF OF THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND I CALIFORNIA AFTER
SCHOOL ADVOCACY ALLIANCE WE
WANTED TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
AND WE ARE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL
FOR THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE DAILY RATE FOR
AFTER SCHOOL AND SUMMER
PROGRAMS AND ASK YOU TO PLEASE
INCLUDE MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN THE FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR EXPANSION OF PROGRAMS
THE STUDENTS ALSO NEED. CARING
ADULTS FACE AND WELCOMING
SPACES SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND
ACADEMIC SUPPORT AND ENRICHMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND FOR ALL
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BLIND.
TWO HUNDRED THIRTEEN. GOOD
EVENING SHOW PROGRAM WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATES COMMENTING ON
THE K. TWELVE EDUCATION PACKAGE
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
EDUCATION INVESTMENT WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
MAINTAIN THE MAIN REVISED
PROPOSAL THREE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WHICH IS
TRANSFORMATIONAL FOR SCHOOL
CULTURE WE ALSO SUPPORT THE NAY
REVISED ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE TO THE LPS
CONCENTRATION GRANT AND URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL RATHER THAN
THE PROPOSED SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
INCREASED WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE NAY REVISED THREE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN EDUCATOR RECRUITMENT
TRAINING AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND OPPOSED THE
LEGISLATURE SUBSTANTIAL
REDUCTION IN P. E. TEACHER
QUALITY INVESTMENTS. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF THE REQUIREMENTS
25% OF LANTRONIX SITE
INSPECTIONS BY COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT ANNOUNCED GIVEN
THAT GOAL TO BE WE OPEN THIS
YEAR ND TYPE IT CAN BE SAFELY
CONDUCTED IN PERSON ANNOUNCED
THAT IT WILL BE MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER TO ENSURE THAT WATER
PROVIDING ALL STUDENTS WITH
SUFFICIENT INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS AND FACILITIES IN
GOOD REPAIR AS SUCH WE URGE YOU
NOT TO LEAVE THIS REQUIREMENT
LASTLY WE ASKED BINDING
PROVIDED. FOR EXPANDED LEARNING
BE MADE AVAILABLE TO MIDDLE AND
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AS WELL AS
CASE TO FIX IT AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR ALL YOUR TIME AND
EFFORT AND HAVE A GOOD EVENING.
LINUM HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MODERATOR MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
JEREMY SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
SUPPORTING TWO ITEMS ONE THE
AUGMENTATION THE CRITICAL
EDUCATION WENT UP A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU
FOR THAT. AND ALSO. I'M IN FILM
AND TV TAX CREDIT EXPANSION.
BOB WE SUPPORT THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AND
ENCOURAGE CONSIDERATION OF THE
BUNCH REQUEST. OF ITS BUDGET
REQUEST FOR OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS MINISTRY BUT MUST ALSO
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE. THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT ALSO
IMPLEMENT THE TAX CREDITS FOUND
AND DINNER PORTANTINO'S SB FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE. NEED HELP THE
STUDIOS BUILDING PRODUCTION
FACILITIES TO CREATE A MORE ONE
VOTE COULD CONSTRUCTION. AND.
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRIES TO
WORK THANK YOU. ALIGNMENT. TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN. GOOD EVENING
SURE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
FULL OF CRAP YOURSELF BECAUSE
THEY CAN BE THE SOUTH COAST
CITIZENS OF NORMAN'S CHALLENGES
AND REDUCING AIR POLLUTION AND
TOXIC TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPRESSLY AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SIGNIFICANTLY
STABLE FOR THE FUNDING IS
CRITICAL FOR MEETING HEALTH
BASED FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS EXHILARATING SORELY.
NEEDED NEAR TERM EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. WORK TO REPLACE THE
TRUCK WITH NEAR ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS ON THE LOWER. AND
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. THIS WORKED IN
TANDEM WITH YOUR MISSION
OPTIONS BEING DEVELOPED FOR
MATHIS POINT IN THE FUTURE. WE
ASK THAT YOU RECONSIDER
PROJECTING EIGHTY EIGHT
REALIZATION AND INSTEAD SUPPORT
THIS YEAR. ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO THE CARL MOYER
PROGRAM AN EXPANSION VALVE
PROVIDES PROGRAMS FACILITY
HELPS INFORM STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
DEVELOPMENT. AND INSURANCE.
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY. WE SHOULD FUNDING
PER JUST FOR AB SEVENTY IN
SANTA HOWEVER AFTER YOU
INCREASE FUNDING TO PRIORITIZE
NEAR TERM EMISSION REDUCTIONS.
AND WE APPRECIATE SB SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING FOR AIR DISTRICTS. I
THOUGHT THAT YOU INCREASES
FUNDING TO COVER ACTUAL PROGRAM
COSTS THANK YOU. BLINDED. TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. GOOD EVENING
THANK YOU CARE KING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STAFF AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO FOR ALL OF YOUR
DEDICATION YOUR TIRELESS WORK
AND CARE YOU DEMONSTRATED IN
SUPPORT OF OUR CHILDREN
FAMILIES MY NAME IS CAROL
GRAHAM MEDIA I WITH LILLY PUT
WAY FINDER FAMILY SERVICES WORK
STATEWIDE AGENCIES STARTING
OVER THREE HUNDRED CHILDREN
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE. AND I'VE
BEEN SERVING OUR COMMUNITY
VULNERABLE CHILDREN YOUTH AND
FFA PROGRAM TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
THIS BUDGET IS CRITICAL COULD
DIRECT THE MIRED NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR
EXPRESSING OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE FOLLOWING YEAR
LEGISLATURE BUDGET INVESTMENT
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES CHARACTER.
RECYCLING TO RESORT PARENTS.
HOW WOULD RELEASED S. PC CARE
FOR BY. OF HIGH NEED. AND FOR
THE ADVOCATES WORK THREE SOME
OF THE- HER I HAVE SEEN IN
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS. I THINK
INCREASED PERMANENCY FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO DESERVE
CONTINUITY AND SOCIAL WORKER
THEY DESERVED ABILITY AND
LIFELONG FAMILIES AND NOT TO
GROW UP IN THE SYSTEM. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER TO
MAKE A POSITIVE IMPACT IN THE
LIVES OF THOSE WE SERVE AND AT
MANY THINGS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BLINDED. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY.
JENNIFER MILEY WITH A
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
WANTED TO HEAR EXTRACT- ARE.
KEEP GRATITUDE FOR COMMITTEE
STAFF IN OUR AND COMMITTEE
CHAIRS FOR MAKING REAL
INVESTMENTS ON HEALTH AND
EQUITY TO SUPPORT THOSE TWO
ITEMS DID NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
CARE STRUGGLE TO ACCESS CARE
AND COULDN'T AFFORD HEALTHCARE-
YOUR WORK IS IMPACTING MANY
LIVES. ARE JUST THANKFUL FOR
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC HEALTH-
AND IRATE WITH THE IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES BUT THEY'RE
GIVEN THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED- AND WE HOPE YOU ATTACK
THE 10% OF COMPOUND HELLO THE-
EXPANDING HEALTHCARE CLASS
UNDOCUMENTED IN YOURS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUT ALSO
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT- WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. AND SUPPORTING THE
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND ON GOING
AND FUTURE HIERO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS- THANK THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR HISTORIC
INVESTMENT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU- AS WE MOVED
HERE TO CONTACT. BLINDED TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO. HELLO
MILLION. AND CONTRACT RESOURCES
WHEN WE HAVE THE- THE HONOR OF
BEING THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS TO THE C. R. D. P.
AFRICAN AMERICAN IMPLEMENTATION
PILOT PROJECTS AND I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU CHAIRMAN TANG AND
THE COMMUNITY. CORE INCLUDING
NINETY P. M. THE PROPOSAL OF
THE ONE TIME FOR YEAR ASH OF
SIXTY THREE POINT ONE MILLION
pPLEASED WITH THE OUT ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION ASKED
FOR THE EQUITY AND OUR RACIAL
JUSTICE FUNDS. ON THE
TRANSGENDER WELLNESS WILL BE
ALSO UNDER THE- OFFICE AS THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY AND I
JUST WANNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO-
THE CHAMPION HI THERE WHO
SPONSORED. THE THE REQUEST-
ASSEMBLYMAN ARAMBULA WHO HAS
JUST BEEN A GRACIOUS THAT.
STONES CHAMPION. AND HERE FOR.
AND- JUST THANK YOU. I'M GONNA
YOU WANT TO WORK FOR. THE BILL
IS YET TO COME. YOU'RE GOING TO
AMAZED AT WHAT COMMITTEE. WITH
EXTRA CREDIT. FOR THE GOVERNOR
OFFICE BUT THANK YOU. SO MUCH
RAJDEEP GRATITUDE AND
APPRECIATION. THANK YOU. WIND
TWO HUNDRED AND. TWELVE YEAH
HELLO MEMBERS AND BUSINESS-
SOME WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA- I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
NICOLE FOR THEIR HARD WORK
DURING THIS PROCESS- FOR
LIFTING UP THOSE WHO SERVE
PEOPLE WITH THIS INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO SEE THE
RESTORATION OF CRITICAL
SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN
SUSPENDED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINE BUT OUR FOCUS TODAY IS ON
GREAT. WE SUPPORT INCREASING
PAY RAISE OVER THREE YEARS AND
THANK THAT A TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLAR BOOST
IN THE FIRST YEAR COULD BE A
GREAT START. FOR THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY EARMARKED FOR. YEARS TWO
AND THREE OVER ONE POINT THREE
BILLION PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES DESERVE MORE THAN
JUST RATE INCREASES ACROSS THE
BOARD THEY DESERVE INCREASES
TIED TO OUTCOME. FOR ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO
YEARS OUR PAY STRUCTURE SURE
THE WARD PROVIDERS FOR
PERFORMANCE NOT JUST THE VOLUME
OF SERVICES DELIVERED THE
AMOUNT ONE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS ISN'T JUST INCREASES
THE MASSIVE INVESTMENT IN OUR
SYSTEM IF WE'RE GOING TO INVEST
THAT MUCH MONEY AND CHANGING
FUNDING STRUCTURES THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR FROM NOW. WE HAVE THE
CARD AND THE OBLIGATION TO DO
IT RIGHT ADMINISTRATION PUTS
FORWARD PROPOSALS THAT
PRIORITIZE OUTCOMES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WE URGE YOUR
LEGISLATORS TO DO THE SAME
ERROR AND REQUIRE THAT OUTCOME
EXTENDED. IN THE EMPLOYMENT
CREATION OF ANY RATE INCREASES
FOR PROVIDERS SERVING PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
LINE. TO HUNDRED FOR. JAMIE
MIDDLE HIGH REPRESENTING YOUR
ORGANIZATION TODAY AT THAT
CALIFORNIA AND THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
I'M CALLING IN REGARDS TO HEAD
START AND HE CAN EXPANSION WE
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF FOR CONSIDERING HEAD
START'S REQUESTS FOR SUPPORT IF
HE CAN'T IMPLEMENTED WE ALSO
WANTED COULD THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS GONNA TRANSFER
CAMPAIGNING THIS REQUEST ON OUR
BEHALF. AT THEIR PROGRAM SERVER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN
FAMILY THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
PLAY FOR TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
TEACHERS AND STAFF HEADSTART
PROGRAMS ARE NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED FOR HIGH QUALITY
WHOLE CHILD WHOLE FAMILY
APPROACH AND THE FOUNDATION OF
INCREASING RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
EQUITY. RIGHT NOW 60% OF
CHILDREN ENROLLED IN HEAD START
OR FOUR YEAR OLD WITHOUT
SUPPORT IN THE STATE TO HELP
HEAD START PROGRAM SHIFT THEIR
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE MORE THAN A
THREE YEAR OLD AND CHILDREN IN
WRONG HE CARED THE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
HEAD START PROGRAMS AND CRUCIAL
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT HAD
THAT PROVIDE THEIR COMMUNITIES
WILL BE JEOPARDIZED HEADSTART
PROGRAM CANNOT EASILY SHIFTED
FUNDING TO THEIR MORE THERE TO
THREE YEAR OLD. BOB THAT WE
APPLICATION OF EARLY HEAD START
GRANT FUNDING AND AN APPROVAL
PROCESS BY THE OFFICE OF HEAD
START WE'RE REQUESTING SUPPORT
FOR A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
CORPORATION IN THE BUDGET FOR
GRANT MAKE SURE THE LOCAL
PROGRAMS CAN CONTINUE AND REACH
MORE CHILDREN AND EARLY HEAD
START HEAD START MIGRANT AND
SEASONAL HEAD START AND
AMERICAN INDIAN HEAD START WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT THIS REQUEST
WILL BE ADOPTED IN THE FINAL
BUDGET AND WE ARE THANKFUL FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF HEAD START
PLEASE MAKE. PLEASE HELP US
MAKE SURE THAT OUR PROGRAM CAN
CHILDREN. WILL NOT BE LEFT
BEHIND THANK YOU. LINE TO
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. HELLO MY
NAME IS KATIE WHAT ABOUT QUICK
BILL GRAHAM CIVIC AUDITORIUM IN
SAN FRANCISCO I APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT INDEPENDENT
VENUES IN THE CURRNT BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THE DETAILS FINALIZED
IN THIS PROGRAM PASSED IN THE
FINAL BUDGET. THANK YOU. ALL.
LINE. TWO HUNDRED NINETEEN.
WORKING MEMBER BUT REALLY YOU
ON BEHALF OF PDW WE APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON BUDGET
DEDICATED WORK ON SUB ONE
EFFECT YOU CHAIRED SENATE THANK
YOU CAN STOP IN OUR BUDGET-CHAMPION WILLIE THE MAJORITY
LEADER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
OPTION OF ALL THE AYE OPPOSED
TRUMP'S OF ONE INCLUDING
PERMANENT RESTORATION THE
COMPASS BANK HI THE 10% OF THE
PENALTY TO REACH BUT THE
PARKING CONTRACT THE
MAINTAINING. COST SHARING RATIO
FOR THE PROGRAM. I'M HAVE A
FIFTY P. PARTNERS BETWEEN US
THE ARE YOU GOING TO THE DOCTOR
WI CHU SUPPORT THE DOCTOR THE
PHONE YOU SEE PACKAGE. UP TO
EIGHTY VERY MUCH. MINE TOO.
TWENTY SIX. GOOD EVENING
MEMBERS THIS IS WHERE MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE WERE DISAPPOINTED THAT I
REQUEST FOR FUNDING TO HELP
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL DO MORE TO
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET
PLAN THAT WE WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRACE FOR
SPONSORING THAT REQUEST AND ALL
THIRTY FIVE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO SIGN ON IN
SUPPORT. WE ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND THE LEGISLATURE FOR
COMMITTING TO SUCH A SIZEABLE
MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT IN
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
INCLUDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE STATE BUDGET CONSUL PROGRAM
FOR PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
ROBUST FUNDING TO HELP YOU QUIT
SCHOOL TO HANDLE THE WEIGHT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THEY WANT
OUT OF THE STATE AS STUDENTS
RETURN. TO SCHOOL NONFAT MONTHS
AHEAD. THANK INVEST AND THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE.
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PILOT PROJECT
AND MANY OTHERS. WE ALSO
APPLIED INCLUSION OF MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR RAPID WHOLE GENOME
SEQUENCING FOR NEWBORNS. DO A
SERVICES AND COVERAGE FOR
MOTHERS AFTER TWELVE MONTHS
POSTPARTUM. LASTLY WE ARE
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
INCLUSION OF A NEW REQUIREMENT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH CUT RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN CHRONIC DISEASES AMONG
CHILDREN BUT- BY FIFTY PERCENT.
BY TWENTY THIRTY THANK YOU.
NINE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN.
GOOD EVENING MARICA COLLINS THE
PARKING TICKET CENTERS FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES BURKE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
SERVING ON A FULL TIME
PERMANENT FAMILIES AND THOSE
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA YOU COULD BE
VERY PRECIOUS FOSTER YEARS
THANK YOU SO MUCH TURN TAKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK
AND THE INVESTMENT THAT YOU PUT
IN SUPPORTING THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF OUR STATE'S. MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN YOU. I BEG
TO GET A SUPERB SHOW OUT TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ROBERT SAID
LOOK YOU KNOW YOU TO ADOPT ALL.
AND WE- ARE. TO YOURS. IT
BRIEFLY PARKED EXPRESS ON
SUPPORT FOR SUPPORT RATHER- FOR
THE INCREASE IN THE- GREAT
CHILDREN'S HEALTH WORKER. AND
PERMITTED FOR FASTER. ALSO- THE
BOSTON CARE. S. T. R. T. PAY
COVERED. ALL SIX. FOUR AND- ON
THE TRUMP CARE GIVERS TALKING.
TO REPORTERS CRUSH WHO ARE
QUICK TO. SERVING AS A SETTING
UP FOR POSSIBLE. LAST WHAT WAS
TO PROVIDE TO HIS STROLLER
INVESTITURE TO HOW PARTS BY THE
MINISTRY. AND SUPPORT BY THE
LEGISLATURE. IN COMMUNITY BASED
ON. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CALIFORNIA. STERN AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BE STRONG PARTNER
THE INFINITY. OF THE OUR COMMON.
CHILDREN AND HE HAD LITTLE HELP
AT THIS. AHA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT TRULY
THANK YOU. WHY. ONE FORTY. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND STAFF CRYSTAL BONTA
PRODUCING ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF
THE SIERRA MADRE PLAYHOUSE AND
A BOARD MEMBER OF THE THEATER
PRODUCERS LEAK OF LOS ANGELES
THANKING MEMBERS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AN EMERGENCY
ALLOCATION OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SMALL PERFORMING
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS. THAT HAVE
BUDGETS UNDER ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION. THIS WILL HELP US GET
BACK TO PRODUCING AFTER A
DEVASTATING SIXTEEN MONTH
CLOSURE. OF MY OWN AND MY
COLLEAGUES PETERS. AND
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT OUR THEATERS
ARE ECONOMIC DRIVERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
I ALSO ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY
CONSIDER SUPPORTING AND FUNDING
S. B. EIGHT OH FIVE SENATOR
RUBIO'S BILL. WHICH WILL
PROVIDE ONGOING MATCHING FUNDS
TO HELP OUR SMALL THEATERS MAKE
THEIR PARENTS RULES UNDER AB
FIVE. AND CONTINUE OUR WORK
TELLING FOR CENTRAL STORIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
WORK. WINE. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT. HI THANK YOU SO MUCH
READING AN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
INSTALL WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR DEDICATION AND SUPPORT
COSTS FOR THE CHILDREN AND WE
TOOK FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
MY NAME IS STEPHEN EVAN AND I
AM AT THE CEO- HOLDEN FAMILY
SAID THIS IS A FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY. BUDGET STRONGLY FEEL
MANY THE CAT WE DESPERATELY
NEEDED INCLUDING THE MUCH
NEEDED HELP TO FUND THE AGENCY
SPECIAL WHAT RATE INCREASE TO
REDUCE THE TURNOVER OF ALL
STYLES WHO IS SO CRUCIAL. TO
THE SUPPORT OF AWFUL YOU CAN
ACHIEVING PERMANENCY. ALSO WE
SUPPORT THE CAREGIVER STIPENDS
TO RESTORE BALANCE TO A
CRITICAL TO THE SAFETY NET. THE
CODE RELIEF TO THE S. T. R. T.
P.'S WHO CAPPED OFF. WITH THE
HIGHEST LEAD. AND THE
INVESTMENT IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TO CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
AGAIN WE SO APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR HELP AND YOUR SUPPORT.
WITH. THIS BUDGET THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FINE. TWO HUNDRED THIRTY.
ONE TO THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
R. WHEN I STARTED THE NUMBER SO
CAN YOU CAN BET ON. IT STARTED
RESIDENT BETTY ARCTIC WE GET A
LOT ABOUT THE HELLER FAMILY
THANK GOD YEP WHAT BANK BOARD
BUT I THINK THAT A BABY ROOM AT.
I'M YOUR MAN. WE GO THE
AMBIANCE. THE LATTER NUMBER
ANYBODY RECALLS OF THEM THANK
YOU. ONE TWO TWENTY THREE. GOOD
EVENING CHAIRED MEMBERS BRIAN
ACOSTA- FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
COMEDIAN ABOUT THAT- STRONG
EXPORT OF A VERY PLEASED TO SEE
BOTH HOUSES ENDORSING
INVESTMENTS AND THE WORKOUT-
CALIFORNIANS CAN BE DEVELOPMENT
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WELL
IT'S WITHIN A SEVENTY MILLION.
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN A NEW
CALIFORNIA TO GET FIVE FIND AND
ALSO THE AUGMENTATION OF
FUNDING. FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
ACQUISITION FUND BOTH WILL BE
VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS THAT-
CONTINUE CALIFORNIA'S LONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH MISSION
DRIVEN- LENDERS. ARE CERTIFIED
TO. ON BEHALF OF THEIR CAL
COALITION FOR RURAL HOUSING AND
THE CALIFORNIA ROLL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ALSO WILL.
WE SEE A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL TO FUND FARMWORKER
HOUSING WE WERE JUST NOTE THAT-
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO WHEN THE
STATE EXPANDED THE STATE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM. IT COULD NOT EXPANDED
THE FARMWORKERS SATISFIED IN
THAT PROGRAM AND SINCE THEN.
FARMWORKERS OF. BY THAT PROGRAM
WE WOULD URGE. EXPAND FUNDING
FOR FARMERS GALLAGHER MADE
COLLUDED AUGMENTATION TO THAT
SATISFIED IN THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUES. WIND.
TO TEN. GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CORRECT ALSO FOR ON
BEHALF OF HLA HELD ON THE
STATEWIDE AND THE DEMOCRATS
COALITION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE INVESTMENTS IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ESPECIALLY
THE AND THE ACADEMICS REQUEST
TO ADDRESS H. I. B. AT TI
HEPATITIS OVERDOSE WE WANT TO
AND ARE THANKS TO THE CHAIR
AND- COMMITTEE CHAIR ROBBIE
LEFT FOR HIS STRONG SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS. AND
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO HEALTH
EQUITY AND WORKING CLOSELY WITH
COMMUNITY TO TRULY UNDERSTAND
THE NEEDS ON THE GROUND WE ALSO
WANT TO SEND OUR THANKS TO A
TEN MEMBER LOGIN LGBT CAUCUS
FOR CHAMPIONING. THESE REQUESTS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WINE. TWO
THIRTY TWO. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER MY NAME IS
DOMINIQUE NONG AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF OVER THIRTY
FIVE MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS AND
THE STATEWIDE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY JUSTICE. WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE
LEADERSHIP PARTICULARLY CHAIR
GARCIA AND HER STAFF AND FULLY
SUPPORT THEIR RECOMMENDATION TO
ALLOCATE THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE OPPOSITE THE
INTERMEDIATE RESTORATION
ESTABLISHED FUNDING AGREED AT
THE HOTEL THE LEGISLATURE
VISION FOR HOW WE TRULY SUPPORT
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WE HOPE YOU
SEE AN INCLUDED. IN THE FINAL
BUDGET THANK YOU. WINE. TWO
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS LEFT UP IN ARMS THE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
CAMPAIGNS WITH THE MANY EMPOWER
NOW URGING YOU TO REJECT THE
FUNDING FOR THE PRE TRIAL PILOT.
AS A RESULT OF NOT ONLY THEIR
BAD IMPACT BUT THE FACT THAT
VOTER. ROUNDLY REJECTED MODELED
THE CONTINUE TO GO AGAIN A
BURGEONING POPULAR MANDATE THAT
DOES NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT BECOMES. AN
UNVETTED. EIGHT OF THEM THAT
ARE GIVEN FUNDING IN A WAY THAT
GO DOWNSTREAM FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC IMPULSES THAT. WE DO
NOT WANT LONG PARKING
CONTROLLING THINGS LIKE PRE
TRIAL SERVICES AND PROBATION A
BIG PART OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THE SIX MONTH OF DATA THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO ACQUIRE VIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT BECAUSE QUOTE OF
PROBATION ON WILLINGNESS TO BE
TRANSPARENT WITH THAT DATA. WE
SAW THAT THE IMPACT OF THESE
PILOT PROGRAMS WERE
DEVASTATING. NOT ONLY ARE WE
ASK YOU TO REJECT THE FUNDING
ON PRINCIPLE RAPIDLY TO
REJECTED FUNDING BECAUSE OF THE
HUMAN COSTS AND GOING TO TAKE.
DO NOT LET US HELP YOU REVERSE
DECISIONS AFTER THE HARM HAS
BEEN DONE THAT CONTINUE TO LOOK
FORWARD AND MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION OF COMMUNITY BASED
HEALTH ORIENTED SERVICE OR
ANYTHING Mà TOLD THE VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND. HONESTLY YOU
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY WANT.
WINE. TWO THIRTY THREE. GOOD
EVENING CARE AND MEMBERS OF MY
TEAM IS AT THE CENTER AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND A STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK WE
APPLAUD THE SENATE ASSEMBLY FOR
INCLUDING A ONE YEAR EXTENSION
OF THE CURRENT WAGE REPLACEMENT
LEVELS FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
IN THE BUDGET WE ARE DILIGENTLY
TO INVEST IN THE D. I PLAN TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA WORKERS
TAXES DO NOT INCREASE. THE
FUNDING WITH EXTENSION WE ALSO
FOUGHT THE IMPORT INVESTMENT IN
CHILDCARE AT THE DIRECTLY
SUPPORT INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES MORE THOUGHT AND AWAITING
A FAMILY PEACE AND FINALLY WE
APPLAUD THE UNIVERSAL. SCHOOL
MEALS PROPOSAL THANK YOU. WINE.
TWO THIRTY FOUR. HELLO
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS PETE
MCDEVITT AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE BELLY UP IN
SOLANA BEACH THE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN THOUGH IT WAS HONORED
AS A SMALL BUSINESS OF THE YEAR
AND SEVENTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT TEACHER THE PANDEMIC
OUR DOORS HAVE BEEN SHATTERED
SINCE MARCH THIRTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. ONLY TO SHOW
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR GRANTS
FOR INDEPENDENT VENUES THANK
YOU FOR INCLUDING THIS AMOUNT
IN YOUR BUDGET PROPOSAL AS WE
AWAIT SUPPORT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WILL HELP ENSURE OUR ABILITY TO
RETURN TO BUSINESS. LOS A
MEMBER OF BOTH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT ANY ASSOCIATION AND
THE SAN DIEGO INDEPENDENT THE
NEW ASSOCIATION WE STAND WITH
OUR PEERS IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. LINE. TWO FORTY TWO. HI
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
MICHELLE HARRISON THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF THE- ACTIVE AND WE
ARE CALIFORNIA WORK. VENTURA
WELL. AND OUT OF THE BETTER BE
OFFICE I'M THE TO ADOPT THAT
ACT AS A JEFF THE GOVERNOR'S
PLAN. FOR JUDICIAL CAL FOR
SHALL I. AIRLINES THREE DOLLARS
AND A IN THE COUNTRY NINETEEN
ONE AND HAS SIXTY YEAR ON.
BATTERY AUTHORED AGENCY SHARE
TO WORK AS A PRINCIPLE ONE
INDEPENDENT AND NOT TO PRE
EXISTING ENFORCEMENT ISSUE
BODIES INTO THEIR REDUCE FOR.
EXAMPLE SITTING IN A WITH OF
ONE THE LARGEST HAS. NOT
PROVISIONS AND TRIAL INTO ONE
SEVENTEEN PEOPLE INCLUDING
CHARGE OF FELONY. AB 7% MAKE
THEIR QUARTER. NINETY HAVE
KNOWN AS ON THE ARREST YOUR-
LIKE NEW JERSEY AND ALL HAS THE
STATEWIDE RECOUNT AND. YEAH
ASIAN. I BOUGHT A BOOK. CHATTER
FROM PANDEMIC OFTEN SAY ONE
LOOKED IN AT THE BY PARK
OPERATIONS CALIFORNIANS
INCREASE. FREE CHILD. NOT BY
THE PROVISION. RATHER THREE
CARE FIRST APPROACH STRENGTH
COMMUNITY RESOURCE AND HONORING
THE FACT. THANK YOU. WINE TO
ONE. HI MY NAME IS MARK MARCH
OUR ALLERGY YOU SERVICES A
LARGE PROVIDER WOOD COUNTY
EXTRA HOMELESSNESS SAN
FRANCISCO. I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER ACTION FOR LIFE WITH A
WOMAN YOU CAN SERVICES AND HOW
PROGRAM IN THE BASEMENT OF. THE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE PROGRAM.
I WANT TO EXPRESS HER
APPRECIATION AND THING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM EFFORT LEGISLATORS
LEADERSHIP AND MORE OF THIS
CRITICAL PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWS
US TO MOVE QUICKLY TO THAT
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF.
YOUNG PEOPLE TRAMPLE
HOMELESSNESS. BARCLAYS WOULD BE
DEVASTATING IF THE PARTNER
SHELTERS IN OUR PROGRAM DOESN'T
OUR DROP IN CENTERS ARE
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT AND ENGAGE
IN PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
INVESTMENTS LIKE THESEHELP NOT
ONLY PREVENT AND END CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS. THE HEALTH HELPS
ADDRESS POVERTY AND MEDIC
RACISM AS MINAMI THE COLOR AN
LGBTQ. DISPROPORTIONATELY
EXPERIENCE. IN ADDITION APPLAUD
THE HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE AND
CONTINUED ASIDE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE THANK YOU. WIND. TWO OH
NINE NINE. THANK YOU AND GOOD
EVENING TERM MEMBER DURING THE
COOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
IT'S A THRILL TO SEE SUCH A
BOLD COMMITMENT ON THEIR
EMISSION VEHICLES PARTICULARLY
IN THE HEAVY DUTY BASE AND I'M
JUST ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER THE VALUE OF
FINISHING THE LAUNCH OF THE
LIGHT DUTY HYDROGEN FUELING
FACTOR RIGHT THE TYPICALLY
ALLOCATING THREE HUNDRED
MILLION TO BRING A LIGHT DUTY
FUELING MARKET TO APPOINTED
SELF SUFFICIENCY. BY INVESTING
AND THE- LIGHT DUTY MARKET
TODAY IMPORTANT COST REDUCTION
FOR HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS WILL
OCCUR TOMORROW WHICH THEN
CREATES THE SCALE NECESSARY TO
DECARBONISE RAIL MARINE AND
AVIATION. BUT IN THE NEAR TERM
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE PROVIDED
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE PATHWAY
THAT SPECIALIZES IN DIFFICULT
TO REACH POPULATIONS SUCH AS
THOSE LIVING IN MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS SINGLE VEHICLE
HOUSEHOLD. COMMUTERS FOR THOSE
REASONS WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU.
WHY NO ONE OH THREE. THAT. ONE
OF THREE AIRLINES OPEN. RETREAT.
HELLO THIS IS SHERIN REPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND THE OVER
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MEMBERS OF
THE BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
COALITION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS WE URGE
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
INCORPORATE THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BRING CALIFORNIA HOMES
PROPOSAL TO STRENGTHEN THE HOP
PROGRAM TO FUND ALLOCATION OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THIS WOULD
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY WHILE ALSO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO USE EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS WE NOW WORK. WE
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ASSEMBLY'S PROPOSAL TO REQUIRE
THE STATE TO DO GAP NEEDS NOW.
AND DIRECT FUNDING IN A DATA
DRIVEN WAY. SEPARATELY NOT THE
BUDGET THE ESTATE PROPOSES
FUNDING FOR HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO RECEIVE GRANTS TO
BECOME A MEDIC CAL PROVIDERS-
FOR HOUSING. SERVICES BENEFIT.
FINALLY WITH THE COURT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING TO ENSURE
REHABILITATION AND EMPLOYMENT
PATHWAYS. FOR PEOPLE EXITING
PRISON AND RECOMMEND FOLLOWING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU'S PROPOSAL
THAT EIGHTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT.
YOU SEE THE COMMITTEES
LEADERSHIP ON HOMELESSNESS
THANK YOU- WINE ONE TWENTY
FOUR. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ISABELLA LEON SECRETARY OF THE
AFTERMATH OF A MONICA SAN DIEGO
WE ARE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR ALLOCATING
FUNDING TO HELP SMALL NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS COMPANY COMPLY
WITH EIGHTY FIVE IT'S FUNDING
WILL PROVIDE SHORT TERM EIGHTY
THOUSAND A CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS EMPLOYERS AS WE
NAVIGATE RE OPENING AFTER MORE
THAN FIFTEEN MONTHS OF SHUT
DOWN AB FIVE IN CONCERT WITH
THE PERFECT DOUBLE BARREL
SHOTGUN ESTADO HOLE IN THE
HEART OF OUR CULTURALLY
DIVERSE. EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMMING IN OUR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OF CONTINUOUS AWARD
WINNING THEATRICAL PROGRAMS FOR
DIVERSE AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES I DO KNOW EIGHTY
FIVE AND CALL THAT HAVE
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
UNFAIRLY SB FIVE IN STRUCTURE
THEY HELP THE SMALL THEATER
COMPANIES LIKE OURS YOU NEED IT
THE MOST. SB FIVE IS A BOLD
APPROACH THAT BILL
SUSTAINABILITY CREATE JOBS IN
AFFECT OUR LOCAL ECONOMIES. AND
COMMUNITIES WELL BEING. ARE YOU
LEADS THE WAY DOING THE THING
SMART AND LYFT. PLEASE SUPPORT
US YOU CAN. OUR CULTURE SOCIAL.
HUBS WORKING AND FOR YOUNG
ARTISTS DESIGNERS TECHNICIANS
AND PLAYWRIGHT WHO LEARNED
THEIR SKILLS AND BUILD THEIR
RESUMES AT LEAST SMALL
COMPANIES. WE WANT TO THANK.
WHO HAVE SUPPORTED AND ZERO
FIVE ESPECIALLY A FAMILY
MATTER. MEMBERS ARE GETTING
FRIEDMAN. AND CORK SILVA BURKE
FIVE DURING THE ONE BILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST FOR ARTS AND
CULTURE RECOVERY AND I ASK. FOR
ALL MEMBERS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE TWO FORTY THREE. GOOD
EVENING DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS REGARDING THAT- PRE
TRIAL ISSUE FOLLOWING THE
HUMPHREY COURT DECISION WHICH
IS CURRENTLY BEING APPLIED
COURTS WILL BE IMPLEMENTING PRE
TRIAL DECISIONS WITHOUT THE
BENEFIT OF HAVING A FUNDED
SYSTEM TO ENCOURAGE THE POLICE
SAYS WITHOUT A STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK THAT CREATE STANDARDS
OF EMPLOYMENT CREATION THERE IS
LIKELY TO BE DESPERATE
APPLICATION IN THE USE OF PRE
TRIAL ACROSS THE STATE. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE
SIGNIFICANT WORK- TO ESTABLISH
EQUITY IN THE ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE WE SEE A STATEWIDE
PRETRIAL FRAMEWORK AS FURTHER
SUPPORTING THIS GOAL WE SEE
THIS AS TIMELY AND IMPORTANT
AGAIN PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF
THE HUMPHREY CASE- AND- HOPE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CONTINUES
TO DISCUSS THE SUPPORT
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND HOW BEST TO
BRING. FIFTEEN I COULDN'T TO
THE PRE TRIAL SYSTEM THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE TWENTY NINE. ONE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY GERMAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MY NAME. AND
DISTRICT. FIFTY SAME COURT. I
AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF ALL.
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU TO THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING TO
HELP ALL NONPROFITS ARE. FIVE
EIGHT FIVE AS AND ALONG THE
SHORE FUNDING AT EIGHT OO FIVE
SENATORS. IT JERRY IT'S A LONG
TIME TO PUT THAT. AND
COMMUNITIES WANT ARTS MISTER TO
HELP SMALL. NEED YEAH TIME
GREAT NEED IN MARK OR MARCH.
AND OFFERED ME FOR A SMALL
PROFIT PART SO THEY CONTINUE
CONTINUE AT CULTURAL SOCIAL
ECONOMIC. THERE YOU NEED
MATCHING FUNDS AND MAPPED THAT
HE EIGHT FIVE WILL PROVIDE.
YOUR OUR- FINALLY A BIG THANK
TO ASSEMBLY AREA FRIEDMAN
FILLED. WAS THE ONE. ARTS AND
CULTURE CUTLERY AND I AM NUMBER.
THANK. WIND. TWO FORTY NINE.
GOOD EVENING CARE NUMBER MY
NAME IS BEATRICE KATHY GRANT
I'M THE ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF
AFFILIATE JUMP OF FIFTY FEET
NONPROFIT THEATER FOUNDED AND
RUN BY L. LGBTQ AND LATINO
WOMEN WE ARE ONE OF THE 70% OF
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
THEATRE IN CALIFORNIA WITH
ANNUAL REVENUES UNDER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. WHILE
I'M EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THE
FUNDS THAT SUBCOMMITTEE FOR ITS
ALLOCATED TO HELP THEATER TWO
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE I'M HERE TO
SAY THAT HEINE NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS COMPANIES NEED
MORE THAN ONE TIME GRANT TO BE
ABLE TO COMPLY WITH AB FIVE WE
NEED YOU TO PLEASE ALLOCATE
FUNDING FOR S. C. EIGHT OH FIVE
WHICH PROVIDES BOTH PAYROLL
COMPLIANCE THE POOR AND
EQUITABLE PAYROLL FUNDING SO
THAT TINY CHRONICALLY
UNDERFUNDED NONPROFIT COMPANIES
CAN CREATE JOBS. AND PAY
MINIMUM WAGE SB EIGHT OH FIVE
BUILD LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY
SEVENTY MILLION WILL FUND THE
PROGRAM AND CREATE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS ARE ARTISTS
WHO HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED BY THE
FIFTEEN NON PANDEMIC SHUT DOWN
PLEASE PLEASE SAVE MULTI DOES
ALLOCATING SEVENTY MILLION. FOR
AT THE EIGHT OH FIVE THANK YOU.
LINE. TWO FIFTY. YES HI MY NAME
IS A MANUAL THAT WAY I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CASA
THERE WONDER ONE THEATER IN
BOYLE HEIGHTS LOS ANGELES AND
LIKE- MY PREVIOUS CALLERS I AM
URGING THIS COMMITTEE TO FUND
SB IT'LL FIVE. AB FIVE HAS-
REALLY RAVAGED SMALL NONPROFIT
SMALL DINNER COMPANIES AND- SB
OH FIVE IS A WAY TO REMEDY THAT
WE PROVIDE SO MUCH TO OUR
COMMUNITY HEARING BOTH HEIGHTS
WE WORK WITH HOMEBOY INDUSTRIES
THE LEADING GNG REDUCTION
ORGANIZATION IN THE NATION WE
WORK WITH COULD YOU GOT ALL
MEADOW WITH COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS WITH USE AND- THE
SMALL. NONPROFIT THEATERS ARE
THE LIFELINE TO LIFE BLOOD OF
THE CLICK OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND I URGE YOU TO OF FUND. SB
EIGHT OH FIVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINE. TWO FIFTY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR EVENING- MY
NAME'S LUCIEN AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CHARLES R. DREW
UNIVERSITY OF MEDICINE AND
SCIENCE THANK THE HONORABLE-
CHAIRMAN PAYING HONORABLE
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR. KARTI
HONORABLE SUBCOMMITTEE ARAMBULA
HONORABLE CAUCUS CHAIR MIKE
GIPSON- IN THE BUDGET TEAM MARK
MARTIN THE SPECIFICALLY- AND A
NUMBER OF OTHERS FOR THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
HERE MARKED FOR CHARLES DREW'S
MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM- AS
I'M SURE MANY OF YOU ALL ARE
AWARE. CHARLES R. DREW
UNIVERSITY OF MEDICINE AND
SCIENCE WAS FOUNDED IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE WATTS RIOTS
AFTER A COMMISSION THAT WAS
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR PAT BROWN
FOUND THAT- AFRICAN AMERICAN
SKIN- SOUTH LOS ANGELES BUT
MORE BROADLY IN L. A. COUNTY-
WERE EXPERIENCING A NUMBER OF-
WHAT LOOK WHAT I'LL CALL PUBLIC
POLICY DEFICIT. THIS
APPROPRIATE THAT YOU ALL ARE
GONNA FUND- IF IT MOVES
FORWARD. WILL FUNDAMENTALLY
TRANSFORM. THE DIVERSITY OF THE
PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE IN THE
STATE WE'RE PROJECTING THAT.
THIS ONE OUR MEDICAL SCHOOL
PROGRAM ALONE WILL INCREASE
BLACK MEDICAL GRADUATES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BY MORE
THAN THIRTY PERCENT. AND THAT
THIS APPROPRIATION WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF LATINO
MEDICAL GRADUATES- A MEDICAL
SCHOOL GRADUATES BY MORE THAN
20% WE ARE THE ONLY
HISTORICALLY BLACK UNIVERSITY
BLACK GRADUATE UNIVERSITY. IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
APPRECIATE- CREATION BECAUSE
WE'RE CONFIDENT IT'S GOING TO
BE A GAME CHANGER FOR THE
FUTURE OF CULTURALLY COMPETENT
HEALTHCARE THANK YOU ALL AGAIN.
LINE. TWO FIFTY FIVE. HELLO
THANK YOUNG. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU WELL. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME'S MERION
I'M A PROGRAM MANAGER OF BURNS
KNOCKED BACK ON THE PROGRAM
THIRTY FIVE SACRAMENTO IS THE
UNIQUE SCHOOL BASED PROGRAM
THAT SERVES THE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY
WHERE THE ONLY PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES PREVENTATIVE DENTAL
SERVICES AND SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
OUR PROGRAM PROVIDERS SERVICES
TO THIRTEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
NINETY FIVE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
AND HUNDRED THIRTY PRESCHOOL
HAS TACTIC. FOR THE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE OUR- ORAL HEALTH
EDUCATION DENTAL SCREENINGS
FLUORIDE VARNISH TREATMENTS AND
NAVIGATION TO DENTAL CARE WE
WORK WITH SCHOOL NURSES
TEACHERS AND- STAFF TO PROVIDE
OUR SERVICES TO STUDENTS EIGHT
ZERO TO TWENTY YEARS OLD WERE
FUNDED AND SUPPORTED BY THREE
PM G. PLANS. FOR EXAMPLE ACCESS
DENTAL AND HEALTH NET OF
CALIFORNIA WHAT MAKES OUR
PROGRAM UNIQUE IS THE
NAVIGATION TO DENTAL CARE WE
WORK WITH THREE TNCS AND A PATH
TO FIND A DENTAL CARE CLOSE TO
TELECOM AND ALSO PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION AND
TRANSPORTATION IF NEEDED.
AVERAGE SCHOOL YEAR WE PROVIDE
OUR SERVICES. TO TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE CHILDREN DRINK- BUT SHUT
DOWN THE PROVIDING HIM ORAL
HEALTH EDUCATION AND TRIED TO
PREVENTIVE DENTAL SERVICES TO
OVER TWO THOUSAND CHILDREN ARE
PROGRAM IS AN EXTRA SPECIAL
PROGRAM FOR SCHOOLS INSTANCES
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. THANK YUNG
KEEP TRANSFERRED A MAJOR FUNDER
A FAIRLY SMALL. PACOIMA PROGRAM.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
PROPOSED ELIMINATE CANCER
PRESENTS CONNECTS. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME ABOUT THE TO MAKE
A COMMENT THAT. THEN SHARED
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR I
APPRECIATE ALL PUBLIC COMMENT-
REGARDING THE FAIRY ROBUST
DISCUSSION. REALLY PRESSURED
ALL THE FEEDBACK AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR- PARTICIPATION
AS WE CONTINUE TO DELIBERATE
WITH THE SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. OVER THERE
COMING WEEKS AS WE- GET READY
TO PASS A BUDGET ON TIME BY
JUNE FIFTEENTH THANK YOU WITH
THAT COMMITTEE ON. ADDITIONALLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET IS
ADJOURNED.